ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO AND THE HIGHER ED
COMMITTEE TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOSE MEDINA CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE O HIGHER
EDUCATION WELCOME TO THE JOINT
OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TO.
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
OR WATCHING VIRTUALLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. PLEASE
NOTE THAT ALL MATERIALS FOR
THIS HEARING COULD BE ACCESSED
ONLINE. AT A. H. E. D. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV SLASH
HEARINGS. TO START EXTEND A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO ALL THE
STAFF THAT HAVE MADE OUR
ABILITY TO HOLD LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS THIS FALL
POSSIBLE. I WILL NOW GO OVER
SOME KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S OVERSIGHT
HEARING. DUE TO THE CONTINUED
STAYED HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SEEN HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL.
THEREFORE WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER O PEOPLE
THEY CAN PHYSICALLY BE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN PERSON. WE ARE
ALSO REQUIRED THAT MASS BE
WARNED AND THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEM BE MAINTAINED. IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN
PRINT PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. TO
NOTE YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
SEVERAL MEMBERS ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FROM
THIS FROM THEIR DISTRICT
OFFICE. THIS IS PERMISSIBLE
BECAUSE NO VOTES WILL BE TAKING
DURING THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING.
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHEN
WE REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA I WOULD
ASK THAT ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. AND PLEASE MAINTAIN
SOCIAL DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE
AROUND THE ROOM. I WOULD ALSO
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'VE
COMPLETED YOUR COMMENTS OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
ASSURED OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PER PERSON
AT A TIME. FOR THE WITNESSES.
OUR PANELISTS AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ARE MAKING USE OF
ONE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OR REMOTE TESTIMONY TO
STATIONS LOCATED IN THE CAPITAL
AND A AND A FEW LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THESE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ASK QUESTIONS. FINALLY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
ARE NOT PHYSICALLY IN THE
HEARING ROOM PLEASE NOTE THAT
YOU CAN PROVIDE YOUR COMMENT AT
ANY OF THE FOLLOWING STATIONS.
AROUND THE STATE. SAN FRANCISCO
AT THE MILTON MARKS CONFERENCE
SENTENCE CENTER. FRESNO AT THE
HUGH BURNS STATE BUILDING. AND
I IS THAT THE STATE BUILDING
CONFERENCE ROOM LOS ANGELES AT
THE RONALD REAGAN STATE
BUILDING IN THE AUDITORIUM SAN
DIEGO IN THE STATE BUILDING AND
THE ODD A TORY. ADDITIONALLY
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD-
VIA TELEPHONE AND I WILL GIVE
THE NUMBER NOW. THE NUMBER FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT BY PHONE IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR TWO OH TWO
ONE THREE ONE FIVE AND WE WILL
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION AGAIN
WHEN IT GETS CLOSER TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE REFER TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE FOR THE ADDRESSES FOR
THESE REMOTE STATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY YOU CAN SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS VIA THE
LEGISLATIVE PORTAL. AS NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TRANSMITTED IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAYBE READ
INTO THE RECORD. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS DURING
THIS HEARING PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE SIX
SO. AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. WITH THESE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS STATED I
WILL HAVE A FEW OPENING REMARKS
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE SURE MCCARTY. THIS
YEAR IT WAS CERTAINLY ONE THAT
NO ONE COULD HAVE EVER
PREDICTED. AS WE SOON ENTERED
THE NINTH MONTH OF LIVING WITH
A PANDEMIC I AM GLAD THAT ARE
COMMITTEES COULD CONVENE A
HEARING TO HEAR LEARN AND
DISCUSS. THE IMPACT OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. WE HAVE ALL HEARD
VARIOUS ISSUES THAT OUR
STUDENTS ADMINISTRATORS FACULTY
AND STAFF HAVE ENDURED AND
CONTINUE TO INDOOR DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS HEARING WILL
ALLOW US TO GAIN MORE
UNDERSTANDING AND AWARENESS THE
VARIETY OF ISSUES THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION IS FACING AND YET
HERE SOME OF THE BEST PRACTICES
THAT ARE MAKING A CHALLENGING
TIME LESS INTENSE. WE WILL ALSO
HEAR FROM STUDENTS AND LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING
AS THEY SEEK TO EARN A COLLEGE
DEGREE DURING THIS PANDEMIC. I
WILL BE LISTENING CLOSELY TO
ALL THE PANELISTS I NOTE THAT
DUE TO SAFETY PROTOCOLS WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO INCLUDE EVERYONE
THAT WE WOULD UNDER NORMAL SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES. MAY HAVE
INCLUDED AS A PANELIST BUT WE
WILL ALSO LISTEN OUT FOR THOSE
THAT WILL SPEAK DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WITH THAT I
TURNED IT OVER TO CHAIR MCCARTY
FOR HIS OPENING COMMENTS. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA I
THINK YOU LAID OUT THAT THE
OVERALL ISSUES THAT WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON TODAY AND CERTAINLY WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME IN OUR
IN OUR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
TALK ABOUT THIS UCCS YOU'RE
HIRED BUDGET COMMITTEE COLLEGE
FINANCIAL AID. BECAUSE WE SHUT
DOWN RIGHT WING- WE'RE ABOUT TO
START SO THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
OF OVERSIGHT FOR THE BUDGET- WE
DO KNOW THAT OF COURSE ALL OF
THE CALLS SYSTEMS HAD
ESSENTIALLY GO. ONLINE NINETY
NINE PERCENT- 95% I HAVE HERE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME OVER ARCHING
ISSUES I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY- SPECIFICALLY ENROLLMENT.
I KNOW THAT YOU SEE AND SEE
ISSUE- MAINLY A STATE FLAT BUT
WE ARE CONCERNED WHAT HAPPENED
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS.
AND THEN FOR THE MAJOR DROP. IN
ENROLLMENTS IN THESE ARE OF
COURSE OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO WERE TRYING TO GET TO
EITHER TRANSFER. OR ENTER THE
WORKFORCE REALLY WANNA. EXPLORE
THAT WE ALSO WANT TO EXPLORE-
BASIC NEEDS ISSUES HOW THIS
PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED OUR
STUDENTS WHEN IT COMES TO FOOD.
HOUSING AND- ISSUES THAT WE'VE
HAD BEFORE BUT I'M CERTAINLY
OUR HEIGHT NOW. AND OVER OF
COURSE THE CAMPUS BUDGETS FOR
ALL THE SYSTEMS SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO START WITH THE- THE
FIRST PANEL. WE'RE GONNA DO TO
MAKE SURE IT'S EASIER FOR THE
MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE WITNESSES. OUR
FIRST SEGMENT WE HAVE- THE
SENSUALLY THE SEGMENTS UCCS YOU
COMMUNICATE ALL AGES AND
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES. WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK IT UP INTO THREE
GOING TO HAVE FIRST THE UC AND
CSU. I PROVIDE- THEIR
PRESENTATION A LOT LOT LESS TO
ENGAGE WITH THEM. AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE AN
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES- SO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH.
NATIVE RESTAURANT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
RAINSTORM. FROM THE CSU SYSTEM.
LET'S BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE INFORMATION ON THE
IMPACT OF COPING NINETEEN ON
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
AM A NATIVE ROSE FROM THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. OKAY NINETEEN HAS
CREATED UNIQUE CHALLENGES FOR
THE UNIVERSITY THAT WE DID NOT
EXPERIENCE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. YOU SEE A STEPPED UP
TO MEET THESE CHALLENGES BY
WORKING TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
TO CALIFORNIANS IN NEED. I
RESEARCHING FOR TREATMENTS AND
A VACCINE AND BY TRANSITIONING
TO REMOTE LEARNING. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SIGNIFICANT
EFFORTS IN INCREDIBLE
FLEXIBILITY SHOWN BY OUR
CAMPUSES. PARTICULARLY BY OUR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF TO
QUICKLY TRANSITION THIS PAST
SPRING. FOR RESIDENTIAL IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO REMOTE
LEARNING. ALL WE HAVE
MAINTAINED THE FOCUS ON HOW TO
BEST DELIVER COURSES TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION.
IN SPITE OF PANDEMIC RELATED.
AWARE OKAY. SORRY BUT YOU ALSO
NEED TO PUT UP TO WEAR THE MASK.
YOU KNOW GOOD. ARE WE MAINTAIN
THE FOCUS ON HOW TO BEST
DELIVER COURSES TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION IN SPITE
OF PANDEMIC RELATED CONSTRAINTS
THAT HELP KEEP ALL OF US SAFE.
CAMPUSES RAMPED UP EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH THE
NECESSARY TECHNOLOGY AND
ACADEMIC AND COUNSELING
SUPPORT. HELPS THE STUDENTS
SUCCEED IN THIS ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN HIGHLY FOCUSED ON STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS TO WORK QUICKLY TO
DISTRIBUTE A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN KERR'S ACT
FUNDING DIRECTLY TO STUDENTS
SYSTEM WIDE. WE ALSO AUGMENTED
THESE BONDS WITH PHILANTHROPIC
COMMITMENTS FROM EACH OF THE
CAMPUSES. OVER THESE PAST SEVEN
MONTHS WITHOUT A DOUBT THE
WALKING TO USING CORPORATE
GUIDANCE FROM OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. THIS SUMMER
HE WORKED DILIGENTLY TO IMPROVE
THE DELIVERY OF INSTRUCTION.
AND CAMPUSES DEVELOP DETAILED
AND THOUGHTFUL FALL PLANS
INCLUDING ROBUST TESTING
PROTOCOLS THAT ENABLE US TO
BRING BACK ON THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS BACK TO OUR CAMPUSES.
AFTER TESTING TENS OF THOUSANDS
BOTH SYMPTOMATIC AND
ASYMPTOMATIC STUDENTS. UC
CAMPUSES HAVE GENERALLY SEEN
POSITIVITY RATES IN THE RANGE
OF ZERO POINT ONE PERCENT. TO
ZERO POINT FIVE PERCENT. A
FRACTION OF THE STATE'S
FOURTEEN DAY AVERAGE OF THREE
POINT 4% THIS IS A TESTAMENT TO
THE COMMITMENT AND HARD WORK OF
YOU SEE FACULTY STUDENTS AND
STAFF. DESPITE OVER NINETEEN
HAS HAD SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL
IMPACT ON THE UNIVERSITY. FROM
MID MARCH THROUGH OCTOBER WE
ESTIMATED TOTAL FISCAL IMPACT
OF NEARLY TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. OF THIS AMOUNT
LOST REVENUE REPRESENTS TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS AN
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC ARE ESTIMATED AT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
REVENUE LOSSES HAVE BEEN
PRIMARILY FELT BY OUR MEDICAL
CENTERS IN IN OUR AUXILIARY
OPERATIONS SUCH AS HOUSING AND
DINING. ADDITIONAL EXPENSES
INCLUDING TECHNOLOGY PP
ADDITIONAL CLEANING TESTING AND
TRACING INFRASTRUCTURE. WHICH
WILL LIKELY GROW AS CAMPUSES
SPEND MILLIONS ON TESTING EVERY
MONTH TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF THE UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
A RELATIVELY QUICK RECOVERY IN
OUR MEDICAL CENTERS WITH
AVERAGE NUMBER OF PATIENTS
NEARLY EQUALING PRE COVERED
RATES. HOWEVER WE REMAIN
CAUTIOUS ABOUT THIS RECOVERY AS
WE WATCH CASES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND IN CALIFORNIA SPIKE
TO RECORD HIGHS. OUR MEDICAL
CENTERS ARE TAKING EXTRA STEPS
TO ENSURE WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY IF WE EXPERIENCE A
SIMILAR SURGE THIS WINTER.
DURING THIS TIME WE WERE ABLE
TO GROW OUR TELEMEDICINE
PLATFORM IN CANAL PROVIDE
EXPANDED MEDICAL CARE TO
PATIENTS IN MORE RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE.
STILL WE ARE UNLIKELY TO
RECOVER LOST REVENUE DURING
REDUCED OPERATIONS AND THIS
WILL REDUCE THE MEDICAL CENTER
RESERVES. THESE RESERVES COULD
HAVE BEEN SPENT ON OTHER
PRIORITIES SUCH AS SEISMIC
RETROFITS. HOUSING A DYING
REVENUE ON THE OTHER HAND HAS
NOT SEEN THE SAME RECOVERY IS
THE MEDICAL CENTERS GIVEN THE
REDUCED NUMBER OF STUDENTS
LIVING ON CAMPUS. GENERALLY
SPEAKING WE ARE LIMITING IT
LIMITING OCCUPANCY TO ONE
STUDENT PER BEDROOM. WHERE
THERE IS A COMMUNAL BATHROOM.
AND WITH A SLIGHTLY HIGHER
DENSITY IN APARTMENT STYLE
UNITS. A HOUSING UNITS VERY BY
CAMPUS FROM A LOW OF 10%
OCCUPANCY TO HIRE 57% DEPENDING
ON THE TYPES OF HOUSING ON THE
CAMPUS HOUSING POP PORTFOLIO.
AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS.
THE DEMAND FOR HOUSING REMAINS
VERY STRONG AND WE EXPECT THAT
HOW I CAN SEE IN THESE REVENUES
WILL QUICKLY REBOUND WHEN IT IS
SAFE TO BRING MORE STUDENTS
BACK TO CAMPUS. WE ALSO FACE
STRUCTURAL FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
AND ANTICIPATE A LONGER TIME TO
RECOVER. THE UNIVERSITY
RECEIVED A THREE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET CUTS FROM
THE STATE THIS YEAR. AND THIS
PANDEMIC RECESSION IS
DIFFERENT- THAN WHAT WE FACED
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION WHEN
WE WERE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THE
STRENGTH OF OUR OTHER REVENUE
SOURCES. INCLUDING A MEDICAL
CENTERS ARE IDEAL REYES AND OUR
RESEARCH ENTERPRISE AS BUDGET
CUTS WERE MADE BY THE STATE. WE
HAVE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
PROACTIVE STEPS TO MITIGATE THE
FINANCIAL IMPACTS MAINTAIN THE
QUALITY OF THE UNIVERSITY. AND
TO MINIMIZE ADVERSE IMPACTS ON
JOBS WHICH WILL BE CRITICAL TO
THE STATE YOU'RE COVERED. YOU
STRATEGIES HAVE INCLUDED
SECURING A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR LOW INTEREST
TAXABLE BOND TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL WORKING CAPITAL TO
OUR CAMPUSES. HI VISION OF OUR
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIOS TO
INCREASE LIQUIDITY. DEFERRAL OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
EMPLOYERS SOCIAL SECURITY
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE THIS YEAR
WHICH WILL ROLL REPAY AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND HIRING
FREEZES AND THE WHOLE THING OF
SALARY ACTIONS TO CURB
EXPENDITURE GROWTH. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDING IMPOSSIBLE
BENEFICIAL TAX CHANGES FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. AS AN EXAMPLE
IF FEDERAL TAX CHANGES OCCURRED
ONCE AGAIN ALLOWED US TO DO
ADVANCE REFUNDING. UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COULD BE FINED UP TO
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS
WHICH WOULD YIELD PRESENT VALUE
SAVINGS ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS. AT
THE ACADEMIC YEAR COMMENCES
FALL ENROLLMENT YOU SEE REMAIN
VERY STRONG. MAINTAINING AND
INCREASING ENROLLMENT AT UC
STANDS IN SHARP CONTRAST WITH
THE NATIONAL NUMBERS WERE
OVERALL ENROLLMENT IS DOWN
ABOUT 4% AND FRESHMAN ROMAN
DOWN AS MUCH AS 16% ACCORDING
TO THE WALL STREET JOURNAL. AS
OF OCTOBER THIRTIETH. YOU SEE
PROJECTED TO BE ABOVE TARGET
FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
ENROLLMENTS. ALTHOUGH THE LOCAL
LAST YEAR'S LEVEL- NONRESIDENT
ROMANS BY A RANGE OF 224% AT
BOTH THE UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE LEVELS WE'VE SEEN MORE
CLASS FOR DEFERRALS OR READ
MISSION. WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE GIVEN PANDEMIC
IN OTHER IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS FROM STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES. WELL AS MODEST
DECLINE IN NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS WILL HAVE TO HAPPEN
CAMPUS BUDGET IT IS NOT AS
CONCERNING AS A PREDICTIONS OF
SOME OF THE MODELS THAT WE
PREPARED OVER THE SUMMER. SO
CLOSING OUR STRENGTH RESILIENCE
WILL CARRY THE UNIVERSITY
THROUGH THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH ALL OF YOU IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. TO DEVELOP A
COLLABORATIVE PLAN FOR CALVARY.
OUR CAMPUSES ARE THOROUGHLY
ENJOYED THOROUGHLY ENGAGED IN
SCENARIO PLANNING ON THE
RECOVERY. WE EXPECT MANY
POSITIVE TRENDS WILL CONTINUE
IN POST PANDEMIC I'M FIVE
MINUTES. I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT WE
WILL EMERGE AS AN EVEN STRONGER
INSTITUTION AS A RESULT OF THE
DECISIONS AND ACTIONS TAKEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU WHAT WILL CERTAINLY COME
BACK TO YOU NOW I WANNA HEAR
FROM RYAN STORM WITH THE CSU.
YES HEY I RYAN WE BELIEVE IF
YOU JUST START SPEAKING THERE
WILL PICK UP YOUR VOICE AND THE
CAMEL WILL GO TO YOU SO. PLEASE
BEGIN. IT IS A PHYSICAL BUTTON
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE DEVICE
BEHIND THE- NEWS THERE WE GO I
THINK I'VE I THINK I'VE FIGURED
IT OUT. ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE BETWEEN
ENSURE MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I THINK I JUST FIGURED
OUT I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME ON
THAT END. YES OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU OKAY TECHNOLOGY
IT IS SO MY NAME IS RYAN STORM
I'M THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET FOR THE
CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO YOU TODAY. I'LL BRIEFLY
SHARE WITH YOU THE POSITIVE AND
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON STUDENTS EMPLOYEES.
STUDENT SUCCESS AND UNIVERSITY
FINANCES. SO THROUGHOUT THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES CHANCER
WHITE HAS GUIDED OUR COBIT
NINETEEN RESPONSE BY OUR TWIN
NOR STARS SAFEGUARDING THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
STUDENTS FACULTY STAFF AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. AND
MAINTAINING OUR STUDENTS
PROGRESS 2 DEGREES. SO IN MARCH
THE SINCE YOU MADE THE MASSIVE
PIVOT TO APPEAR TO VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTION. TRANSITIONING
SEVENTY THOUSAND CLASSES
TOGETHER WITH STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES TO VIRTUAL REALITIES.
TODAY LESS THAN 7% IN A PERSON
COURSE OFFERINGS FOR FALL
TWENTY NINETEEN ARE BEING
DELIVERED IN PERSON IN FALL
TWENTY TWENTY. WHEN WE MADE THE
BIG SHIFT TO VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTION IN MARCH WE TOOK
GREAT CARE TO MITIGATE THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT TO OUR
STUDENTS. HERE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES WE MAINTAINED ON
CAMPUS HOUSING IN THE SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS WITH NO
PLACE NO SAFE PLACE TO GO. WE
DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND NEW LAPTOPS AND
OFFERED MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
WIFI HOT SPOTS TO HELP ADDRESS
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. AND
INVESTMENT OF MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
IS IN ADDITION TO THE THOUSANDS
OF LAPTOPS AND TABLETS ALREADY
ON HAND THAT OUR CAMPUS IS MADE
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS. WE
CONTINUE TO MEET OUR STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS WITH NO CONTACT
FOOD DISTRIBUTION. AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURE. CAMPUS COUNSELING
SERVICES WERE ARE OFFERED
VIRTUALLY SERVING STUDENTS
THROUGH INDIVIDUAL AND GROUP
SESSIONS AS WELL AS OFFERING-
PROGRAMMING CENTERED AROUND
COPING WITH UNCERTAINTY AND
ANXIETY. BY SHIFTING TO A
VIRTUAL MODALITY EARLY AT ALL
ALLOWED US MORE TIME TO PREPARE
FOR PRIMARILY VIRTUAL FALL.
FACULTY WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ENHANCE TEACHING AND LEARNING.
ACROSS OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FACULTY MEMBERS OR
MORE THAN 60% OF OUR TEACHING
FORCE CHOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND HOURS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND PROGRAMMING
OVER THE SUMMER. WHAT WE ARE
PLEASED WITH THE EFFORTS OF
THOSE COMMITTED TO ENSURING OUR
STUDENTS PROGRESS TO DEGREE.
WE'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC'S ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN IN THE IMPACT THIS HAS
HAD ON OUR VALUED EMPLOYEES. SO
IN AN EFFORT TO EASE THE IMPACT
THE CSU IMPLEMENTED MULTIPLE
APPROACHES. USE OF RESERVES FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY.
INSTALLING NUMEROUS COST
CUTTING MEASURES AND DEVELOPING
OTHER CREATIVE WAYS TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF COBIT AND AVOID
LAYOFFS. THESE EFFORTS HAVE FOR
THE TIME BEING UNMITIGATED ANY
SYSTEM WIDE LAYOFFS OR FOR LOW
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER AT THE CAMPUS
LEVEL DUE TO THEIR UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
NOTICES OF LAYOFF. AN ACTUAL
LAYOFFS. UNFORTUNATELY A CSU
CAMPUSES HAVE HAD TO REDUCE
BOTH MANAGEMENT POSITIONS
APPROXIMATE A HUNDRED OF THOSE
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF A
PANDEMIC. AND ALSO REPRESENTED
POSITIONS THAT WORK IN OUR NON
CORE PROGRAM AREAS. THE NON
CORE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN HIT THE
HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC WITH
THE MAJORITY THE LAYOFF PLAN
NOTICES BEING THE RESULT OF A
LACK OF WORK. NOW THE NON CORE
PROGRAM. PHYSICIANS ARE
SUPPORTED BY REVENUES SUCH AS-
A SUGGESTED HOUSING FEES BILL
PLANS PARKING AND RETAIL SALES.
THESE OPERATIONS OBVIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC DUE TO THE LACK OF
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS. PROXIMATE
THREE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR LAYOFF
NOTICES WERE INITIALLY SENT TO
EMPLOYEES OF APPROX UP OUT OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND SETIA PLOYS. AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES WE HAVE
RESCINDED NINETY OF THOSE
NOTICES. NO ONE CIRCUMSTANCES
HAVE PERMITTED THIS ISSUE HAS
REASSIGNED CURRENT EMPLOYEES TO
OTHER CLASSIFICATIONS US
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF NOTICES.
AS AN EXAMPLE CINEMA STATE THEY
ISSUED NOTICES TO- FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS AFTER CLOSING THEIR
FOOD SERVICE OPERATIONS. BUT
WE'RE ABLE TO REASSIGN THIRTEEN
EMPLOYEES TO OTHER
CLASSIFICATIONS AND ANOTHER
NINE EMPLOYEES WERE PROVIDED
PART TIME WORK AS NEW WORK
BECAME AVAILABLE. CURRENTLY THE
CSU IS IN THE MEET AND CONFER
PERIOD AS OUTLINED IN THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AT EIGHT CAMPUSES TO
BE CLEAR NO REPRESENTED
LAYOFFS. HAVE BEEN FINALIZED.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS
TO MITIGATE THE LAYOFFS THIS
ISSUE HAS ALSO IMPLEMENTED
MULTIPLE PAID LEAVE PROGRAMS TO
KEEP EMPLOYEES IN THEIR
POSITIONS. THESE PROGRAMS
FOCUSED ON EMPLOYEES AGES SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER. OR PLOYS WITH
PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS. ALSO
PROVIDED COVERAGE FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE UNABLE TO
WORK REMOTELY. OR PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO DEAL WITH
COVIDIEN PACKS SUCH AS CHILD
CARE ILLNESS OR THE CARE OF A
FAMILY MEMBER. WE'RE STILL
TABULATING THE DATA BUT A
PRELIMINARY FIGURES INDICATE
THAT MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED EMPLOYEES UTILIZE
A COMBINATION OR ALL OF THE
PAID LEAVE PROGRAM TO SEE IF
YOU OFFERED. ON AVERAGE
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYEES TOOK AN
ESTIMATED. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO HOURS OF LEAVE BETWEEN THE
PERIODS OF MARCH EIGHTEENTH AND
JUNE THIRTIETH. ALSO ON THE
LEAVE PROGRAMS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES THAT
EMPLOYEES LIKE OURS- THAT HAVE
EMPLOYEES ELIGIBLE FOR THE
FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE. I HAD TO
PROVIDE THE FEDS PROVIDED TO
TWO THIRDS OF EMPLOYEES PAY BUT
THE A CHANCE ARE MADE THE
DECISION TO INSTEAD PROVIDE
1100% PAY. NOW MOVING TO
ENROLLMENT IN THOSE LEVELS SO
DESPITE THE UNPRECEDENTED
EVENTS OF TWENTY TWENTY OUR
STUDENTS HAVE PERSISTED AT
REMARKABLE RATES OR MANY
INSTITUTIONS NATIONWIDE HAVE
REPORTED A DECLINE IN
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT THE
CSU HASN'T ROLLED ITS LARGEST
EVER STUDENT BODY. THE TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES COLLECTIVELY
ENROLLED THE HIGHEST NUMBEROF
STUDENTS IN OUR HISTORY NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHICH IS A
THREE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
SPEEDS GREATER THAN FALL TWENTY
NINETEEN. ADDITIONALLY THE
SINCE YOU GRADUATED A RECORD
NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN SPRING
TWENTY TWENTY. BY CONFERRING
1-002-800-0900 TWENTY FIVE
DEGREES. INCLUDING. ONE HUNDRED
NINE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY BACCALAUREATE DEGREES. IN
MAY ONLY TWO MONTHS AFTER
PIVOTING TO A VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTION IN MARCH THE CSU
ANNOUNCED THAT FALL COURSES
WOULD ALSO BE VIRTUAL. WE
BELIEVE MAKING THAT DECISION
EARLY ALLOWED STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES- TO PLAN ACCORDINGLY.
IT PROVIDES CERTAINTY AT A TIME
OF TREMENDOUS UNCERTAINTY. NOW
ANOTHER BRIGHT SPOT OF THE C.
ISSUE IS THE CONTINUED SUCCESS
SUCCESS OF GRADUATION TO SHIP
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WHICH
CONTINUES TO INCREASE
GRADUATION RATES AND NARROW
EQUITY GAPS EFFORT TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE NEEDS.
L. LAST MONTH DOCTOR LORD
BLANCHARD GAVE A PRESENTATION
HIGHLIGHTING THE CONTINUED
IMPROVEMENTS MADE AS A RESULT
OF. THE SUPPORT AND INVESTMENT
BY THE STATE. HIS PRESENTATION
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR WEBSITE AND
A FULL REPORT WILL BE PRESENTED
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY.
IN THE MEANTIME I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY POINTS AND
DOCTOR BLANCHARD'S PRESENTATION.
SO FIRST STARTING WITH FIRST
TIME STUDENTS. BEFORE
GRADUATION RATE FOR FIRST TIME
STUDENTS INCREASED BY THIRTY
INCREASED 231% COMPARED 219%
THE LAUNCH INITIATIVE FIVE
YEARS AGO. THE SIX OUR
GRADUATION RATE FOR THOSE FIRST
TIME STUDENTS REMAINS AT 62% IN
ON AVERAGE FIRST TIME STUDENTS
ARE TAKING MORE UNITS PER TERM
ALMOST FIFTEEN UNITS PER TERM.
THAT'S THE MOST THAT WE'VE EVER
HAD. IN OUR- EXPERIENCE.
ANOTHER NOTABLE MILESTONE
ESPECIALLY RELEVANT TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. SIXTY RECORDED A
RECORD RETENTION RATE EIGHTY
FIVE POINT 5% OF FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS RETURN TO CAMPUS FOR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY. ALSO SEEING
PROGRESS WITH TRANSFER
STUDENTS. WHICH HERE GRADUATION
RATE FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS HAS
INCREASED 2404% JUST SHY OF OUR
45% GOAL TARGET FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE FOR YOUR GRAD
RATE FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS HAS
INCREASED 279% AS CHANCER WHITE
HAS SAID QUOTE A LOT OF CREDIT
GOES TO THE STUDENTS FOR THEIR
PERSISTENCE AND FLEXIBILITY
TRANSITION TO VIRTUAL
INSTRUCTION. IN SUPPORT ARE
MADE NECESSARY BY THE PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THE HARD WORK AND DEDICATION OF
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF WHO
OVERCAME UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES TO ADVANCE THE. TO
OUR FINANCES NOT SO GOOD OF A
ROSY STORY HERE. SO WE SERVING
CAMPUSES DURING THE SPRING
TERM. AND AGAIN FOR THIS FALTER.
AND ASK FOR THEIR ESTIMATES OF
CODED RELATED REVENUE LOSSES
AND COSTS FOR ALL FUND SOURCES.
ALL TOGETHER IT IS JUST OVER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACT AND THAT FIGURE
INCLUDES THE RESULTING WHAT TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MILLION.
DOLLAR ONGOING STATE
APPROPRIATION REDUCTION IN THIS
CURRENT YEAR. CAMPUSES IN THE
SYSTEM OFFICE CONTINUE TO SEEK
WAYS TO DAMP TO DAMPEN THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS UP AT
THIS UNPRECEDENTED TIME. WE
HAVE INITIATED A HIRING CHILL
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. WE
STOPPED ALL TRAVEL AND HAVE CUT
OPERATIONAL COSTS WHEREVER WE
CAN. WHILE WE HAVE FAILED
SAVINGS IN AREAS SUCH AS
UTILITIES OTHER COSTS OF HAVE
NECESSARILY INCREASED SUCH AS A
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
SANITATION FACILITY
MODIFICATIONS FOR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND OF COURSE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
EQUIPMENT SOFTWARE AND RELATED
SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES REPORT THEY PLAN
TO DRAW ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
POINT FOUR MILLION FROM PARK
UNCOMMITTED RESERVES. JUST IN
THE COURT EDUCATIONAL AND
SUPPORT PASSED IN SUPPORT AREA
ALONE. THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT
45% OF ALL EMERGENCY RESERVES
WE HAVE TODAY. FOR NON CORE
ENTERPRISES LIKE STUDENT
HOUSING AND PARKING THESE AREAS
ARE SUFFERING REVENUE LOSSES.
IN OUR DRAWING ON SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF THEIR THOSE RESERVES
AS WELL. SO BEING ABLE TO COVER
DEBT SERVICE ON MORE RECENTLY
CONSTRUCTED FACILITIES IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT CONCERN OF THE
UNIVERSITY. NOW ALL- CREDIBLE
FINANCIAL FORECASTS INDICATE
THAT THIS PANDEMIC COULD CREATE
THREE YEAR FINANCIAL AND
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES TO THE
STATE AND TO THE C. ISSUE.
THEREFORE IF OUR FINANCES
pMONTHS OR YEARS BEYOND WHAT WE
KNOW TODAY. YOU NEED TO BE
AWARE THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
EXPLORE MORE DISCOURAGING
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
US THAT COULD BE FURLOUGHS MORE
LAYOFF NOTICES. THAT COULD BE
LIMITING STUDENT ROMAN AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR A SLOW DOWN IN
TIME TO DO CREEK 2 DEGREES FOR
OUR STUDENTS. WE HAVE SOME
IDEAS WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU. ON HOW WE COMMUNICATE
THE NEED OF ANY OF THOSE
DIFFICULT CHOICES. SO CLOSING
THIS ISSUE IS PERSISTING
THROUGH THE DIFFICULT UNUSUAL
TIME TO REMAIN TRUE TO OUR CORE
MISSION AND DELIVER A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION TO OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING THAT PACKS OF COKE IN
NINETEEN. ALEX HAD WHAT IT'S
HAD ON US CSU STUDENTS ARE
EMPLOYEES ARE STILL SUCCESS AT
THE UNIVERSITY'S FINANCES.
THANK YOU AYE MR STORM AGAIN WE
HEARD JUST NOW FROM UC AND CSU
WE'RE GONNA WAIT A LITTLE BIT
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES ALLOW
MEMBERS TO. ENGAGE ASK
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OFF I'LL
HAVE A FEW BUT I THE FIRST
TORNADO OVER TO ANY COMMITTEES.
LIKE TO JUMP INTO MISTER
O'DONNELL YES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE A
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. BOB BUT
QUESTIONS ARE YOUR FIRST
QUESTION ON PAGES ONE AND TWO
OF THE COMMITTEE BACKGROUND.
SHOWING COSTS LOSSES BECAUSE OF
CODE NINETEEN DO THOSE NUMBERS
ACCOUNT FOR FEDERAL STIMULUS
FUNDS FOR THE FOR THE THREE
MINUTES FUNDS THAT ARE. HANDED
DOWN. TO THE SYSTEM. EITHER ONE
COULD RESPONSIBLE. YEAH
COMMITTEE PACKAGE BUT THE THIS
IS NATHAN BROSTROM AND WE DID
RECEIVE- ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN KERR'S
ACT FUNNY THAT WENT TO OUR
MEDICAL CENTERS AND CAMPUSES
THAT IS ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION SO THAT
THAT IS A- A BENEFIT TO- I TO
THE CAMPUSES MEDICAL CENTERS.
THANK YOU IN THIS ISSUE.
MAYBE
WILL I HAVE THE UC STILL BEFORE
US MISTER TRACKER JUST. ASK ONE
MORE QUESTION A UNDER HIM. DO
YOU HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY MOVE
AROUND FUNDS DO DO DO YOU FIND
THAT WHAT THE STATE IS HANDED
DOWN TO YOU IS IN THE FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH FASHION WHERE YOU CAN
MOVE IT AROUND TO. TO WHERE YOU
SEE IT. THE NEED IS. YEAH TO
SOME EXTENT WE CAN- THERE IS
SOME FUNGIBILITY B. IN THE- IN
STATE FUNDING AND MEDICAL
CENTERS. TO SHARE FUNDS WITH
THEIR OWN CAMPUSES- WE HAVE-
PROBABLY THE AREA THAT WE'RE
MOST LIMITED IN IS THE- IS
CONTRACTS AND GRANTS THOSE ARE
VERY LIMITED ON WHAT WE CAN
SPEND THE DIRECTOR. OF FUNDING
ON. AND THEN ALSO- ARE WE HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT MEANS FOR OUR
OUR BONDS. WE HAVE A GENERAL AN
EDUCATIONAL LEAN WE HAVE THE-
MEDICAL CENTER LEAN. AND THE-
LIMITED PROJECT REVENUE BONDS
WHICH ARE FOR HOUSING AND
DINING. THOSE ARE ONLY WE CAN
ONLY SPEND CERTAIN REVENUES TO
WANT TO PAY THAT DEBT SERVICE
SO THAT'S- THOSE ARE
CONSTRAINED BUT OTHERWISE WE
HAVE SOME FUNGIBILITY AND HOW
WE MOVE FIVE. I FUNDS AROUND
THAT WITHIN THE CAMPUS. SO IF
THERE IS IF THERE IS A BOND FOR
HOUSING LET'S SAY THERE'S OF ON
HOUSING. DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH
THAT IT DOESN'T AT THIS POINT.
JONATHAN RESERVES TO CARRY
THOSE FOR SOME TIME GOING
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT WE DO WE
HAVE- OUR HOUSING IS ABOUT 38%
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW ACROSS ALL
BUT IT RANGES FROM A LOW OF TEN
PERCENT. AND SANTA CRUZ IN
MERCED TO OVER 50% AT AT SAN
DIEGO THE LEAN IS A SYSTEMATIC
MEANS WE ARE ABLE TO USE
REVENUES ACROSS THE SYSTEM TO
COVER THAT IN ADDITION EACH.
OUR HOUSING SYSTEM HAS RESERVE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO DRAW ON TO
PAY THE DEBT SERVICE. THANK YOU
AND HAVE YOU ADDED AS AS OF YET
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY LAYOFFS OR
FURLOUGHS. ALL RIGHT. THERE
HAVE BEEN- MOST OF THOSE HAVE
BEEN TEMPORARY- TO DATE THERE
HAVE BEEN- ONE THOUSAND A
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. BUT NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
OF THOSE HAVE BEEN TEMPORARY
LAYOFFS- WITH ONLY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY- A PERMANENT WHITE HOUSE.
AND PRESIDENT DRAKE IS WORKING
ON SOME ACTIONS WHERE WE ARE
TRYING TO. PRESERVE JOBS AND
GOD REALLY MINIMIZED-
ESPECIALLY PERMANENT LAYOFFS.
AND SO WE'RE REALLY TAKING SOME
ACTIONS TO THE REGENTS- I NEXT
WEEK FOR CONSIDERATION THERE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. REMEMBERS MR
MEDINA. MY QUESTION IS TO YOU
SEE AND I HAVE TO I UNDERSTAND
THAT NEARLY TWO THIRDS UC
STUDENTS REPORTER SIR. ACCESS
TO THE INTERNET IN ORDER TO
TAKE THE REMOTE REMOTE COURSES
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT OVER 80%
ARE NOT HAVING ACCESS TO A
PRIVATE SPACE. OR SUFFICIENT
MATERIAL TO TAKE THEIR COURSES.
WHAT MEASURES AT UC CAMPUSES
TAKING PROVIDE STUDENTS. ACCESS
TO BROADBAND. INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. AND WHILE YOU MAY
NOT HAVE A LIST. IN FRONT OF
YOU IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FOLLOW
UP WITH MY STAFF AND. REPORTER.
FIVE CAN YOU START OVER OKAY
YEAH I'LL BEGIN AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND THAT NEARLY TWO
THIRDS OF U. UC STUDENTS HAVE
REPORTED BEING CONCERNED ABOUT
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET IN ORDER
TO TAKE THE REMARK REMOTE
COURSES ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
OVER 80% REPORT NOT HAVING
TAXES TO PRIVATE STUDY SPACE OR
SUFFICIENT MATERIAL TO TAKE
THEIR COURSES WHAT MEASURES
HAVE UC CAMPUSES TAKEN TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH ACCESS TO
BROADBAND AND INTERNET.
CONNECTIVITY. YEAH THE- THAT
THIS WAS A BIG- OUR CONCERN FOR
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES AND WHEN WE
DO WE DO IT ANNUAL SURVEY OF IT
UNDERGRADUATES. AND THEY FOUND
JUST AS YOU REPORTED THAT MR
MEDINA- 80% DID NOT HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE STUDY SPACE- THAT
GREW EVEN HIGHER WHEN YOU LOOK
AT FIRST GENERATION OR PELL
GRANT STUDENTS. AND MANY OF
THEM DID NOT FEEL LIKE THEY HAD
ACCESSTO- TO RELIABLE
BROADBAND TO PARTICIPATE- SO WE
DID SEVERAL THINGS FIRST LIKE
I'D LIKE TO SEE IS YOU. WE
DISTRIBUTED ON BOTH LAPTOPS AND
HOT SPOTS- TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
WHO NEEDED THEM- I SPENT LAST
SPRING AT UC MERCED. AND WE
WERE VERY- GRATEFUL AND HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH HEWLETT
PACKARD WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO.
DONATE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR QUITMAN JAZZ TO OUR
OUR UC MERCED STUDENTS I KNOW
EACH OF THE- EACH OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES HAD
SIMILAR EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS HAD ADEQUATE- A
LOT OF FUN. WE ALSO OPEN OUR
CAMPUSES- MORE THAN- WE LET
STUDENTS STAY IF THEY FELT THAT
THEY IT WAS IN A MORE
APPROPRIATE- A PLACE FOR THEM
TO STUDY. ALSO FELT SAFER THAN
THAN AT HOME SO- AS I MENTIONED
WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND STUDENTS ON CAMPUS ALL
RIGHT NOW AGAIN. YOU KNOW
THAT'S OUR CAPACITY IS WELL
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND- BUT-
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THIS
WHILE STILL MAINTAINING A- SAFE
POSITIVITY RATES- BUT WE WILL
GET YOU THE- ALL THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE- OF
TECHNOLOGY ARE WE DID HAVE A
SPECIAL. SEGMENT OF THE CURES
ACT FUNDING THAT WENT OUT
SPECIFICALLY FOR TECHNOLOGY
RELATED DATA DEFICIENCIES- AND
WE CAN NOT WILL HIGHLIGHT THAT-
AND MATERIAL FOR YOUR FOR YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AND NEEDS AND IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE THAT BY
CAMPUS. FORCE THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED. ABSOLUTELY
THIS QUESTION TO YOU AGAIN. UC
RIVERSIDE THAT I. IN RIVERSIDE
AS WELL AS UC IRVINE STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT TO ME A
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- THAT THEY'RE GETTING
CAUGHT IN LEASES IN LEASES WITH
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING. NOT UC
HOUSING BUT OFF CAMPUS HOUSING-
PRIVATE LEASES BUT ESPECIALLY
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT AGAIN NOW WITH
CLASSES BEGINNING IN THE FALL
STUDENTS I KNOW AT UC
RIVERSIDE. AND IRVINE ARE
GETTING STUCK WITH THESE LEASES
ARE THAT THEY CAN'T GET OUT
RIGHT DID LANDLORDS ARE SAYING
WE WILL ONLY LET YOU OUT OF THE
LEASE IF YOU FIND SOMEONE ELSE
TO TAKE YOUR PLACE- AND SO
THEY'RE GETTING CAUGHT WITH
THE- NO BAD CREDIT IF THEY JUST
MOVE AWAY. AND CERTAINLY AGAIN
MORE FINANCIAL STRAIN IS UC ARE
UC CAMPUSES DOING ANYTHING TO
TRY TO AT LEAST. NOTIFY THE
STUDENTS OR WHAT IS YOU SEE
DOING SO THAT THAT DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN BECAUSE IT'S
QUITE AN ISSUE BOTH IN
RIVERSIDE AND IRVINE. YEAH AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEAN I'LL HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU ON WHAT EACH
CAMPUS IS DOING I KNOW WHEN I
WAS AT- OR SAID IN THE SPRING.
THAT WAS AN ISSUE IN A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS YOU KNOW CAME TO
US AND WANTED TO KNOW SHOULD
THEY BE SIGNING THESE LEASES
AND SO WE ACTUALLY HAD SOME ON
CAMPUS RESOURCES. TO HELP THEM
ESPECIALLY THEN BECAUSE ASIANS
WITH- WITH LANDLORDS BUT- I'LL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON WHAT
EACH INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES DOING
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS- I DO KNOW
YOU KNOW IRVINE HAS QUITE A BIT
OF. P. THREE HOUSING AND I KNOW
THAT IRVINE STEPPED IN TO MAKE
LEASE PAYMENTS- ON BEHALF OF-
OF SOME OF THE STUDENTS TO- TO
MITIGATE. THAT ANY. FINANCIAL
IMPACT ON THEM. THANK YOU. OKAY
I'LL HAVE A FEW THAT QUESTIONS
YOU BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON THIS I
THINK SOME OF THE QUESTIONS TO
US I'LL START WITH YOU SEE. YOU
SEE RIGHT HERE NATHAN WITH US
AS FAR AS ENROLLMENT. I WANTED
TO I'VE I'VE TALKED TO A FEW OF
YOUR CAMPUS LEADERS IN LAST FEW
MONTHS ABOUT. ENROLLMENT TRENDS
OF SPECIFICALLY. WHAT HAPPENED
WITH NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
AND WE REALIZE THAT SAID. FOR
WRONG YOU'RE RIGHT THAT'S A KEY
PART OF THE THREE LEG GET
FINANCIAL BASICALLY PATH FOR
THE UNIVERSITY DOES STUDENT FEE
REVENUE FROM CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS YEAH GENERAL FUND
FROM THE STATE. AND NONRESIDENT
THE EXTRA NONRESIDENT TUITION
YOU GET ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR ALL THE NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS- WHAT WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH THAT WITH THE
TREND AS FAR AS NON RESIDENTS
DURING THIS COVERED PANDEMIC.
OUR NON RESIDENT STUDENTS ARE
THE ONLY ONE- CHAIRMAN PARTY
WHICH HAS SEEN A- DIP AT ALL
AND IT HAS RANGED FROM- 2%
DECLINE TO A 4% DECLINE ACROSS
THE CAMPUSES. ARE
INTERESTINGLY- INCOMING
STUDENTS HAS BEEN IT HAS STAYED
STRONG BUT IT'S A LOT OF
RETURNING STUDENTS WHO DECIDED
THAT THEY DID NOT WANT TO DO IT
REMOTELY. AND DID NOT RETURN TO
CAMPUS THE FIRST PLACE WE SAW
THIS WAS. AT BERKELEY WHICH IS
YOU KNOW ONE OF OUR- OUR
SEMESTER CAMPUSES SO THEY
STARTED EARLIER THAN THE
QUARTER CAMPUSES. THEY SAW
DECLINE ARE BOTH IN RETURNING-
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS AND ALSO IN SOME OF
THE ONE YEAR. MASTER'S PROGRAMS
THAT WERE. VERY POPULAR WITH-
SOME OF THEIR INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS. ARE THE- OTHER
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE NOT SEEN AS
BIG AS A CLIENT THE ONLY OTHER
ONE THAT HAS A SIMILAR DECLINE
IS UC IRVINE. BUT THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD A VERY BIG CLASS
FOUR YEARS EARLIER AND SO THEY
WERE DEIBERATELY ARE REDUCING
THEIR- THAT THE NUMBER OF- OF
STUDENTS- BUT AGAIN IT'S BEEN
YOU KNOW. MUCH LESS THAN WE HAD
PROJECTED- IN THE RANGE OF
ABOUT 224% DECLINE- ED ANYONE
ANYONE GIVING CAMPUS. ALL RIGHT
SO AT AND WE KNOW WE HAVE A NON
RESIDENT. POLICY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT. WE WORKED ON A
YEARS AGO WITH YOU IT MYSELF
TANG THINK THAT'S A FAIR.
COMPROMISE CAME UP WITH IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY A CAP UT IT'S
R. RATIO SO. ESSENTIALLY EVERY-
YOU KNOW NON RESIDENT STUDENT
YOU ENROLL WE WANT TO THE ROLE
ROUGHLY YOU KNOW THREE. THREE
OR FOUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
DEPENDING ON YOUR CAMPUS- SO IS
IT IS THAT YOU KNOW. APPLES TO
ORANGES WORKS APPLES TO APPLES
WHEN WE CAN LOOK AT.
POTENTIALLY FEWER NON RESIDENTS
DOES THAT AT ALL. EXPAND SPACE
OR CAPACITY FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN.
THAT IS ALWAYS THE ISSUE THAT
WE HERE WE GO HOME TO OUR
DISTRICTS AS WE HAVE A NEIGHBOR
OR FRIEND OR SO AND SO'S GOT
UP. FOUR POINT SOMETHING GPA
AND CAN'T GET INTO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
WE WILL CERTAINLY SEE THE RATIO.
AS WE SAW NEARLY IN TWO
THOUSAND- TWO THOUSAND
INCREASING CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
AND YOU KNOW ROUGHLY ABOUT
THIRTEEN HUNDRED I'M REALLY
DECLINE IN IN NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS. BUT IS IT AS YOU
POINT OUT THIS IS GOING CAMPUS
BY CAMPUS AND SO ON I WILL BLOW
THE OVERALL HE PERCENT CASH
THAT SHOULD FALL MORE IN EACH
OF THE CAMPUSES ARE ABOVE THAT
WILL SEE THEIR RATIO. ON AND
THEN IT IS VERY ENCOURAGING
THAT THE- FOR YOU SEE CONTINUE
IT REMAINS TO EVEN WITH. YOU
SUCH A- IN IN THE MAIL. AND
ACTUAL PRESIDENT ROLAND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THE FACT THAT WE.
EIGHTY HUNDRED STUDENTS WAS.
GEN YEAH AND LASTLY DO YOU
THINK THE NON STUDENTS WHO ARE
ARE IN THE UC IT JUST TOOK A
TOOK A COVERED BREAK. JUVENTUS
A PATE THAT THEY WOULD COME
BACK ON OR THEY TRY TO GET THAT
DEGREE ELSEWHERE PROBABLY MAKES
SENSE THAT IT WOULD FINISHED OR
SO CLOSE IT'S HARD TO FINISH UP
SOMEWHERE ELSE SO YEAH. HOW DO
WE SEE THAT PLAYING OUT. WELL
MANY OF THEM WILL COME BACK BUT
THEY JUST WANTED TO HAVE A
MEETING PERSON RESIDENTIAL. AND
ALSO YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY THEIR
INTERNATIONAL- ATTAINING. HE
WAS ON THAT MAYBE YOU KNOW
MAYBE. IT IS JUST NOT. I'M NOT
ABLE FOR THEIR EDUCATION AND SO
I THINK THEY IN ANY WAITING A
SEMESTER OR WE NEED A FULL
YEAR. BEFORE THEY RETURN TO.
MRS YEAH. THANK YOU THAT MAKES
SENSE- COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR
RAINSTORM IN CS YOU CAN GET
RYAN RYAN BACK AT. YOU KNOW I
WAS PLEASED BY WHAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT HOW MORE STUDENTS ARE
TAKING- THE FIFTEEN UNIT GOAL.
TO BE GOING TO BE GOING FULL
TIME AND- WELL I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HEAR A LITTLE BIT FROM
OUR PRESIDENT HERE AT THAT SAC
STATE. AND EVEN THEY HAVE BEEN
INCREASING YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
EVEN AND DURING CO THAT WE'VE
SEEN THAT- INCREASES WELL SO-
CAN YOU TALK MORE ABOUT THAT.
MR STORM. YEAH I THINK I
GENERALLY SPEAKING- THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT ARE DRIVEN- OUR
SUCCESS IN THAT WHITE ONE IT'S
JUST GETTING THE WORD OUT WORD
OUT THAT. YOU NEED TO TAKE
FIFTEEN UNITS IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY FASHION
AND- AS MORE AND MORE COHORTS
OF NEW STUDENTS HAVE ENTERED IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS OR THE
GRADUATION OF IT I MEAN WE'VE
ESSENTIALLY HAVE A WHOLE. ALL
OF OUR COHORTS OF STUDENTS ARE
NOW STUDENTS WHO HAVE HEARD
THAT MESSAGE LOUD AND CLEAR FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. AND SO I
THINK YOU JUST SEE THAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENING YEAH THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE MESSAGING
POINTED AT THE OTHER POINT OF
IT TOO IS OF COURSE THE FUNDING
OF THE GRADUATION OF ITSELF. IT
HAD BEEN ADDED HATS THREE SOLID
YEARS OF REALLY SOLID FUNDING
FOR THAT FOR THE GRADUATION OF.
WHAT THAT ALLOWED FOR IS THE
CAMPUS IS TO MATCH THAT DEMAND
FROM STUDENTS AT ALLOWED
CAMPUSES TO OFFER THOSE
ADDITIONAL COURSES SO THAT.
STUDENTS COULD TAKE THOSE UP TO
FIFTEEN UNITS. WORTH OF COURSE
IS NOT A GRADUATE AS AS THEY
SEE FIT COURSE THAT I GRABBED
IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE SAID THAT
YOU MUST TAKE IT AWFUL LOAD. UP
OF COURSE EVERY STUDENT HAS
THEIR OWN UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND CAN GO AT A SLOWER PACE OF
THE CHU SO BUT- THE GOAL OF THE
GRADUATION OF WAS TO OFFER THAT
IS AS TO THE EXTENT WE COULD
POSSIBLE TO OVER STUDENTS. I
THINK- I. THINK WE'RE SHOWING A
LOT OF GREAT SUCCESS SO FAR.
YEAH WELL I OBVIOUSLY I THINK
THAT IS A VERY- IMPORTANT NEWS
AND IT. IT IS A TWO FOLD HELP
THAT HELPS THE STUDENTS
GRADUATE. WITHIN FOUR YEARS
WITHOUT AS MUCH DEBT- WE KNOW
THAT'S THE STUDENTS GO ON FOR
FIVE OR SIX YEARS THEY- RUN OUT
OF. CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY THEY
HAVE TO BORROW MONEY. JUST
SOMETHING OUT SAID THIS IS
CYCLE. AND THEN FURTHER. YOU
KNOW EVERY YEAR AS YOU TELL US
WE HAVE. THIRTY THOUSAND
SOMETHING. QUALIFIED HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO WANT TO GO
TO THE CSU WOULD. WHO CAN'T GET
IN. SO THE MORE STUDENTS YOU
KNOW FINISH IN FOUR YEARS
THAT'S MORE SPACE FOR. HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES WHO WANT TO
GET THE IN THE CSU SYSTEM- SO.
APPRECIATE THAT ONE THING THAT
I KNOW I TALK TO YOU ABOUT. DR
RAMBLE AND I HAVE A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WE PUSHED
LEGISLATION. WOULD THEN. CSU
PRESIDENT OF CASTRO. AND NOW OF
COURSE HE'S THE LEADER OF THE
CSU SYSTEM. TO TRY TO. CHANGE
OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM. TO
REALLY- NEAR THE GOALS THAT YOU
HAVE THIS FULL TIME. AND WITH
WITH THE FINANCIAL AID SO NOT
NECESSARILY FIFTEEN. PER
SEMESTER BUT THIRTY PER YEAR
SO. STUDENTS STILL WANT TAKE
TWELVE FOR SEMESTER THEY CAN.
DO SOMETHING IN WINTER SESSION
OR SUMMER SCHOOL- WE THINK THAT
ALL OF THE NAVAL STUDENTS MOST
OF POORLY TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS- YOU KNOW BUT ALSO. ALLOW
THEM TO NOT HAVE TO TAKE
STUDENT DEBT AT THE END WHEN
THEY'RE RIGHT NOW THEY'RE CAL
GRANT ELIGIBILITY SO. LOOK.
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT THIS YEAR. THANK YOU MR
TANG- AND HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
FOR THIS PANEL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH IS
QUESTIONS SO. THE. TWO POINT
THREE BILLION- LOST THAT THAT
DID NOT CLICK THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE THE CODE THAT CARES ACT
MONEY AS WELL AS THE FOR CSU
THE SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. REVENUE
LOSS DID IT INCLUDE THE FIVE
TWENTY FIVE FROM CARES. I KNOW
IT DID NOT SO WHAT WE DID WAS
AT THE BEGINNING OF BOTH OF
THESE TERMS THE SPRING- TWENTY
TWENTY TERM IN THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TERM. SERVER AT OUR
CAMPUS TO SEE WHAT IS THAT WHAT
IS THE POTENTIAL DAMAGE NOW
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WILL SHAKE OUT
RIGHT. THE USE OF KERR'S ACT
FUNDING WILL BE PART OF THAT
MEDICATION ALSO YOU'LL SEE THE
MITIGATION IN THE WAY OF. OUR
HIRING FREEZE OF THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS SO-IN AND ALSO THE USE
OF OUR OF OUR RESERVES. SO
THAT'S JUST THE KIND OF A HIGH
WATER MARK IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
THINK OUR CAMPUSES HAVE IN
TERMS OF EXPOSURE AND OBVIOUSLY
THAT NUMBER WILL. LIKELY COME
DOWN. OVER TIME BASED ON THESE
MEDICATIONS SO IN TERMS OF IN
TERMS OF YOUR ACTUALS WHERE YOU
ARE THE WE- REALLY HAVE A LOT
OF. DETAIL ON ACTUALS OF OTHER
THAN THE ACTUAL. CAUSES FOR.
DETAIL JUST LOOKING FOR WHERE
YOU ARE. YEAH YEAH YEAH- WHAT I
CAN REPORT TO YOU WHAT WOULD BE
THE COST TO DATE SO WE HAVE
COSTS COVERED RELATED FOR ALL
FUND SOURCES OF ABOUT EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO DATE. FROM
THE START OF MARCH THROUGH- I
THINK IT'S THROUGH THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER. AS I SAID ONE
HUNDRED WORK BUT WAS MY
QUESTION SO I JUST I JUST HOUSE
WHERE ARE YOU. IN TERMS OF
REVENUE MINUS EXPENSES ACTUALS
AS OF TODAY. I CAN'T I CAN'T
TELL YOU THAT AS OF TODAY I
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ABOUT
THE DETAIL OF THAT. THANKS OF
TEXAS SURVEY OF CAMPUSES TO DO
SO. YOU DON'T YOU DON'T TRACK
IT ON A MONTH BASIS. WELL WE DO
IT MORE- PERIODICALLY JUST ON A
MONTHLY BASIS- SO WE ARE JUST
ABOUT TO POP THAT. YOUR QUICK
LIKE WHEN LIKE ONCE A YEAR I
THINK IT'S ALL THE MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN THAT BUT THAT'S
THAT'S WAITING INTO AN AREA
THAT I DON'T HAVE THE BEST
UNDERSTANDING OF RIGHT NOW
SAFETY PRACTICAL. THAT'S FINE.
MISTER BREWSTER JUST SAY WE
JUST WANT TO REITERATE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALM BEACH THE
QUESTION. YEAH WE DO TRACK IT
ON A- A MONTHLY BASIS- BOTH-
FOR THE POTENTIAL OF. FUTURE
HEROES THAT FUNDING BUT ALSO
FOR FEMALE ONE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
BE- I RECOUPED. SO OUR NUMBER
ACTUALLY AS OF OCTOBER THIRTY
FIRST WAS TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. AGAIN TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOST REVENUE OR REVENUE. THAT
WAS- BELOW OUR PROJECTIONS AND-
INCREASED- EXPENSES AND AGAIN
THAT'S A ACROSS BOTH OUR
CAMPUSES AND OUR MEDICAL
CENTERS I GOT. A NOTICE. OF THE
OF THE CURES ACT FUNDING. THERE
WAS A CONCERN ABOUT MR LAST
SENTENCE THAT WAS WHAT. I DON'T
KNOW THAT'S A GROSS WITH FISCAL
IMPACT BUT WE DID GET CARES ACT
FUNDING OF ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
AND- SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
GOT GOT. TO THAT WAS CALCULATED
INTO YOUR REVENUE NUMBERS. YEAH
OKAY PERFECT IN AN THEY CAN. IN
SIX QUESTION FOR BY FOR. BOTH
CAN YOU JUST GIVE US A SENSE.
YOUR YOUR TESTING PROTOCOLS
YOUR CONTACT TRACING PROTOCOLS
FOR. FURRY ART BY DO YOU KNOW
YOUR STUDENTS FACULTY STAFF
THOSE WHO ARE ON CAMPUS. YEAH
MAYBE I'LL I'LL START OUR EVERY
CAMPUS HAS THE DISKS ARE
DIFFERENT- PROTOCOL BUT WE ARE
TRYING WE ARE HEARING MANY OF
THEM UP FOR EXAMPLE A UCLA- HAS
DEVELOPED THE SWAP SEEK WHICH
WILL BE A MUCH LOWER COST. OF
PROTOCOL AND THEY'RE STARTING
TO WORK WITH UC SANTA BARBARA
ON IT ARE YOU SEE IS THAT IS
LOOKING TO PARTNER WITH UC
BERKELEY BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
BERKELEY IS USING A- A
COMMERCIAL- VENDOR WHICH IS
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN AND I
ADDS TO THEIR COSTS. ARE UC SAN
DIEGO HAS PROBABLY BEEN THE
MOST RIGOROUS IN TERMS OF THEIR
PROTOCOLS BECAUSE EVERYONE ON
CAMPUS TWICE A MONTH- AND THEY
DO IT ALL- INTERNALLY SO WE ARE
HOPING ESPECIALLY MOVING INTO-
WINNER AT QUARTER SPRING
SEMESTER. THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
BRING MORE STUDENTS BACK ON
CAMPUS BECAUSE OF THE- BOTH
THAT THE- THAT THE TESTING THE
CONTACT TRACING AND THEN THE
QUARANTINE- ABILITY SO- RIGHT
NOW WITH POSITIVITY RATES ARE
WELL BELOW POINT FIVE PERCENT.
WE STILL HAVE PLENTY OF
CAPACITY FOR A QUARANTINING OUR
STUDENTS WHO ARE- WHO. ARE ARE
ARE COULD BE POSITIVE. I THINK
THE ABOUT YOUR- TRACING
PARTICLE. OUR I GET IT'S
DIFFERENT FOR EACH CAMPUS BUT-
UC SAN DIEGO IS PROBABLY THE-
PROBABLY THE BUT THE MOST
ROBUST WITH THAT AND THEY- ARE
THEY HAVE BEEN INCORPORATING
THAT THE OTHER THING THAT SAN
DIEGO IS DONE IS THEY'RE ALSO
USING IT FOR OFF CAMPUS
STUDENTS WHO ARE COME ON AND
THEY FOUNDED THEIR TEST THE
POSITIVE THE RATES ARE HIGHER-
SOMETIMES AS MUCH AS THREE
TIMES HIGHER SO STUDENTS ON ON
CAMPUS SO. ONE OF THINGS OR
FINDING IS THAT IT'S ALMOST
SAFE IS FOR STUDENTS TO BE IN A
RESIDENTIAL- I CAMPUS BASED AYE
AYE COMMUNITY. GREAT THANK YOU
AND THEN- I JUST A FULL OPEN
FROM THAT YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
WAS- A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
LOSSES WERE YOUR DURING YOUR
ANCILLARY SPACES LIKE HOUSING
AND FOOD SERVICE SO HOW DO YOU
I GUESS HOW DO YOU. MANAGE THAT
AYE AYE I THINK FOR THE LONG
TERM YOU MUST HAVE. SOME SOME
AMOUNT OF DEBT SERVICE ON THE
HOUSING OR THINGS LIKE THAT SO
HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR WHAT
YOUR PLAN ON MANAGING THE- YEAH
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
WE DO HAVE. YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
DEBT SERVICE ON ON- A LOT OF
THE HOUSING. THAT'S PROBABLY
OUR MOST FIXED EXPENSE- IN
ADDITION PRESIDENT DRAKE. HAS
BEEN ADAMANT THAT HE REALLY
WANTS TO MINIMIZE- PERMANENT
LAYOFFS WE WANT TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND NOT. A PART OF
THE PROBLEM AND SO WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO. PRESERVE USING
REDEPLOYMENT AND OTHER OTHER
MEASURES- TO PRESERVE-
EMPLOYMENT- RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW
THE RESERVES ARE STANDING UP.
FOR A DELIVERIES- BUT WE'RE AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
EXPAND OUR CAPACITY AS WE MOVE
INTO THE WINTER QUARTER AND
SPRING SEMESTER. AGAIN AS I
SAID- SYSTEM WATER ABOUT 38%
CAPACITY. THAT RANGES FROM A
LOW OF 10% TO A HIGH OF OVER
FIFTY PERCENT- BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO USE RESERVES- WE
WERE VERY- THE- THAT THE
TAXABLE BOND ISSUE THAT I
MENTIONED LAST SUMMER WE DID
ONE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS.
THE ALL IN RATES WERE ABOUT
ONE. POINT FOUR PERCENT. OF FOR
SEVEN YEAR TERM SO ARE VERY
VERY LOW COST MONEY THAT ALSO
GAVE CAMPUSES. ARE SOME
QUESTION AND IN TERMS OF
PRESERVING EMPLOYMENT. EVEN
WITHOUT THE LOSS IN REVENUES.
THE THANK YOU WE HAVE.
PRESIDENT DRINKS ON OFFER. I
THINK WE HAVE SOME PHILOSOPHY
FOR OUR BUDGET APPROACH THIS
LAST YEAR AS WELL SO THANK YOU.
MISTER STORMERS JUST ASKED TO
SEND QUESTIONS AROUND. CONTACT
TRACING AND TESTING FOR YOUR.
DON'T MISS A STORY STILL THERE
JUST CHECKING. I NEED TO LEARN
HOW TO HIT THAT YOU COULD NOT
BE BUT I MY APOLOGIES THE WORST
OF. SO FROM THAT FROM THAT
VANTAGE POINT OF WE DON'T HAVE
THE SAME. LUXURIES THAT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALGARY CALLING
SEVEN TERMS OF ACCESS TO DIRECT
MEDICAL- FACILITIES LIKE THEY
DO. AND SO FROM A FROM A- THE
CSU STUDENT VANTAGE POINT THAT
THE FIRST POINT OF CONTACT
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE EITHER
PRIVATE- THEIR PRIVATE HEALTH
SERVICE CARRIER OR ALSO DAY AT
THAT CAMPUS HEALTH SEARCH
SERVICES CENTER RIGHT- SO
THAT'S- THAT'S- GENERALLY. WHAT
WE'RE STUDENT WOULD WOULD GO
FOR THAT TYPE OF CARE I THINK
MAYBE- I'LL PUT THAT I
PRESIDENT NELSON ON THE SPOT
HE'LL BE IN YOUR PANEL TO IT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE FULSOME.
PLANTATION FROM WHAT A
PARTICULAR CAMPUS HAS TO OFFER
IN TERMS OF CONTACT TRACING.
AND TESTING OF STUDENTS BUT I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE THAT THAT
BREADTH OF KNOWLEDGE OR-
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE AT THIS POINT.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH LIKE ME
TO ANSWER THAT HOUSING QUESTION
IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE AT MISTER PRESIDENT
HAD TO SAY ABOUT IT OVER AT ON
OUR CAMPUSES WE'RE RUNNING OUT
ON AVERAGE ABOUT A 20% CAPACITY
OF OUR STUDENT HOUSING WE HAVE
A- PRETTY SIGNIFICANT- DEBT
SERVICE OUT ON OUR STUDENT
HOUSING IN A VERY SPEC CANVAS
RIGHT DEPENDING ON IF IT'S MORE
READRESIDENTIAL OR OR OR MORE
A COMMUTER NATURE. OF BUT IT IS
A CONCERN- GENERALLY SPEAKING-
BASED ON A COUPLE OF
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH-
WITH OUR CAMPUSES- IN THAT ARE
CFO'S. I WOULD SAY THAT MOST
CAMPUSES ARE FEELING LIKE THEY
CAN WEATHER- THIS PARTICULAR
TERM PERHAPS INTO THE SPRINGIF
THINGS. GET MORE DIFFICULT FOR
IT THINGS WILL GET MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR HOUSING COME
FALL- TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO COVER UP
COSTS FOR STUDENT HOUSING. AND
SO JUST UP APPRECIATE THAT
COVERS A WHAT WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE OPTIONS YOU'RE CONSIDERING
THAT INTO. OF COURSE YOU
UTILITY SERVICE IS ONE OF THOSE
OF WE HAVE SOME RESERVES WE CAN
WE CAN DO THERE- AND THEN IT
WILL IT WILL ALSO DEPEND ON IN
TERMS OF- IF. AND HOW MUCH WE
CAN REPOPULATE GOING FORWARD-
FOR THE SPRING WE ARE STILL
VIRTUAL AND SO WHAT LIKE I SAID
THE CFO'S OF SAID WELL WE THINK
WE CAN GENERALLY GET THROUGH
THE SPRING IF. YOU KNOW WE'RE
AT OUR CURRENT OCCUPANCY
LEVELS. BEYOND THAT THEN IF WE
GET INTO THE FALL AND WE HAVE
THE SAME LEVELS OF OCCUPANCY
THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE
CHALLENGE WITH IN TERMS OF-
BEING ABLE TO COVER DEBT
SERVICE BEING ABLE TO. PROVIDE
THAT LEVEL OF- bTINUED
EMPLOYEE- THAT STOPPED THE
PLOYS THAT ARE FUNDED BY THE
STUDENT HOUSING PROGRAM SECTOR
BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO FEW MEMBERS
FIRST. FOR AYE MR STORM SO YOU
STAY RIGHT THERE AT FIRST
MISTER O'DONNELL. YET THANK YOU
I DO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THESE SEE I DID NOT. GET AN
ANSWER FROM THE CSU- I THE
SPOKE TO QUESTION ONE WHICH IS
ABOUT THE BACKFILL WITH IT WITH
THE- CARE DOLLARS- BUT- WITH
REGARD TO- FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
C. ISSUE DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY. OF BILLS IN YOUR
BUDGET. SO THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
YES. I THINK THE ANSWER TO THAT
IS WE WOULD SURE APPRECIATE
MORE- RIGHT NOW WHAT WE HAVE
THIS WE HAVE STATUTE THAT SAYS
THAT WE ARE ALLOWED WITHIN WITH
R. C. ISSUE FUNDS SO THIS WOULD
BE PARKING. HOUSING AND- EVEN
OUR OPERATION OUR CORE OR CORE
AND NON CORE FOR WE HAVE THE-
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO LOAN
FUNDS BETWEEN- THE- LOAN MONIES
BETWEEN THOSE FUNDS. HOWEVER WE
CANNOT AND DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO TRANSFER MONIES
BETWEEN THOSE FUNDS. LIKE YOU
AT THE STATE LEVEL. IN THE
GENERAL FUND YOU RECEIVE
REVENUES FROM A WHOLE HOST OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES RIGHT YEAH
HARPER TAXES PERSONAL INCOME
TAXES AND YOU CAN MELT THOSE
TOGETHER. AND YOU CAN EXPAND
THEM ON WHAT YOU NEED TO AT SIX
AT. THE UNIVERSITY IN A WAY
WERE HAMSTRUNG INTHAT WAY.
WHERE WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
TAKE ALL OF OUR REVENUE SOURCES
ESPECIALLY A COVERT ON. TALK
ABOUT THE COVERT SEASON HERE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
THEN BE ABLE TO UTILIZE ALL OF
OUR REVENUE SOURCES IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE. POTENTIAL LAYOFFS TO
MITIGATE COST IMPLICATE. ANY
DEFICITS THAT WE MIGHT HAVE IN
A PARTICULAR PROGRAM ON A
PARTICULAR CAMPUS SO. SO ONE
THING THAT WE THINK WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL IS TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY. THROUGH A
STATUTORY CHANGE TO CHANGE THAT
TO A TRANSFER OF. FUNDS
BETWEEN- TRANSFER OF MONEY
BETWEEN FUNDS. OTHER STRAIGHT
AFTER THAT OF COURSE- BUT-
THAT'S THAT'S ONE THAT WAY WE
COULD HAVE LOOKS BUT THE OTHER
THING THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
FORTY- AT THE MOMENT LIKE.
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
EVEN THE STATE HOUSE. WHERE YOU
COULD- YOU COULD BORROW FOR
LIQUIDITY PURPOSES RIGHT NOW.
OUR ONLY AVENUE RIGHT NOW IS
TOO LOW BETWEEN FUND SOURCES.
OR TO UTILIZE THE RESERVES THAT
WE HAVE. THANK YOU AND I'M SURE
THEY'LL BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD.
THE POSITIVES AND THE NEGATIVES
OF THAT THAT THAT FLEXIBILITY-
JUST ONE OTHER QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO NEXT YEAR'S FRESHMAN
CLASS. SO I THINK I'VE READ
LATELY THAT THIS ISSUE IS-
EDUCATING MORE STUDENTS THAN
EVER HAS. SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT WHAT WOULD NEXT
YEAR'S FRESHMAN CLASS LOOK LIKE
MY TO BE LARGER. SMALLER
BECAUSE SOME STUDENTS MIGHT
HELD OFF. A YEAR MAYBE YOU
MIGHT KNOW NUMBERS ASSOCIATED
THAT MAYBE NOT. DO DO DO YOU
HAVE ANY. YOU HAVE ANY
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT NEXT YEAR'S
FRESHMAN CLASS MY LOOK ON. YES
SIR THAT'S THAT'S THE THAT THE
BIG CRYSTAL BALL QUESTION.
GENERALLY SPEAKING UP FROM OUR
ROLE WITH EXPERIENCE RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
WE HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN OUR
TRANSFER STUDENTS THAT BEARS
ALMOST TO THE DOCK TO THE
NUMBER. A SLIGHT DECREASE IN
OUR FIRST TIME FRESHMEN. AND
THERE COULD BE A WHOLE HOST OF
REASONS WHY THAT'S THE CASE BUT
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAS ALLOWED US T MAINTAIN OUR
ROLE THAT HAS HAS BEEN THE FACT
THAT WE KNOW WE ANNOUNCED
EARLIER INTENTIONS OF GOING
VIRTUAL. JUST BEING ABLE TO
ALLOW FAMILIES THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO PLAN FOR IT. SO IF ARE WHAT
WE THINK IS OUR SUCCESS IN IN
DECIDING WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO
BE FOR A SHORT PERSON. I THINK
THAT WILL HELP INFORM US
WHETHER FRESHMAN ENTER THE
UNIVERSITY OR OR HAVE IT-
THERE'S A DEMAND FOR FRESHMEN
TO ENTER THE UNIVERSITY IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUT
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A WAYS OUT
THERE IS JUST AN OUT THERE I
WOULD THINK THOUGH THAT IF THE
ECONOMY PROCESS AS IT IS- AND
IF IT PERSISTS AS IT IS IT
MIGHT BE MORE DIFFICULT FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL TO. GAIN EMPLOYMENT THAT
DO OTHER THINGS SO THERE MAY BE
GREATER DEMAND TO CONTINUE TO
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION- BUT
IT'S RIGHT NOW IT'S DIFFICULT
TO FOR SEE WHAT THE ANSWER IS
ON THAT INVOLVED TWENTY ONE.
WHAT WHAT IS THE UNIVERSITY
PROJECTING. ALL RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PROJECTIONS THAT
I THAT I'M AWARE OF FOR NEXT
YOU PROBABLY WON'T HAVE
LOCATIONS OR DO I ASSUME AT THE
END OF THIS MONTH. THEY WOULD
BE OUR DATABASE. YET THE END OF
THIS MONTH FOR OUR CAMPUS BUT
IT COULD IT COULD GO INTO THAT
THE NEW YORK AS WELL SO. OKAY
SO IS IT IS THE IS THE
APPLICATION. DEADLINE TYPICALLY
AS I RCALL. AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER. IT'S THOSE
APPLICATIONS FOR THE C. ISSUE
AT LEAST ARE DUE AT THE END OF.
NOVEMBER IS THAT BEEN ALTERED
PUSH BACK AT ALL OR- IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE CAMPUS- BUT- FOR
THE MOST PART. WE CAN HAVE A
CUT OFF DATE OF. OF NOVEMBER
LIKE YOU'RE SAYING OR COULD.
DEPENDING ON DEMAND A
PARTICULAR CAMPUSES. IT COULD
BE IT COULD BE LATER IN THE
YEAR YOU COULD BE EVEN. WELL IN
THE SPRING TO SENDING OUT HOW
MUCH OF A ROLE THAT IS AT THAT
CAMPUS SO THE REASON WHY I
THINK. SO NOW IT'S MARKETED TO
TODAY. IT'S NOVEMBER THIRTIETH
BUT IT COULD CHANGE. IT DEPENDS
ON THE GENERAL ANSWERS IS OKAY
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE NOT.
ENROLLMENT GUY- YOUR NUMBERS
GUY FOR BUT BUT BUT IT DOES BUT
IT DOES DEPEND ON IT IT DOES
DEPEND ON THE ON THE PARTICULAR
CAMPUS. SO IS THAT YOUR EVERY
YEAR IS NOT JUST TRUE IN. THIS
SITUATION IT. IT CAN CHANGE IT
CAN CHANGE YEAR TO YEAR
DEPENDING ON HOW ENROLLMENT IS
DOING AT OUR PREVIOUS CAMP ZIP
FOR EXAMPLE. DEMAND IN THE LONG
BEACH STATE. AT FULLER TEN.
VERY HIGH THAT'S THAT'S UP IN
OUR EXPERIENCE. IT'S ORT OF
THE ROLE THAT DEADLINES ARE
EARLIER IN THE YEAR. HOWEVER WE
HAVE A- NUMBER OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES SONOVA
HUMBLE SAN FRANCISCO. WHERE
THOSE CAMPUSES. ARE
EXPERIENCING LESS THAN ROBUST
DEMAND AND LESSEN ROLL WITH. IT
SO THAT THEY WILL KEEP THEIR
ADMISSION. OR MISSION WENT OPEN
LONGER ANDERSON ALLOW FOR THAT.
MOMENT OF IT. SO SOMEONE LIKE
CHICO WORM MANY STUDENTS. MOVE
FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER.
MIGHT EXPERIENCE DIFFERENT IN
OUR OWN. THAT CHOI EVERY IS IT
JUST BECAUSE A COVERT. THAT'S
TRUE EVERY YEAR I THINK- BUT-
EVEN BEFORE COVE ED ARE
ENROLLMENTS IN THE FAR
NORTHERN- CAMPUSES HAVE IT SOFT
OKAY. UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU I TWO MORE
QUESTIONS PERSEUS YOU MISTER
MEDINA MR ARAMBULA THANK YOU A
RYAN I'D I'D LIKE TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
DECISION- INITIALLY TO NOT LAY
OFF EMPLOYEES- AND I THINK THAT
THAT DECISION STAYED FOR AROUND
SIX MONTHS I BELIEVE. AND NOW
THE SITUATION WHERE EMPLOYEES
ARE BEING LAID OFF- IF YOU
COULD JUST TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THE RATIONALE FOR
THOSE DECISIONS AND WHAT CHANGE
TO GET US TO WHERE WE ARE
HAVING TO LAY OFF EMPLOYEES NOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA WE'VE
BEEN. DOING OUR BEST TO KEEP
EVERYBODY IS EMPLOYED AS
POSSIBLE AS LONG AS POSSIBLE WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A NUMBER OF.
LEAVE PROGRAMS- BEGINNING AT
THE AT THE START OF THAT THAT-
THE PANDEMIC. I STARTED OFF
VERY EARLY ON WITH THOSE WHO
ARE AGE SIXTY FIVE AND ABOVE
AND THOSE WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS SO WE OFFERED. A
NUMBER OF HOURS OF LEAVE THAT
AND THEN WE ALSO HAD OTHER
TYPES OF LEAVES THAT IF YOU
COULD WORK ON SITE YOU COULD
YOU COULD TAKE SAY UP TO THREE
OR FOUR HOURS OF WORK THERE.
ANOTHER ONE WAS IF YOU HAD TO
CARE FOR KIDS OR YOU HAVE YOU
WERE CARING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
SICK OR YOU YOURSELF WERE SICK.
GET A NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ALLOWED AT ALLOWED
EMPLOYEES- LITERALLY A MONTH TO
TWO MONTHS AT A TIME TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE LEAVE AND RETAIN POINT
RETAINER HEALTH CARE. OKAY SO
THAT WAS THAT THAT'S THE
BACKDROP. WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES
TO THEN. THIS POINT TIME WHERE
YOU'RE NOTICING NOW THAT WE
HAVE. WELL LET ME AT LEAST LET
ME LET ME MAKE TWO TO TWO
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES SO. THE
FIRST OF A PLOY IS WITH US IN
OUR NON CORE AREAS TOO. SO
THOSE ARE LIKE BOOKSTORES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT- WHEN THERE
WAS NO- NO NO FOOD SERVICE OR
THE BOOKSTORES WERE CLOSE THOSE
ENTERPRISES- HAD TO HAD TO LEAD
A NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES GO MOSTLY
STUDENT WORKERS FOR THE MOST
PART THERE- AND I WAS JUST
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REVENUE
COMING IN AND THERE WAS NOBODY
THAT WAS THAT WAS. TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF BEING ON CAMPUS
BECAUSE THE CAMPUSES WERE
CLOSED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES WE
PROVIDED ALL OF THESE LEAVE
OPPORTUNITIES- THROUGH THE- AT
THROUGH THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR SO JUNE THIRTY AT THAT
THAT EXTENDED BECAUSE OF THAT
THE FEDERAL CARES ACT. OF CARE
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE THOSE WHAT
IS BOILING DOWN TO NOW IN TERMS
OF OUR THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR ORIGINAL LAYOFF NOTICES.
IS THAT WE HAVE EITHER A LACK
OF WORK OR WE HAVE A LACK OF
FUNDS RELATED TO THESE. SO FOR
IT LIKE I SAID IN MY TESTIMONY
AT THE EXAMPLE WAS SENT ON THE
STATE. THOSE WERE STATE
EMPLOYEES THAT WORKED IN DINING
SERVICES AND THERE WAS. NO
DINING SERVICES BEING PROVIDED
ON CAMPUS THE CAMPUS WAS
LARGELY SHUTTERED. AND SO WE
THEN HAD TO BECAUSE THERE'S A
LACK OF WORK AND A LACK OF
FUNDS RELATED TO IT WE HAD TO
THEN LATE NOTICE THOSE FOLKS.
BUT LIKE I ALSO SAID IN MY
TESTIMONY IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AND MEETING CONFERRING
WITH THESE UNITS TO REALLY TRY
TO FIND GOOD PLACES FOR A PLACE
THAT WERE THERE MAY BE A
CLASSIFICATION OR TWO THAT MAY
BE ABLE TO GO FROM BACK AND
FORTH- IN THE CASE OF CINEMA.
OF THOSE WITH SERVICE A NUMBER
OF THOSE WHO SERVICE EMPLOYEES
WERE CONVERTED OVER TEXT AUDIO
OR THEY WERE ABLE TO BE RE
HIRED ON A TEMPORARY BASIS SORT
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN IN
ORDER FOR THAT TO HAPPEN. BUT
AT SOME POINT IT DOES HAVE TO
GIVE WHERE YOU YOU DO RUN OUT
OF FUNDS IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE
WE HAVE WE WOULD HAVE TO
CONTINUE WITH SOME OF THESE
LAYOFFS. BUT THEY'RE. THERE
THAT IS A KIND OF A FOR I
RESORT AND TERMS OF. IF WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY AND BECAUSE
THAT SERVICES NO LONGER BEING
PROVIDED DURING THE PANDEMIC
THEM THAT'S TO BE THE CASE
NOBODY COMES TO THEM HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE REHIRED WITH
THINGS CHANGE WITH THE
POTENTIAL PANDEMIC LEAVES WE
HAVE A VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME
WHERE EMPLOYEES CAN HAVE
ANYWHERE BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE
YEARS TO. FIRST FIRST RIGHT OF
RETURN BACK TO WORK SO THAT'S
THAT'S ANOTHER ADDED BENEFIT SO
IT'S UNFORTUNATE WE'RE AT THIS
POINT IN SOME INSTANCES- BUT
IT'S A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF THE
FOLKS SYSTEM WIDE. AS LONG AS
THINGS DON'T CONTINUE TO SPIRAL
DOWN IN TERMS OF THE PANDEMIC
AND STATE FUNDING WE HOPE THAT
WE CAN MITIGATE THIS EVEN
FURTHER WITH HIRING FREEZES AND
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS BUT IF
THINGS GET WORSE- I CAN'T
PROMISE TO YOU THAT THERE WILL
NOT BE ADDITIONAL LAYOFF
NOTICES IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER AMBER.
THANK YOU AND- MY QUESTION IS
CAN BE FOR YOU MISTER STORM IF
I CAN- FIRST I WANT TO ACTUALLY
HIGHLIGHT ENROLLMENT IT APPEARS
THAT NATIONALLY WE'VE HAD
ENROLLMENT DECREASED
APPROXIMATELY 4% AND YES THERE
ARE THREE CAMPUSES IN THE CSU
SYSTEM THAT ARE SHOWING ALL
TIME RECORD HIGH ENROLLMENTS
WHETHER IT'S SACRAMENTO STATE.
FRESNO STATE OR CSU BAKERSFIELD
AND WOULD LIKE AND HOPE YOU
COULD OR YOU MAY PUNCH TO-
ROBERT NELSON WHO'S COMING
LATER TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
BEST PRACTICES THAT THOSE
INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING TO
ENCOURAGE ENROLLMENT TENDS TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WELL YOU
KNOW I THINK I DON'T KNOW ALL
THE REASONS WHY OUR ROLE THAT
IS TAKING OFF IN THOSE
PARTICULAR AREAS. I WILL SAY
THOUGH THAT WITH THE CENTRAL
pTALKING ABOUT A CENTRAL VALLEY
CAMPUSES RIGHT. YOU JUST SEALED-BY A LARGER GROWTH IN IN THE
POPULATION- GOING THAT
DIRECTION- YOU ALSO HAVE I
THINK THE INSTANCE OF FOR NOW
THIRTY YEARS YOU HAVE IT BEING
BEATEN TO EVERY CHILD'S HEAD IN
SCHOOL. THAT YOU SHOULD GO ON
TO TRY TO BE A FOUR YOU'RE A
COLLEGE STUDENT RIGHT IT'S SO
YOU HAVE A EXCEEDING NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT ARE WANTING HER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE WANTING
TO GO TO SCHOOL. AND GO TO
HIGHER AT REPUBLIC THE OTHER
FACTOR IS OF COURSE- DATE THERE
ARE ARE ARE. NO OPTIONS FOR
LESS OPTIONS FOR EMPLOYMENT
THEN. I SAY THEY WERE IN THE
RECENT PAST- BUT I THINK YOU
SEE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT YOU SEE THAT
THERE IS A HUGE DEMAND GROWING
AT THE CENTRAL VALLEY THERE.
AND I THINK THAT'S A VERY GOOD
THING- BECAUSE- HISTORICALLY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS AS NOT
HAD. EXCEEDINGLY HIGH RATES OF.
HIGHER ED. I PARTICIPATION IT
GRADUATION TENS OF TETRA. BUT
MAYBE MAYBE A PRESIDENT NELSON
COULD SHUT A LITTLE BIT BETTER
LIGHT ON IT FOR FROM THE
SIXTIES PERSPECTIVE. I MAY BE
BIASED BUT AS A CENTRAL VALLEY
NATIVE I THINK OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MANY IN MY COMMUNITY ALLOW
US TO ALSO GET BACK TO THIS
GREAT STATE SO. I'M QUITE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE INTO BOTH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND SO MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISTURBING. MY NEXT QUESTION
FOR YOU MISTER STORM THOUGH IF
I COULD- I'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT
ABOUT FLEXIBILITY AND- ONE OF
THE FLEXIBILITIES WE DID WITHIN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
WAS LOOKING OUT READ THE
ABILITY TO RE DIRECT ON SPENT-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS AND
WANTED TO ASK YOU IF THAT WAS
SOMETHING YOU HAVE. A BEGUN TO
DO TO MEET TO HELP TO COVER THE
INSTRUCTION AS WELL AS THE-
OTHER OPERATING COSTS. WELL I
THINK IN THE SHORT ANSWER IS AT
THIS POINT WE ARE. NOT FLEXING
THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE MONEY
TO BE USED OPERATE- EXPENSES AT
THIS POINT. IN THE PRIMARY
REASON FOR THAT. IS THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF NEW
STATE FUNDING. OR BOND FUNDING
FROM GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND
VOTES TO BE ABLE TO.
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS OUR MOST
PRESSING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS- RIGHT NOW OUR FOR OUR
ONE OF OUR FIRST APPROACHES IN
TERMS OF. SATISFIED WITH THE
FINANCIAL NEEDS OF THE
OPERATING FUND OUR CORE OUR
CORE FOR OUR CORPORATE JET IS
USING OUR RESERVES AS DIRECTED
WITHIN THE BUDGET ACT. AND THEN
ALSO USING SOME OF THESE OTHER
TOOLS THAT I'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE ABOUT HIRING FREEZES.
AND REDUCING TRAVEL THAT SORT
OF THING WE REALLY WANT TO TRY
TO PROTECT THE USE OF THAT-
THAT REMAINING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ONE WE HAD A LOT OF
A LOT OF CAMPUSES THAT WERE ON
THE BRINK AND ARE STILL MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION TOWARDS
FIXING SOME OF THE ROCK MORE
PRESSING NEEDS. AND WITH THE
FAILURE OF PROP THIRTEEN ON THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT WITH
NO FORESEEABLE G. O. BONDS- FOR
FACILITIES GOING FORWARD AND
WITH US IN A IN A DOWNWARD
ECONOMIC CYCLE RIGHT NOW. WE
JUST FEEL AT THIS POINT LET'S
LET'S HOLD THAT FLEXIBILITY AT
BAY AND TRY TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE KEY
THINGS BECAUSE EVENTUALLY
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THOSE
THINGS FAIL YOU AND IT'S
PROBABLY BEST TO ADDRESS THEM
NOW THE WAIT UNTIL THE END.
WHEN YOU HAVE NO MONEY
POTENTIALLY IN YOUR IN THE IN
THE IN THE DEPTHS OF HAVING A
REALLY TOUGH BUDGETARY TIME AS
A CAMPUS AND THEN YOU HAVE A
WATER LIKE GO OUT OR THE ROOF
IS THIS WINTER WAS THE WINTER
THAT PRINT IT. AND SO OUR
CAMPUSES ARE STILL STILL
HOLDING TO THE USE OF THAT
MONEY- WE'VE GIVEN THE
DIRECTION TO THE CAMPUS IS TO
CONTINUE DOWN THAT ROAD. IF
THINGS DO PERSISTENT GET WORSE
I THINK THAT YOU MAY SEE A
CHANGE POTENTIALLY BUT AT THIS
POINT WE WANT TO TRY TO PROTECT
THE SMALL AMOUNT OF TO FOR ME
THIS MONEY THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. FOR THE BEST USE WE
GET TODAY. I JUST SIMPLY JUST
ONE TO IT UP TO I HAVEN'T HEARD
IT AND DISCUSS. THUS FAR TODAY
AND IT IS ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOL CHEST. FOR US TO BE RIGHT
TO ADDRESS AS WE GO FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER LIVING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU TO THE PANELISTS FOR- FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING
MISTER SNOW REYES. A POINT THAT
I WANTED TO GO OVER WITH HIM
BUT ALSO WITH YOU SEE- AND I
APPRECIATE. ALL THE EXTRAS THAT
YOU'RE BRINGING TO THIS- WE'RE%
DEALING WITH- YOU'D MENTION
ENROLLMENT FIGURES. FOR NORTH
BAY NORTH COAST SERVING
CAMPUSES FROM SAN FRANCISCO
STATE TO HUMBOLDT. AND WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH BOTH THE
DOUBLE WHAMMY OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO MULTIPLE YEARS OF WILD
FIRES. THAT HAVE BOTH- OF
COURSE. BURNED DOWN THE HOMES
OF. STUDENTS AND PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS EVEN THE UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENT AT CINEMA STATE BUT
ALSO PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS. AND
I WANT TO ASK YOU- BUT BOTH
SYSTEMS BUT TED BUT I. YOU FOR
CSU YOU'RE SERVING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES YOU SEE. WOULD BE
MORE MATRICULATING FROM THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND WHETHER R NOT
YOU SEEN. THE IMPACTS OF BOTH.
THE WILD FIRES. OVER THOSE
YEARS AND THAT IMPACT ON
ENROLLMENT BECAUSE IT ON THE
STATE. IS MAYBE MORE OF A
COMMUNITY SERVING- IT DOES HAVE
THAT IT'S A BIT OF A
DESTINATION BUT YOU KNOW FIRST
HUMBLE BEING MUCH MORE SO BUT
ISTHERE THEY'RE ALL COMMUNITY
SERVING. IN ALL OF THOSE.
COUNTIES OR NEARBY COUNTIES
HAVE BEEN SO IMPACTED BY FIRES
AS THEY HAVE BEEN BY THE
PANDEMIC. THAT EITHER YOU HAVE
YOU SEEN. THE RESULTS OR OR
OUTCOMES BECAUSE OF THOSE-
OBSTACLES FOR STUDENTS TO
ENROLL IN IT AND MATRICULATING.
OR COULD YOU BE MORE SENSITIVE
TO THAT AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S MUCH MORE MY QUESTION.
FOR YOU SEE WOULD BE. HOW HAVE
YOU ADAPTED FOR- FOR THOSE
CHALLENGES THAT THOSE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS OR
RETURNING STUDENTS MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. ALREADY ALL STAR
DENNIS LEVINE- SO I THINK IT'S
A VERY VERY GOOD POINT- WE DO-
I LIKE SEE IF YOU WE DO HAVE A-
A- APPLICATION DEADLINE OF
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH IT IS
EXTENDED TO. DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST FOUR- FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS BUT- THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE HAVE EXTENDED THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF
WILDFIRES AND THE NOT ONLY THE
INABILITY. FOR OUR STUDENTS TO-
APPLY BUT ALSO THE ABILITY OF
SEVERAL OF THEM TO TAKE
STANDARDIZED TESTS ARE BACK
WHEN WE REQUIRED STANDARDIZED
TESTS SO WE HAVE. OUR EXTENDED
THAT- YOU KNOW CAMPUS AS WELL
WE ARE NOT IN THE DIRECT- ZONE
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED QUITE A BIT
BY- THE- EQUALITY AND WE HAVE
JUST ADOPTED A SYSTEM WIDE. AIR
QUALITY STANDARD ALL RIGHT SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE UNIFORMS
VISIONS ON WHEN I CAMPUS IS-
WHEN CLASSES ARE HELD WHEN
OUTDOOR WORK IN ATHLETIC
ACTIVITY- I TAKES PLACE BUT- I
THINK THE VERY GOOD WE'VE NOT
SEEN ANY DECLINES- WE DON'T.
QUITE HAVE IS AS MUCH A
REGIONAL A STUDENT POPULATION
AS THE AS THE CAL STATE SYSTEM
SO WE HAVE NOT SEEN DECLINES-
BASED ON THIS BUT I DO THINK WE
WANT TO BE A PRETTY.
PARTICULARLY COGNIZANT OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO MAY BE FACING- I
CHALLENGES BEYOND THE PANDEMIC
IN TERMS OF THEIR APPLICATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER ROSTRUM. BUT
FOR THIS ISSUES PER. IS THAT- I
THINK YOU'RE COMPLETELY RIGHT
MR LEVINE THAT THE FACT THAT.
YOU HAVE ALL THESE OTHER THINGS
ON TOP OF THE PANDEMIC.
AFFECTING HUMBLE IN CINEMA IN
SAN FRANCISCO THE LIFE TAKE. I
THINK WHAT I THINK ONE THING
FROM THE FROM CINEMA AND A
HUMBLE PERSPECTIVE IS THAT.
THERE'S AND THIS APPLIES TO
CHICO AS WELL IS THAT THOSE
CAMPUSES DRAW A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF THAT THEIR STUDENTS
FROM OUT OF AREA AROUND A
REGION. AND SO YOU SEE PART OF
THAT PLAYING OUT EVEN THIS
YEAR- WITH THE FACT THAT- UP.
YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT
INSTINCTIVE NATURE DON'T TO
WANT TO. STAY AT HOME AND NOT
GO ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE STATE
IN ORDER TO GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY OVER THERE- SO THAT
MIGHT BE PART OF THE PSYCHOLOGY
OF IT BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING IN
TERMS OF THE DISSERVICE TO
THOSE REGIONAL STUDENTS. UP
THERE IS EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT A
WEALTH OF. OPPORTUNITY THAT IS
EXTENDED TO ALL THOSE LOCAL
STUDENTS SO IF YOU'RE A IF
YOU'RE A NORTH STATE STUDENT OR
YOU'RE IN THAT THE HUMBLE AREA
OR IN THE SNOWBERRY THERE'S-
THERE'S- AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY THERE- SO
IT IT'S NOT A- IT'S NOT A-
SITUATION WHERE- STUDENTS
LOCALLY ARE ARE. ARE HAVING TO
COMPETE WITH OUT OF AREA
STUDENTS THERE'S A DIFFERENT
DYNAMIC THERE AND IT AND THAT
IS IN THE CASE IN TERMS OF
ADMISSIONS I THINK THE ONE
CHALLENGES THOUGH OF COURSE IS
THAT- YET THE JUST THAT. THE
DESIRE TO BE ENROLLED IN THOSE
CAMPUSES AT THIS POINT WHATEVER
WHATEVER THE TREND IS IN TERMS
OF THE- AND- AND- IT STUDENTS
ATTENDING. THEY JUST HAPPEN TO
BE DOWN HUMBOLDT HAS HAD A
LONGER STRETCH OF THIS- THEY'VE
GONE BACK SEVERAL- ACADEMIC
YEARS WHERE THEIR ENROLLMENT
HAS BEEN SOFT. SO NUMBERS ONLY
BEEN EXPERIENCING THAT LATELY
BUT INTERNET BUT BUT ACT THE
RIVER QUESTION OF WHETHER THOSE
STUDENTS LOCALLY ARE BEING
SERVED. AT THAT UNIVERSITY
THERE'S AMPLE OPPORTUNITY THE
QUESTION IS GETTING THROUGH ALL
OF THESE WILDFIRES AND ALL
THESE PANDEMICS AND ALL THE
OTHER PRESSURES ECONOMIC
PRESSURES WHETHER THEY'RE ABLE
TO ATTEND OR NOT THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY DRIVEN BY. THE CHOICE OF
THE STUDENT FAMILY THEMSELVES.
I THINK MISTRESS NOW. OKAY YOU
I ROBUST QUESTIONING THEIR
FRIEND UC AND CSU ABOUT THIS
ISSUE WE HAVE TWO OTHER MAJOR
SEGMENTS IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH TWO
MILLION STUDENTS AND ARE
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE SO WE HAVE AT LEAST SET
NEVER MET WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE VICE CHANCELLOR OF
ALEX GRAVES. WITH THE
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CALIFORNIA SERVICE
START WITH LEE SETS. CAN YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF BOTH THE
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TO
AND HIRED COMMITTEE. I DO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING TAKING TIME TO LISTEN
TO OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTION. MY NAME IS WITH
THAT AND IT AND THE- I SEEM TO
RECALL FINANCING FACILITIES
PLANNING I HAVE THE HONOR OF
WORKING TO REPRESENT TWO POINT
ONE MILLION STUDENTS AT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN COLLEGES.
THE STATE'S CALIFORNIA'S ME
COLLEGES PROVIDE A RANGE OF
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS AIMED AT
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY IT
STUDENTS SEEKING FOUNDATIONAL
SKILLS CERTIFICATES TO ADVANCE
THEIR CAREERS OR TO EARN A
DEGREE TO TRANSFER. TODAY I AM
GOING TO SHARE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF OUR EFFORTS TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED OF EDUCATION. AND OUR
EFFORTS TO ENGAGE IRAN ROLE
STUDENTS AND HOW WE MORE. THAT
WERE ALLOCATED BY THE STATE. AS
THE WORLD CONTINUES TO GRAPPLE
WITH THE CONSEQUENCESOF COVER
NINETEEN THAT AREN'T EVEN
IMPACTED IT EQUITIES OF OUR
ECONOMIC RECESSION HAVE BEEN
GROSSLY APPARENT CALIFORNIA
FACES THE DICHOTOMY OF AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY THAT
EXACERBATE INEQUALITIES FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
WILL FURTHER ENRICHING THE
WEALTHY. THE STATE NEED TO PLAN
FOR AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY WE
BELIEVE THAT SUCH A PLAN SHOULD
INCLUDE CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HOW MANY CALLS. HAVE
BEEN ESSENTIAL TO THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
SINCE SPRING OUR COLLEGES HAVE
OPERATED EMERGENCY CENTERS COBA
NINETEEN PATIENT OVERFLOW
FACILITIES AND COLIN NINETEEN
TESTING SITES FOR THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONTINUE TO EDUCATE
THE MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S
NURSES AND FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL
AS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS. BUT OUR STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN THE HARDEST HIT
POPULATION IN ALL OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. TAKE FOR EXAMPLE
TONYA A STUDENT AT CHAFEE AND
WORKING MOTHER WHO MADE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION OF CAUSING
HER EDUCATION TO WORK ANOTHER
JOB PART TIME JUST TO
SUPPLEMENT FOR LOST INCOME
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. STUDENTS
LIKE HONEY I DON'T HAVE
FINANCIAL AID AS A SAFETY NET
WELL TWO THIRDS THIS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ATTEND
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ONLY 7% RECEIVE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THROUGH CAL GRANT. AND
IN A SURVEY AND TOWN HALLS BY
BOAT C. SACK IN THE STUDENT
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA GIVE ME
COLLEGES. REPORTED LOSING MOST
OF THE FINANCIAL INCOME AND
HAVING CHANGES. AND THEIR
FINANCIAL ARRANGEMENTS. FURTHER
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL STIMULUS
OF WITH NOTRE ABSENT FOR SOME
OF OUR POPULATIONS SUCH AS
DREAMERS PART TIME STUDENTS
AND- IN THIS STIMULUS DOLLARS.
AND THOSE RESOURCES OR INSTEAD
OF SUPPLANTED OR TEMPORARILY
FILLED THROUGH RESERVES AND
OTHER A CATEGORICAL. THESE ARE
ALL TEMPORARY BANDAID ON ISSUE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE TOPIC
TODAY IS REALLY TO FOCUS ON
AREAS LIKE ENROLLMENT SO SURE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE SAW
FOR SPRING AS WELL WHAT WE'RE
SEEING FOR A FALL. TODAY'S CALL
COPULATION HAS SHIFTED ITS FAR
MORE DIVERSE IN FACT 64%
CALIFORNIA'S ENROLLEES OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND 40% OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE TWENTY FIVE
AND OLDER WE SERVE LOTS OF
ADULT LEARNERS. IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGE
IS A PLACE GREATER FOCUS ON
OUTREACH TO POST TRADITIONAL
STUDENT POPULATION. THIS WORK
IS CHALLENGING BUT IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY OF THE STATE.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE CALIFORNIA THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR LEADERS CAN
CONTINUE TO BE A STEADFAST
PARTNER. SO THAT WE DON'T LOSE
MOMENTUM. AND CONTRARY TO SOME
OF OUR SPEC. AND WORRIES
COMPLETIONS IN SPRING TWENTY
pOUR SYSTEM. AND FAST ACTION
LIMITED THAT THE CLIENTS THAT
WE SAW IN SPRING TO DEATH UNDER
1% MUCH IS ATTRIBUTED TO THE
RESPONSIVENESS OF OUR SYSTEM
COMMITMENT OF OUR STAFF FACULTY
AND OUR LEADERS TO MAINTAIN
MOMENTUM AND FOCUS ON PUTTING
STUDENTS FIRST AND ADVANCING
THEIR SUCCESS. WE PUT STUDENTS
FIRST BY GIVING THEM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT ON ANY OF
THE MAJOR ISSUES WE TRANSITION
TO ONLINE WITHIN A MATTER OF A
WEEK. WE ISSUED GUIDANCE
FLEXING AND ALLOWING THE USE OF
SOME OF OUR CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS FOR A ONE TIME
EMERGENCY GRANTS BECAUSE WE
KNEW THAT STUDENTS HAD A
FINANCIAL GAP THEY WERE DEALING
WITH. WE MADE MERGING TWO
GRANTS EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO
RECEIVE WE PROVIDED LAPTOPS AND
WIFI HOTSPOTS FOR STUDENTS
SENATE MEAL PROGRAMS. ISSUED
EXCUSE WITHDRAWALS PROVIDED
STUDENT FEE REFUNDS THESE RAPID
AND FAST ACTING STUDENT
CENTERED ACTIONS MADE SURE
STRUGGLING STUDENTS ARE NOT
PLACED ON ACADEMIC PROBATION
THEY DIDN'T LOSE ACCESS TO
THEIR FINANCIAL AID I HAD SOME.
AT LEAST MODEST FUNDS TO
NAVIGATE THE CHALLENGES
PRESENTED BY THE PANDEMIC THESE
APPS ACTION STOP THE WORSE FROM
HAPPENING. BUT OUR CHALLENGES
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
ARE FRALEY ATTACHED TO
EDUCATION OUR STUDENTS ARE
FACING MANY OF THE ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL CHALLENGES THAT ARE NOW
UBIQUITOUS ACROSS HIGHER
EDUCATION UNCERTAINTY IN
EMPLOYMENT DAY CARE UNCERTAINTY
SHIFTING WORK SCHEDULES.
UNANTICIPATED EXPENSES. MANY OF
THESE THIS AND ARE NOT NEW FOR
OUR STUDENTS BUT THEY'VE BEEN
HIGH BY POPE IN NINETEEN. BUT
ARE STILL PART OF THE INSTANT
OF ARE STILL HAVE TO HAVE HAD
TO OVERCOME ALL THE TIME. IN
THIS SIGNED POSTER CLEAR. ARE
STILL DESPERATELY NEED
FINANCIAL AID ACCESS. LET ME
TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
FALL. WE HAVE A DECENTRALIZED
SYSTEM- LIMITED INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY- PROVIDE A LACK OF
REAL TIME INFORMATION WILL HAVE
ACTUAL BY JANUARY FIFTEENTH
WHEN AND COLLEGES AND DISTRICTS
REPORT. MOST ON ON DEFAULT
TWENTY TWENTY TERM. SO IN ORDER
TO OBTAIN PRELIMINARY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING THIS FALL WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE R. P.
GROUP. IN OUR PRELIMINARY
SAMPLE INDICATES THAT HEAD
COUNT ENROLLMENT IS DOWN BY
ABOUT 7% FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY. BASED ON THE SAMPLE FTS
IS DOWN BY AN ESTIMATED 10% FOR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY. AN EARLY
SURVEY DATA INDICATES TO
POSSIBLE PATTERNS STUDENTS ARE
TAKING FEWER COURSES AND
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN ARE FACING GREATER
CHALLENGES. WE'VE SEEN SIMILAR
DATA. IN A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
CENSUS SURVEY THAT INDICATED
THAT LOW INCOME AND LOWER AND
OLDER STUDENTS WERE MORE LIKELY
TO PASS THEIR EDUCATIONAL PLANS
FOR FALL. BECAUSE THEY HAD
INTERRUPTIONS IN THEIR INCOME.
BY SUPPORTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
FEED THESE TRENDS. THE CANCERS
OFFICE HAS DONE A LOT OF WORK
TO TRY TO RE ENGAGE IN SUPPORT
OF DISTRICTS IS IN RE ENGAGING
STUDENTS WE'VE LAUNCHED TWO
MAJOR ENROLLMENT CAMPAIGNS OF
IT ACROSS THE STATE. THESE TO
COMMUNICATION AND MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS FOCUSED ON STAYING
AND ROLLED AND LATE START SO
THAT WE CAN PROMOTE COURSES
THAT WERE AVAILABLE LATER IN
THE SEMESTER FOR OUR STUDENTS
THESE CAMPAIGNS FOCUSED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA MUSIC SITES THAT.
WERE OFFERED IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. AND SPRING MAKE
COLLEGE HAVE. NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THE DOLLARS
AND YOU I'M MAC. THIS CALL AND
TECH. EQUIPMENT TRAINING TO A
QUICK TRANSITION TO ONLINE-
ADDING NEW METALLIC EASE OF
LEARNING AND ALL OF THE
SPECIFICALLY ON TECHNOLOGY R.
COSTA BEEN ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION YOU CAN VIEW ON
THAT. FUNDS COMBINED ARE
COLLEGES OF LOST EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN IRAQ REVENUE FROM
ENTERPRISE SERVICES LIKE
CAFETERIAS BOOKSTORES PARKING
LOTS AND OTHER SOURCES THAT ARE
NEXT TO OFFSET KEY ACADEMIC
SUPPORT ON CAMPUSES. IN SPRING
OUR COST PER STUDENT HAVE
INCREASED NEARLY 4% WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS FIGURE
WILL GO UP AND FALL TWENTY
TWENTY. FURTHER CERTAIN COURSES
DON'T HOLD VIRTUAL MODELS THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OFFER AND
ARE CHALLENGING TO OFFER DURING
THE PANDEMIC. THESE INCLUDE
COURSES IN NURSING HOMES AND
MEDICAL CENTERS CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS PHYSICAL
EDUCATION AND OTHERS LIKE CTE
HALF TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT AND
LIMITED CAPACITY FOR THE SAFETY
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR FACULTY
FOR COLLEGES REDUCE CAPACITY
MEANS INCREASED COSTS. WILSHIRE
BRIEF WHAT WE GET WITH. AND YOU
OF THE TWENTY TWO BUDGET. OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVED
TOTAL DEFERRALS OF ONE POINT
FOUR FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
APPORTIONMENT FROM. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND AS YOU KNOW DEFERRALS
CAN PERMIT AN AUTHORIZED
DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN
PROGRAMMATIC LEVELS BY CREATING
OUT YOUR OBLIGATIONS AND WHILE
THEY PREVENT CONCERT WE ARE WE-
WHILE THESE ARE PREFERRED OVER.
WE KNOW THAT THEY CAN MAKE A
LIMITED INCREASES IN THE
FUTURE. AND SO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WAS TASKED WITH
DETERMINING METHODOLOGY FOR
DISTRIBUTING THE BURDEN OF
DEFERRALS THIS YEAR AND
TRADITIONALLY DEFERRALS ARE NOT
SPREAD EQUALLY AMONG ALL
DISTRICTS AND FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON DISTRICTS
THAT RELY MORE HEAVILY ON THE
STATE FOR THEIR FUNDING. THESE
DISTRICTS ARE OFTEN ONES THAT
SERVE MORE LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
AND HAVE LESS PROPERTY WEALTH.
AND AS A RESULT THEY HAVE A
**** GREATER SHARE OF A STATE
FUNDING. AND THESE DISTRICTS IN
THESE SITUATIONS OFTEN HAVE TO
BORROW MORE MONEY IN ORDER TO
MEET PAYROLL AND OTHER STUDENTS
AND ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. SO
RECOGNIZING THIS THESE
INEQUITIES THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE CRAFTED AN APPROACH THAT
INSURED EACH DISTRICT RECEIVED
AT LEAST 83% OF THEIR FUNDING
FROM ALL SOURCES THIS INCLUDED
PROPERTY TAXES AND ENROLLMENT
FEES. WITH THIS EQUITY
ADJUSTMENT ALL SOURCE THE
FUNDING VERY VALUE WAITED AND
LOWER WEALTH DISTRICTS DIDN'T
HAVE TO CARRY THE BURDEN OF
BARLEY. SO AND THIS HEALTH CAN
CALL. HAVE PROVED TO BE
CRITICAL THE STATE AGAINST COLD
IT WE ARE THE LARGEST PROVIDER
OF WORKFORCE TRAINING AND WE
REPRESENT A PATH TO PRIME. TO
PROSPERITY AND ECONOMIC
VIABILITY FOR ALL. OUR STUDENTS
ARE MOTHERS VETERANS WORKING
LEARNERS DREAMERS AND SO MUCH
MORE THIS POPULATION
CONSTITUTES THE CORE OF OUR
WORKFORCE. THEY NEED US AND WE
NEED THEM. THIS STORY THERE'S A
STORY THAT RESONATES WITH ME
ONE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
NEWEST COLLEGE MADERA. HEY
LITTLE SCHOOL WHO'S A FAST. AND
ARMY NATIONAL GUARD. IN HIS
TIME TO THE SPRING HE WAS
DEPLOYED TO ANOTHER PART OF THE
STATE TO HELP WITH FOOD
DISTRIBUTION AS PART OF THE
EMERGENCY. AND THOUGH HE HAD AN
INTERRUPTION TO HIS EDUCATION
HE IS COMMITTED TO COMPLETING
HIS WORKFORCE AND SERVING HIS
COMMUNITY. THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE WE
TRAIN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
FIRST RESPONDERS AND- THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IMPORTANT SO IF
WE HAMSTRING CALIFORNIA'S MANY
COLLEGES NOW. WE WON'T BE READY
AND AVAILABLE TO TRAIN THE
WORKFORCE AND BE THERE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION THIS NEXT YEAR
AHEAD AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL
KEEP IN MIND THE VALUE THAT WE
BRING TO CALIFORNIA. AND THE
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE. THANK
YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS THANK YOU LOSE THAT
AND NOW GO TO ALEX GRAVES. ALEX
YOU MAY BEGIN. GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MY NAME IS ALEX GRACE
WITH THE ICC YOU. AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE. ON THE OVER EIGHTY
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE.
FROM SIMPSON UNIVERSITY IN
REDDING. YOUR P. U. S. AT USC
AND MANY MORE UP AND DOWN THIS
GREAT STATE. COLLECTIVELY OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND ROLL JUST
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATES. ABOUT 20% OF
THE UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION IN
THE STATE- AND THREE QUARTERS
GIVE OR TAKE OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION ARE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. AT THE
OUTSET OF KOBE NINETEEN IN THE
SPRING. AT SCHOOLS MOVED
SWIFTLY TO GET THEIR STUDENTS
HOME SAFELY TO IDENTIFY
STUDENTS WHO FOR VARIOUS
REASONS NEEDED TO REMAIN ON
CAMPUS. AND ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS GOT THE LAPTOPS
HOT SPOTS- TABLETS AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT THEY NEEDED
TO CONTINUE. THEIR STUDIES-
WHILE ALSO SHIFTING STUDENT
SERVICES TO AN ONLINE MODALITY.
I'D LIKE TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON
TRENDS WE SEE RELATING TO THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. THE ADJUSTMENTS ARE
INSTITUTIONS OF MADE IN
RESPONSE TO THAT AND WHAT ROLE
MEANT ARE INSTITUTIONS LIKE
THIS ACADEMIC YEAR. SO THE
IMMEDIATE AND ONGOING IMPACTS
OF KOBE NINETEEN ON
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCES HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT- THIS SPRING WE
SURVEYED OUR CFO IS FINDING
IMMEDIATE LOSSES IN EXCESS OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS-
JUST FOR ROOM AND BOARD-
REFINANCE- AND ENCLOSURES- IN
TERMS NOT COMPLETED. WITH THE
MEDIAN AMOUNT BEING ABOUT TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE SAW MEDIAN
LOSSES IN REVENUE FROM SUMMER
PROGRAMS AND FACILITY RENTALS
IN THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
AROUND ONE MILLION DOLLARS PER
INSTITUTION. AND JUST FOR
CONTEXT- THE MEDIAN ENDOWMENT
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS IS AROUND
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS- THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH IS RESTRICTED
FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES OF THOSE
WERE. SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
IMPACTS. INSTITUTE HAVE SEEN
ADDITIONAL BUDGET CHALLENGES
EMERGES THE PANDEMIC IS
CONTINUED. AND WHILE WE YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT A CENTRALIZED
SYSTEM AND DON'T HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA- WE DO SEE A
NUMBER OF EXAMPLES INSTANCES
ACROSS THE STATE THERE ARE
INSTITUTIONS LARGE AND SMALL. I
AM A FOURTEEN DOLLAR A
PROJECTED BUDGET SHORTFALL FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
FIFTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
AUBURN. THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
AT OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE AND
TWELVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AT HARVEY MUDD COLLEGE
AMONG OTHERS. ADDITIONALLY
SCHOOLS HAVE INCURRED
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO INVEST IN
NECESSARY TESTING- FACILITY
UPGRADES AND OTHER HEALTH AND
SAFETY MEASURES. FOR EXAMPLE
CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY IN ORANGE
COUNTY HAS SPENT EXCESSIVE
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS ON
VARIOUS HEALTH AND SAFETY
UPGRADES. INCLUDING OVER ONE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TESTING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
VENTILATION UPGRADES AND OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE WASHABLE MASKS TO
STUDENTS. SO OUR SCHOOLS
MANAGING THIS- THEY ARE. DOING
THEIR BEST TO MANAGE THESE
BUDGET ISSUES AND COST-
CHALLENGES. THREE THINGS LIKE
HIRING AND SALARY FREEZES-
CUTTING TRAVEL BUDGETS SALARIED
OPTIONS FOR SENIOR LEADERSHIP.
AND POSTPONING NONESSENTIAL
FACILITY CONSTRUCTION AND
RENOVATIONS. FURLOUGHS HAVE
ALSO OCCURRED AND IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE-
UNIVERSITIES HAVE GENERALLY
APPROACH THIS I WITH THE
PRINCIPLE OF DOING SO IN A
MANNER- THAT WILL BE THE LEAST
DISRUPTIVE TO THE ACADEMIC-
INSTRUCTION AND THE SERVICES
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS AND
LASTLY. SCHOOLS ARE CERTAINLY
LOOKING TO SEE WHAT SHORT TERM
FUNDRAISING THEY CAN DO- WHILE
ALSO SEEING WHAT OTHER
FLEXIBILITY AS THEY MAY HAVE.
WITHIN THE UNRESTRICTED FINDS
IT IN THEIR ENDOWMENTS. TURNING
TO ENROLLMENT THIS FALL AICC
YOU DID SURVEY OUR ADMISSION
AND ENROLLMENT STAFF- TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT IMPACT
HOPE IT HAS HAD ON THEIR
ENROLLMENT. WE HAD FIFTY SIX
INSTITUTIONS RESPOND WHO
COLLECTIVELY EDUCATE 91% OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS SO WE
FEEL LIKE IT'S A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE SAMPLE WE ASKED
TO COMPARE. TWENTY TWENTY AND
ROMANCE- TO THE OUT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AMONG FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN AMONG TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND ALSO RETURNING
STUDENTS. OVER THREE QUARTERS
OF INSTITUTIONS REPORTED
DECLINES IN HOUSTON AND RONIT
AND FIRST IN THAT ROLE THAT
OVERALL INSTITUTIONS SEEN
IMMEDIATELY DECLINE AROUND
SEVEN PERCENT. WITH DECREASES
ACROSS ALL THREE STUDENT
POPULATIONS INCLUDING 10% FOR
NEW STUDENTS AND 6% FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS. WE ALSO
ASKED ABOUT SUMMER MELT- AND
THE RESPONSES THERE WERE
FRANKLY. STAGGERING I'M NOT A
SINGLE INSTITUTION RESPONDED-
THAT THEIR SUMMER MELTED
DECREASED COMPARED TO THE PRIOR
YEAR OVER HALF OF INSTITUTIONS
RESPONDED THAT SUMMER MELT
SOMEWHAT HIGHER. BUT MORE
CONCERNING WAS THE 25230% AND
INSTITUTIONS WHO ESPONDED THAT
SUMMER MELT WAS MORE THAN 30%
HIGHER. THAN THE PRIOR YEAR.
SCHOOLS ALSO REPLIED THAT
DEFERRAL RATES WERE UP AND IN
SOME CASES AT HISTORIC LEVELS
NOT PREVIOUSLY SEEN AT THEIR
INSTITUTION- ONE REPORTED THEY
HAD FIVE TIMES AS MANY
DEFERRALS AS THE PRIOR YEAR.
AND ANOTHER REPORTED DEFERRAL
RATES WERE UP 80% SO IN CLOSING
AS I WRAP UP I JUST OFFER A FEW
OBSERVATIONS A FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. FIRST COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE CONTINUED
TO HAVE SOME POPULATION OF
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS YOU KNOW FOR
COURSES OR PROGRAMMES IT CAN'T
BE FULLY ONLINE OR FOR STUDENTS
WHO CONTINUE TO LIVE IN ON
CAMPUS HOUSING- THE COST OF
TESTING IS SIGNIFICANT. AT
LEAST IN OUR EXPERIENCE SO FAR
WE'RE GENERALLY TALKING SEVENTY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A TEST. AND
SO ANYTHING THAT STATE CAN DO
TO HELP BRING THESE COSTS DOWN
I WOULD BE GREATLY APPRECIATED
WELCOME BY INSTITUTIONS AND
HELP FREE UP CRITICAL RESOURCES
FOR OTHER MISSION CRITICAL
PURPOSES. SECOND THE ENROLLMENT
DECLINES THAT WE SEE AND
NATIONAL REPORTING AND OUR OWN
SURVEY DATA. INDICATE A MASSIVE
DISRUPTION WITHIN HIGHER
EDUCATION ACROSS ALL TYPES OF
INSTITUTIONS ABOUT IMMEDIATELY
AND FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS IN
THE PIPELINE TH THESE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE FELT FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. AND
CERTAINLY FOR OUR SECTOR I THE
6% DECLINE IN TRANSFER STUDENT
LOAN IT CERTAINLY RAISES SOME
CONCERNS- REGARDING STATUTORY
TARGETS FOR THE EIGHTEEN WHICH
OF COURSE IS TIED TO THE- GRANT
AWARD AMOUNT FOR OUR STUDENTS-
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE. PROMOTING
COLLEGE ATTENDANCE FOR STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THE INSTITUTION-
PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES ARE
ALL OVER THIS STATE IN ANY
GIVEN REGION- YOU'RE LIKELY TO
SEE THE MAJORITY OF FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONSBEING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES. WE HAVE
THIRTY SIX IN THE LA REGION
ALONE SEVEN ORANGE COUNTY.
FLORIDA EMPIRE AND SIX IN SAN
DIEGO THIS IS EXAMPLES. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
AND HIGHER EDUCATION RIGHT NOW.
BUT I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT IT
IS AS IMPORTANT AS EVER- TO
ENCOURAGE AND PROMOTE COLLEGE-
FOR STUDENTS SO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND. I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS COMMON FROM THE DASH.
I I'M GONNA CRUSH TO ALEX IT'S
MY AND THAT SOME OF THE SMALLER
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES. AND
UNIVERSITIES THAT HAVE- SMALLER
RESERVES HAVE BEEN GREATLY
IMPACTED IS THERE ANY DANGER OF
SEEING ANY OF THESE SMALLER
PRIVATE COLLEGES HAVE ENDED TO
CLOSE THEIR DOORS. SURE THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO SAY
RIGHT NOW GIVE IN JUST YOU KNOW
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE AND THE
LIGHT AT THE END OF THIS TUNNEL
IS- CERTAINLY WE HAVE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE VERY-
SMALL ENDOWMENTS- AND THEREFORE
YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
RESOURCES TO DRAW FROM- AND I
THINK YOU KNOW THEY ARE ALL.
SEEKING TO- ASSESS WHAT OTHER
OPTIONS THEY HAVE EITHER IN
TERMS OF. LINES OF CREDIT OR
OTHER YOU KNOW STOP GAP
MEASURES- TO HELP BRIDGE THIS
DIVIDE BUT CERTAINLY THE
LONGER- THIS DISRUPTION
CONTINUES- THE MORE. THEY HAVE
WILL BE FOR SOME OF OUR SMALLER
REGIONAL INSTITUTIONS. THANK
YOU ALEX. THIS MCCARTY. YES
THANK YOU- I APOLOGIZE I MISSED
THAT COMMUNITY CALLS MOST OF IT
PRESENTATION SO YOU MAY WANNA
WENT OVER THIS. AT LEAST THAT
BUT IF YOU CAN GIVE US A
SNAPSHOT IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. IN ENROLLMENT-
DROPPING. HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
YOU KNOW I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF AN IDENTICAL. STORIES BUT
THERE BEEN ANY SURVEYS FROM
YOUR CAMPUSES ON WHAT THAT. THE
TOP ISSUES ARE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
USUALLY WHEN YOU HAVE A
RECESSION. PEOPLE GO BACK TO
SCHOOL IN THE COMMUNICATIONS
BUT THIS IS A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF. PANDEMIC. IN A LOT OF OUR
WORKERS. YOU KNOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH A OWN ISSUES WITH THEIR
OWNFOR. THEY MAY HAVE KIDS AT
HOME AS WELL AND THEY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THEIR ONLINE.
EDUCATION SO- WHAT TYPE OF. OF
ANALYSIS DO WE HAVE IF ANY. SIX
MONTHS LATER. YEAH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. ONE OF
THE THINGS I SHARED IS THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE
THAT HAVE BEEN THE MOST
AFFECTED PERSONALLY BY THESE
CAN DAMAGE. BECAUSE THEY
STARTED THIS PANDEMIC. ALREADY
WITH LOCAL RESOURCES LOW ACCESS
TO FINANCIAL AID SO DIDN'T HAVE
THE SAFETY NETS. ANY JOB LOSSES
CHANGES IN WAGES AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SO WHAT WE SAW IN
SPRING WAS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
GENERALLY MAINTAIN ENROLLMENTS
THROUGHOUT. THE SPRING SEMESTER
WHILE WE WERE DOWN- JUST UNDER
1% FOR A FULL WE DON'T GET OUT
DAY INTO JAN FIFTEENTH WHAT WE
DID INSTEAD WAS A SEND A
STATEWIDE SURVEY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH ONE OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS.
AND BASED ON THAT SAMPLE WE'RE
SEEING THAT WE ARE DOWN ABOUT
7% OF N. F. TES. AND SO WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT IN SOME OF
THE EARLY ANALYSIS WE'RE SEEING
THAT STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN WERE LIKELY MOST
AFFECTED AND THAT STUDENTS MAY
STILL BE ON OUR CAMPUSES BUT
TAKING FEWER CLASSES. IT'S A
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT
THEM AS INDIVIDUALS IT'S GOING
TO BE KEY AS WE MOVE FORWARD
BOTH TO MAINTAIN OUR PIPELINE
TO AT UC AND CSU OF TRANSFERS
IN ACC YOU. BUT JUST GENERALLY
TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE. A
GENERATION OF STUDENTS. ARE YOU
ARE YOU THAT IT'S THE OLD OLDER
STUDENTS. IS YOU WOULD THINK
THAT THE YOUNGER STUDENTS WHICH
I MEASURE OF THE PERCENTAGE
WISE THAT YOU KNOW FRESH OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL ARE SIMILAR TO THE
CSU STUDENTS WHERE THEY'RE
THEY'RE THINKING HEY THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY REALLY DO MORE AND
TAKE MORE UNIT SO ARE YOU
FINDING SOME OF YOUR YOUNGER
STUDENTS ARE NOT ONLY. STICKING
OUT BUT ALSO. TAKING MORE UNITS
AND- TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
TIME THAT THERE. AT HOME
SENSUAL. WE'RE WE'RE VERY WE'RE
VERY INTERESTED IN DIGGING INTO
OUR DATA WENT COME JANUARY WHEN
WE HAVE ACTUAL NUMBERS- RIGHT
NOW WE'RE REALLY WORKING ON
SPECULATION BUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE LEARNED JUST
ON SURVEY DATA. IS THAT IN
SUMMER WE DID HAVE INCREASES IN
ENROLLMENT SO THAT PLAYS INTO
THIS CONCEPT THAT STUDENTS MAY
HAVE BEEN NOT TAKING ADDITIONAL
COURSES AS THEY PREPARED TO
ENTER FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
MAKING UP COURSES. OF VARIOUS
POSSIBLE SCENARIOS FOR FALL OF
BECAUSE 40% OF OUR POPULATION
IS ADULT LEARNERS ARE ASKED IF
THEY HAVE DEPENDENTS THAT ALSO
ARE BACK IN SCHOOL AND GYM
CLASSES. WE BELIEVE THIS COULD
HAVE ADDED ADDITIONAL PRESSURES
ON THEIR OVERALL LIFE UP BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT AGAIN AS
MENTIONED WE'RE VERY INTERESTED
IN AND WILL ANALYZE ONCE WE GET
FURTHER DATA ON FULL. TWENTY
TWENTY COME JANUARY. OKAY THANK
YOU. I THINK THAT KIND OF. DR
THANK YOU AND WAS THAT YOU HAD
A COMMENT- JUST A MOMENT AGO
THAT I REALLY WANT TO DRILL
INTO YOU SAID YOU NEED TO
SUPPORT THEM AS INDIVIDUALS AND
WHEN YOU SAID THAT THAT HAS
ECHOES WITHIN HEALTH CARE FOR
US TO THINK ABOUT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. AND
OFTENTIMES THERE ARE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF EDUCATION THAT
ALLOW CERTAIN STUDENTS TO DO
WELL OR TO PERFORM UNDER WHAT
WE SHOULD EXPECT AND SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION FOR YOU IS THAT
SINCE YOU REPRESENT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. IS WHAT ARE WE
CURRENTLY DOING TO MEET THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES I REMEMBER
ARAMBULA THAT QUESTION REALLY
ROOTED AT. SUPPORTING OUR END
OF IT THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE.
SO WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PUT
TOGETHER THIS YEAR HAS BEEN ON
A ONE TIME BASIS. ESSENTIALLY
PULLING FROM FUNDS IN ONE PLACE
TO SUPPLEMENT WITH OTHERS AND
WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONGOING COSTS THAT ARE
UNMATCHED. BY EITHER CARES OR
FEMA. AND SO ONE OF THE KEY
PIECES THAT WE ASK FOR IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE MENTAL
HEALTH. NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE
HIGHLIGHTED IN MULTIPLE TOWN
HALL SESSIONS BUT ALSO IN THEIR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
PRIORITIES. THAT THEY'RE ASKING
FOR AN INVESTMENT IN MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES POTENTIALLY
FROM PROP SIXTY THREE. THIS IS
THAT SOMETHING THE STATE HAS
DONE IN THE PAST INVESTING IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES ON
THEIR CAMPUSES OR CONNECTED TO
THE CAMPUS ITSELF. THAT'S GOING
TO BE KEY RIGHT NOW WHAT WE
HAVE- A SERIES OF- MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFFERED ONLINE VIRTUALLY. BUT
WE ALSO HAVE CAMPUS IS OPEN
FOR- CONNECTING THEM TO OF
COURSE PLANNING BUT- TO REALLY
GET AT THE ROOT OF THEIR
PERSONAL NEEDS I GOT INVESTMENT
PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDS WOULD BE
VERY VALUABLE. I'D LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH IF I COULD TO
VETERANS. THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
UC'S IN CSU'S AND HOW THEY-
TREAT OUR STUDENTS WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER LOUIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND- AND
THANK YOU VICE CHANCELLOR
NAVARETTE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY AND YOUR SENSITIVITY TO
STUDENTS AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT ENROLLMENT TRENDS AND-
MENTAL HEALTH PROBABLY IMPACTS
IS QUITE QUITE A BIT BUT THIS
IS A BROADER ISSUE BECAUSE OF
THE CHALLENGE OF THE PANDEMIC
AND- A TECHNOLOGY ADOPTION
LEARNING IN A DIFFERENT WAY
WHAT HAVE WE SEEN NOT JUST IN
IN MATRICULATION AS FAR AS YOU
KNOW RETURNING STUDENTS AND OUR
PEOPLE- IN ROLLING AT THIS
CAMPUS IS BUT TO. COURSE
COMPLETION ITSELF BECAUSE
PEOPLE WILL ENROLL IN A COURSE
BUT PERHAPS DROP OUT- AT SOME
OR DROP AWAY- AT SOME POINT IN
TIME THAT THAT MAYBE WE LEARNED
SOME LESSONS IN THE SPRING THAT
THAT WE TOOK WITH US THIS FALL
HOW WE'VE BEEN STRENGTHENING
THIS BECAUSE- COMMITTEE
COLLEGES PLAY SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN EVERY COUNTY- IN CORNER
OF OUR STATE- IT IS THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THIS IN A
GRANULAR WHY THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY GIVE. WE'VE LEARNED
A VARIETY OF THINGS FROM SPRING
ALONE AND AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM FALL. BUT ONE KEY
PIECE IS THAT AS- WE SAW IN THE
SPRING IS THAT. HOW QUICKLY WE
TRANSITION. OF HOW FLEXIBLE AND
ADAPTIVE FOR STAFF AND FACULTY
WAR REALLY MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN. OUR
COURSE SUCCESS RATES WE
GENERALLY THEY REMAIN PRETTY
STABLE. WHAT WE ALSO OFFERED IS
STUDENTS THE ABILITY TO HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED A AN EXCUSE
WITHDRAW. IT'S SOMETHING THAT
CONTINUES TO BE AVAILABLE TO
DISTRICTS THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE
IF A STUDENT EVER FACES AN
EMERGENCY SUCH AS A PANDEMIC.
HAVING THE WIDESPREAD KNOWLEDGE
OF THIS AS A WAY TO NOT
PENALIZE STUDENTS FINANCIAL
AID. OR THEIR ACADEMIC- THEIR
ACADEMIC PATHWAY HAS BEEN VERY
KEY. THE OTHER IS- HOW MUCH WE
NEED TO DIVERSIFY OUR ONLINE.
SUPPORT AS A SYSTEM ARE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF VARIOUS AT
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM THAT CAN
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. THOSE
HAVE BEEN KEY AND AGAIN WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DELVE INTO THIS
BECAUSE- WE WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO KEEP
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT THAT COMES
THROUGH OUR DOORS ENGAGED AND
ON THE RIGHT PATHWAY. THANK
THANK YOU MISS NAVARETTE FOR
FOLLOWING STUDENTS- SUCCESS AND
HOW IT'S IMPACTING THEM AND
PARTICULARLY. FOR THEIR THE
IMPACTS TO FINANCIAL AID
BECAUSE- COST OF LIVING IN SO
MANY OTHER EXPENSES THAT GO
INTO THIS THAT COULD BE PLACED
AT RISK BECAUSE OF. HOW
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING IT IS
FOR STUDENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO- TO RESPOND IN AND
BE. THE STUDENTS THAT THEY HAD
INTENDED TO BE. I ALSO WANT TO
HAVE. ASK ABOUT THE SENSITIVITY
TO- THE LEGISLATURE IS-
FUNDING. OF THE FIRST IN AND
NOW SECOND YEARS. OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FIRST EDENS AND HOW
THAT IS IN. OR NOT BY A- DROP
IN IN CLASS THAT THEY HAD AND
TO TAKE AND I KNOW YOU SAID
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE STAINED
KIND OF STATIC- BUT NONETHELESS
THERE ARE STUDENTS WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THIS DOES THAT PUT
AT RISK. ANY OF THEIR FREE- OR
YOU KNOW THE FEES THAT HAD BEEN
ANTICIPATED. FOUR I BELIEVE
YOU'RE SPECIFICALLY REFERRING
TO THE RESOURCES ALLOCATED
UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN.
OUT WHICH WAS CHAMPIONED BY THE
ASSEMBLY. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE PROVIDED AND NOTED IT-
THAT OUR STUDENTS NEEDED
EMERGENCY AID. SO WHAT WE DID
IS WE ALLOWED STUDENTS TO
MAINTAIN AND THAT YOU KNOW FREE
COLLEGE. AS LONG AS THEY STATED
ROLE WE HAD EXEMPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS. UNDER AB NINETEEN IF
THEY HAD TO DROP BY ONE AND ALL
THAT SO WE DIDN'T. WE DIDN'T
REMOVE THEM FROM THAT PROGRAM.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE DID IS
THAT THOSE. THOSE DOLLARS AND
THAT CATEGORICAL PROGRAM. WAS
VERY INTENTIONALLY CRAFTED BY
THE ASSEMBLY TO BE FLEXIBLE TO
MEET THE NEEDS. OF A PROMISE
PROGRAMS LOCALLY. WHAT THAT DID
IS ALLOWED THOSE FUNDS TO ALSO
BE USED FOR MORE. FRANCE FOR
THOSE VERY SAME STUDENTS SO.
THAT PLUGS ABILITY MADE IT
POSSIBLE TO AGAIN MEET
EMERGENCY. LAST MINUTE NEEDS
THAT STUDENTS MAY HAVE HAD
UNTIL. IT AYE I'LL TAKE THIS
TIME TO THANK YOU FOR BELIEVING
THAT POSSIBILITY. AND THANK YOU
MISS NUMBER. RESTRICTING THANK
YOU ALSO DOES ANOTHER CORE TO
MR READ I'M JUST GETTING US OF
HOW THE CALL ARE DOING WITH THE
TO. AND IF THE FORTY TO SET YOU
KNOW LINES CREDIT AND DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL TO CHOOSE FROM HELP
GET TO THIS YEAR AND HOW HOW
THEY'RE DEALING WITH A FUNDING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO. AS
MENTIONED- DEFERRALS ARE MUCH
PREFERRED OPTION OVER BASE
REDUCTIONS. SO THIS YEAR WE
HAVE. AN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER
OF DEFERRALS. BUT WE THANKFULLY
HAD SOME VEHICLES THAT WERE PUT
IN PLACE BOTH BY THE STATE
THERE ARE NEW- TAX ANTICIPATION
REVENUE NOTE- THAT ALLOWS
COLLEGES. TO BORROW AT LOW COST
RATES AND LEVERAGES THE STATE'S
TRIPLE A RATING SO THAT'S ONE
OPTION. YOU KNOW COLLEGES CAN
ALSO USE THEIR RESERVES. AND
LINES OF CREDIT SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE VEHICLES THAT THEY
USE TO GET PAST. THESE
DEFERRALS. WHAT WE DID AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS ALSO
LOOK AT ALL THE SOURCES OF
FUNDS. THAT COLLEGE RECEIVES
AND WHETHER THEY ARE IN A
HIGHER WHILE. NOT AREA. HIGHER
PROPERTY WEALTH AREA. WHERE
DOES THEIR A LOWER PROPERTY
AREA. BECAUSE THEY ARE IN THE
LOWER PER BOTH AREA. AND PASSED
FOR. THEY'VE HAD TO BEAR THE
BURDEN OF TO. BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO BLOW WARM BECAUSE THEY GET
MORE ON STAY DOLLARS. SO WHAT
WE DID MAKE SURE EVERY SINGLE.
RECEIVED AT LEAST EIGHTY THREE
PERCENT- OF THEIR TOTAL FUNDS
FROM ALL SOURCES IN ORDER TO
GET THROUGH THESE HIGH LEVEL OF
DEFERRALS. I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS OF HOW WE
DID THAT. AND A BRIEF ON OUR
METHODOLOGY. NO THAT'S GREAT
THERE THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING
INFORMATION MAKES LOT OF SENSE
THANK YOU. NOT SEEN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON A THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR. POLICE BEEN
SELLING GALLAGHER IF I COULD GO
AHEAD. MR GALLAGHER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- ONE I DIDN'T REALLY
HEAR FROM THE FIRST
PRESENTATION OR- YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN A BIG ADVOCATE OF SAY AND
HOW DO WE KIND OF GET BACK TO
IN PERSON LEARNING I THINK A
LOT OF US WANT TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN I'VE CERTAINLY HAD A LOT
OF. A CONTACT MY OFFICE FROM
STUDENTS- WANTING TO. YOU KNOW
GET BACK IN THAT ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY THINK THEY GET THE
MOST OUT OF THEIR- FOR THEIR
EDUCATION AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- DO ANY OF THE CAMPUSES
WHERE WERE YOU UYS THAT- IN
TERMS OF. ARE YOU MAKE ANY
DETERMINATION YET AS TO WHAT
YOU MIGHT DO IN THE SPRING.
SEMESTERS WE MAYBE HAVE SOME
HYBRID SYSTEM. I KNOW IT CHICO-
FOR INSTANCE THEY THEY KIND OF
STARTED A HYBRID. MODEL ON
CAMPUS- THAT THERE WAS YOU KNOW
AN OUTBREAK ASSOCIATED THAT IT
WAS NOT SO MUCH DUE TO. WELL
WASN'T DUE TO ON CAMPUS
INSTRUCTION RATHER MORE STUDENT
GATHERINGS OFF CAMPUS- THAT HAD
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THE CONCERN
FOR THE COMMUNITY BUT YEAH DO
WE HAVE. PLANS FOR OFFERING IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR THE
SPRING SEMESTER. SURE AT THIS
IS ALEX GRAVES GOING TO THE IC
LIKE TAKE FIRST CRACK AT THAT.
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS- YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW CONDITIONS ARE
THOSE DECISIONS HAVE LARGELY
BEEN DRIVEN BY A COUNTY LEVEL
CONDITIONS- WITHIN THE STATE'S
FRAMEWORK AROUND SAY FREE
OPENING- SO IN SOME AREAS FOR
EXAMPLE AT SIMPSON UNIVERSITY
IN REDDING- DID. LARGELY
REPOPULATE WITH IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AT THE BEGINNING
THIS FALL TERM- WHILE ALSO
GIVING STUDENTS WHO FOR
WHATEVER REASON PREFERRED TO
STAY- IN A VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT
THAT OPTION- YOU KNOW OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE WE'VE WE'VE
SEEN DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
SUCCESS WITH THAT- WE HAVE
INSTITUTIONS IN THE CENTRAL
COAST TO HAVE REPOPULATED- BUT
CONVERSELY AND L. A. COUNTY
WHERE WE HAVE THIRTY SIX
INSTITUTIONS- THE COUNTY THERE
HAS. IT LANDED SOME ADDITIONAL
MEASURES THAT HAVE MADE- ANY
KIND OF RE POPULATION BEYOND-
THOSE FOR YOU KNOW PROGRAMS
THAT CAN'T BE DONE VIRTUALLY
LIKE STUDIO ARTS- HEALTH
PROFESSIONS THINGS LIKE THAT
IT'S BEEN VERY CHALLENGING- SO
I THINK YOU KNOW INSTITUTIONS
ARE TRYING TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS RIGHT NOW FRANKLY- TO
GIVE AS MUCH NOTICE TO STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES FOR THE SPRING-
BUT I THINK MUCH OF THEIR
CALCULUS AND THAT. IN THEIR
SCENARIO PLANNING WILL BE.
DRIVEN BY THE CONDITIONS
LOCALLY. TO ADDRESS BRIEFLY. ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'LL HAVE. CHANCELLOR OF
BYRON BREELAND LATER YOU CAN
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE. A
DISTRICT BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS A SERIES OF HIGH GRADE
OPTIONS ACROSS OUR COLLEGES OF
LOS YOU'RE STILL ONLINE WHERE A
POSSIBLE TO BE ONLINE CERTAIN
CTE CLASSES IN ESSENTIAL
INDUSTRIES HAVE GONE BACK AT A
VERY LIMITED CAPACITY WHERE. OF
VARIOUS SAFETY PRECAUTIONS
TEMPERATURE TESTING PLEXI
GLASS- IMPLEMENTED ALL THESE
VARIOUS PERCUSSION BUT AGAIN
THANK GOD WE CAN ONLY OFFER A
VERY LIMITED CAPACITIES. FOR
THE SAFETY OF STUDENTS AND
FACULTY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM ANY OF THE MEMBERS WHO MAY
BE OUR REMOTE. NOT SEEN ANY
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR PROVIDING VERY-
IMPORTANT INFORMATION TO US AND
US WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA I WILL
INTRODUCE THE SECOND PANEL.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. SO IT IN THE SECOND
PANEL I'M GOING TO BRING UP THE
PRESIDENT OF CSU SACRAMENTO.
ROBERT NELSON HE B. HE WILL BE
AND WITNESS VIEW IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. I WILL ALSO
INTRODUCE THE CHANCELLOR OF SAN
JOSE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THAT IS VIRANT
CLIFF BREELAND AND HE WILL BE
AND WITNESS VIEW IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX. SO PRESIDENT NELSON
IF YOU ARE THERE AND YOU'RE
READY YOU CAN BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK TODAY
ABOUT HOW SACRAMENTO STATE HAS
RESPONDED TO THE PANDEMIC. AND
KEPT OUR ACADEMIC MISSION
STRONG IN THESE UNCERTAIN TIMES.
IT HAS BEEN AND THEN.
CHALLENGING NINE MONTHS BUT
I'VE NEVER BEEN PROUDER AND
MORE IMPRESSED. HI HOW ARE
FACULTY AND STAFF AND STUDENTS
HAVE REACTED THEY ARE MY HEROES.
AS YOU KNOW IN MARCH THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSITY IMMEDIATELY SHIFTED
TO A VIRTUAL OPERATIONS. IT WAS
NOT ALWAYS EASY AND IT WAS
DEFINITELY NOT FUN. SOME
COURSES CLEARLY COULD GO ONLINE
OTHERS SUCH AS NURSING AND
ENGINEERING PROVED TO BE MORE
CHALLENGES. DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES OUR STUDENTS
ACADEMIC. CONTINUE TO INCREASE
ONLY SEVENTY ONLY SEVENTY OF
OUR THIRTY ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED STUDENTS WITH GREW
DURING THE SPRING SEMESTER. IN
ALL MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS ENDED
THE TERM ELIGIBLE TO GRADUATE I
RECOGNIZE NUMBER. MOST
IMPORTANTLY OUR FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE HAS CONTINUED
TO RISE IT IS NOW TWENTY ONE.
POINT SEVEN PERCENT. AN
INCREASE. FROM JUST EIGHT POINT
5% IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THE
GRADUATION RATE FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN L. AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS HAS TRIPLED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE
GRADUATION RATE FOR HISPANIC
STUDENTS HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED
TO TWENTY ONE POINT 1% WHICH IS
LESS THAN ONE PERCENTAGE POINT.
FROM OUR UNIVERSITY RIGHT. THE
RISING GRADUATION RATES AT JUST
SACKED STATE HAS COLLECTIVELY
SAVED OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS. GETTING THROUGH THE
SPRING SEMESTER WAS A CHALLENGE.
THE DECISION FOR ALL C. S. USED
TO GROW VIRTUAL IN MAY HAS
HELPED SET STATE THE STAGE FOR
A SUCCESSFUL FALL SEMESTER. AS
I SAID EARLIER NOT ALL CLASSES
CAN BE TAUGHT ONLINE. 5% OF OUR
NINE THOUSAND COURSES ARE
CURRENTLY BEING TAUGHT IN
PERSON BECAUSE OF THE NEED FOR
SPECIAL EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
MANIKINS FOR NURSES AND
SPECTROMETERS FOR BIOLOGISTS.
ONLY FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS ARE
IN OUR DORMS. WE USUALLY HAVE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED STUDENTS IN
THE DORMS. MANY OF THE STUDENTS
IN THE DORMS ARE FORMER FOSTER
STUDENTS AND TOO MANY OF THEM
WERE HOMELESS STUDENTS.
PREVIOUS TO THE PANDEMIC. TO
HELP THE FACULTY CONVERT THEIR
EXISTING COURSES INTO ONLINE OR
BLENDED COURSES WE USE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
CARES ACT DOLLARS TO CONDUCT
SOME RETRAINING EFFORT THAT WE
CALLED TEACHING ONLINE SUMMER
CAMP. MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
FACULTY TOOK PART IN THESE
THREE. WEIGHT TRAINING SESSIONS.
THIS SUMMER EFFORTS WERE NOT
ONLY TO HELP THE FACULTY
SHARPEN THEIR SKILLS ON CAMPUS
AND ZOOM. BUT ALSO THE TRAINING
EMPHASIZED EMPATHY FOR THE
STUDENTS ONLINE LEARNING
EXPERIENCES AND STRESSED THE
NEED FOR CONSTANT COMMUNICATION.
HOPING OUR FACULTY TO PREPARE
TEACH ONLINE MEANS NOTHING IF
WE'RE NOT ALSO DOING SOMETHING
TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
FOR OUR STUDENTS. SINCE MARCH
THE UNIVERSITY HAS SPENT MORE
THAN TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON
TECHNOLOGY EQUIVALENT. LOAN
THOSE PURCHASES TO OUR
STUDENTS. THIS INCLUDES. ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE LAPTOPS. ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR HOT SPOT.
WHICH WE PAY FOR EACH MONTH.
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
WEBCAMS. AND WE'VE PARTNERED
WITH COMCAST TO HELP OUR
STUDENTS GET FREE BROADBAND.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES INVESTMENTS
CONTINUE TO COST THE UNIVERSITY
MORE THAN FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS EACH MONTH FOR THE HOT
SPOT SALONE. BUT OUR STUDENTS
FIRST DECISIONS HAVE CLEARLY
PAID OFF AS OUR MOMENT IS UP
AND OUR STUDENTS ARE TAKING
MORE UNITS THAN EVER. AS OF
THIS MONTH WE HAVE.
310-005-0010 IN GENERAL ANOTHER
RECORD NUMBER. THIS IS ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY MORE
THAN LAST YEAR. THIS FALL WE
BEGAN IMPLEMENTING OUR LARGEST
RECORD SCHEDULING EFFORT TO
DATE. WHAT WE CALL THE HORN AND
LYFT. RATHER THAN ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO CHOOSE COURSES
RANDOMLY EACH STUDENT PROVIDED.
IS PROVIDED WITH OF COURSE
SCHEDULE THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS.
WE'RE NOT LAUNCH PROVIDES
STUDENTS AT PRE DESIGN FIFTEEN
TO SIXTEEN UNIT FIRST SEMESTER
COURSE SCHEDULE WHICH IS BASED
ON THEIR MAJOR AND ON THEIR
INTERESTS. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
HORN AT LAUNCH WILL HELP
STUDENTS START THEIR COLLEGE
CAREERS ON THE RIGHT TRACK. AND
KEEP THEM ENGAGED IN THE
COURSES AND HELP THEM GRADUATE
ON TIME. SO FAR THE RESULTS
HAVE BEEN VERY IMPRESSIVE. AS
OUR FRESHMEN AVERAGING UPLOAD
IS FOURTEEN POINT FIVE AN ALL
TIME HIGH. THIS IS AN INCREASE
FROM TWELVE POINT SEVEN UNITS
IN. TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. WE
ARE WE'RE ON OUR WAY TO
GRADUATING OUR STUDENTS IN FOUR
YEARS. FIFTEEN UNITS TIMES TO
TIMES FOUR EQUALS A HUNDRED
TWENTY UNITS A DEGREE IN FOUR
YEARS. WELL THE PANDEMIC IS
CHANGE HOW WE TEACH AND HOW WE
OPERATE. I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
IT CANNOT DISTRACT US FROM THE
WORLD. THAT IS SURROUNDING US.
TO THAT END WE ARE MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY WITH AN ANTI
RACISM INITIATIVE THAT I
BELIEVE THAT ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF HAVE
EMBRACED. SACRAMENTO STATE DOES
NOT JUST CONDEMN RACISM WE'RE
UNDERWAY DURING IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO END. RACISM TO
THAT END I HAVE ALSO PLEDGED TO
INVEST IN SANDERS PROGRAMS AND
OTHER AREAS THAT ARE DOING ANTI
RACISM WORK ON OUR CAMPUS. I
PLEDGE TO SUPPORT FACULTY IN
BUILDING. ANTI RACIST
CURRICULUM AND ANTI BASS
PEDAGOGY. AND I PLEDGE TO
PROVIDE TRAINING DEVELOPMENT
AND LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO LEARN
ABOUT THE ACTIONS THAT THEY CAN
TAKE TO FIGHT RACISM. WE'RE
ALSO INCREASING OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO CHANGE THE
WAY. OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
POLICED. WE WILL NOT STAY QUIET
AS OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES EXPENSE EXPERIENCE IN
JUSTICE AND RACISM. WE'RE
COMMITTED TO FOLLOWING THROUGH
ON THIS IMPERATIVE. IN
CONCLUSION. I WANT JUNE IN ALL
SACRAMENTO STATE CONTINUES TO
BE. OUR UNIVERSITY ON THE RISE.
AND OUR THAT OUR STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF HAVE
ABSOLUTELY RISEN TO THE
OCCASION. I KNOW THAT MANY OF
MY FELLOW SIX CSU CAMPUSES HAVE
UNDERTAKEN SIMILAR EFFORTS AS
S. AND I PLEDGE TO YOU THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE
STUDENT SUCCESS. HOWEVER I MUST
REMIND YOU AND CAUTION YOU.
THAT WE ARE AN UNPRECEDENTED
FISCAL TIMES. WE'RE FACING
STATE BUDGET CUTS ISING
SPENCER'S AND REVENUE LOSSES.
SINCE ACT SINCE MARCH
SACRAMENTO STATE I HAVE
EXPERIENCE. ALL THIRTY MILLION.
REVENUE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
REVENUE LOSSES FROM CAMPUSES
AND FROM CAMPUS AND
EXHILARATING FOR EXAMPLE
FIFTEEN MILLION FROM HOUSING
SIX MILLION FROM PARKING SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION FROM FOOD
SERVICES JUST TO NAME A FEW. WE
ALSO EXPERIENCED AT TEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION. DOLLAR CUT IN
STATE GENERAL FUNDING OF OUR
BUDGET. AND WE HAVE HAD TO
SPEND FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
IN RELATE OVER THE EXPENSES.
AND THERE WILL BE MORE OR THAT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THEREFORE
WE HAD TO GO INTO OUR RESERVES.
AND WE'VE USED SEVEN MILLION OF
OUR CAMPUS RESERVES UP TO THIS
POINT. THAT LEAVES US WITH ONLY
ONE MONTH OF RESERVES. THAT WE
CAN CALL ON. SO THINGS ARE
TIGHT. BUT WE MUST CONTINUE THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS AND WE
CANNOT CONTINUE THEM WITH THESE
CUTS. I KNOW MANY OF YOU
PERSONALLY. AND I KNOW THAT YOU
CARE ABOUT OUR STUDENTS AND YOU
WANTTO SEE THE BEST FOR THAT
M. AS TO ALL OF US AT SAC STATE.
THANK YOU FOR HELPING ME. FOR
HELPING SEX STATE. AND THE CSU
SYSTEM. TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
STINGERS UP I'LL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO NOW TO
CHANCELLOR BYRON CLIFF REALLY
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO QUESTIONS.
AND HE ISN'T WITNESS VIEW IN
ROOM. ONE TWENTY SIX. THAT GOOD
AFTERNOON TO ALL MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION- AND THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO I WANT
TO THANK GOD BOTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA- GREAT TO SEE YOU
AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE WITH YOU ALL THIS
AFTERNOON. AGAIN MY NAME IS
BYRON GOOD FREELANCERS A CHANCE
FOR THE SAN JOSE EVERGREEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
WHICH IS COMPOSED OF SAN JOSE
CITY COLLEGE EVERGREEN VALLEY
COLLEGE. AND A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EXTENSION CENTER IN THE
CITY OF MIL PAETUS AS WELL AS A
CENTER FOR ECONOMIC MOBILITY
LOCATED IN DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE.
SAN JOSE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IS LOCATED IN
THE HEART OF SILICON VALLEY. WE
SERVE APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
AND HAVE THE DAHLE DISTINCTION
OF BEING DESIGNATED AS BOTH A
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION AS
WELL AS AN AGENT SERVING
INSTITUTION. IN SPITE OF THE
COOPER WEALTH THAT EXIST IN THE
VALLEY. WE ALSO BOTH PERHAPS ON
THE LARGEST INCOME AND WEALTH
GAPS IN THE WORLD AMONG PEOPLE
LIVING AND WORKING IN THE LAND
OF INNOVATION ON THE SILICON
VALLEY. IN OUR DISTRICT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
LOW INCOME. WITH APPROXIMATELY
6% QUALIFYING FOR THE PROMISE
FEE WAIVER FORMALLY KNOWN AS
THE GOVERNOR FEE WAIVER. OUR
FULL TIME FACTOR ALSO KNOWN TO
BE AMONG THE MOST DIVERSE IN
THE NATION. BREAKING IN THE TOP
FIVE NATIONALLY AMONG THE TOP
TWELVE HUNDRED PLUS TO YOUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS. WHEN THE
PANDEMIC HIT. YOU KNOW OF
COURSE THAT IT PRESENTED MANY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
THROUGHOUT OUR SYSTEM. AND AS
OF YESTERDAY IT WAS REPORTED
THAT WE REACHED AN ALL TIME
HIGH OF A HUNDRED FORTY SIX
THOUSAND NU KOPEN NINETEEN
CASES NATIONALLY. WITH NO END
IN SIGHT IN TERMS OF THE U. S.
GETTING A HANDLE ON THE
OUTBREAK. HEADING INTO WHAT IS
BEING TERMED THE DARK WINTER.
AS SUCH I CHALLENGES TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITIES WE WILL NEED US
THE MOST- SHOULD CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE OUR FULL ATTENTION. AND
ESPECIALLY OUR COMMITMENT OF
RESOURCE. S. CLARA COUNTY WITH
ONE OF THE ORIGINAL HOT SPOTS
IN TERMS OF THE FIRST MAJOR
OUTBREAK OF CORPORATE NINETEEN
IN THE U. S. S. J. E. C. C. D.
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST DISTRICTS
IN THE NATION TO MOVE TO REMOTE
OPERATIONS AND INSTRUCTION. IN
FACT A DIFFERENT WENT FROM
HAVING APPROXIMATELY 15% OF OUR
OFFERINGS AND DISTANCE
EDUCATION. TO HAVING
APPROXIMATELY 95% OF OUR
OFFERINGS- IN IN THIS IS
EDUCATION A MATTER OF DAYS.
OSTENSIBLY THERE WERE CONTINUE
TO BE MANY CHALLENGES
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS WHO
MUST REMAIN THE FOCAL POINT. OF
OUR EFFORTS- AS WELL AS OUR
SYSTEM WIDE EFFORT. LOCALLY AND
ACCORDING TO AN INTERNAL SURVEY
CONDUCTED IN OUR DISTRICT WE
FOUND THAT OUR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE HIGH RATES. OF A
LOSS OF INCOME FOOD SECURITY
HOUSING INSECURITY AND
INCREASED RESPONSIBILITIES AT
HOME. GIVEN THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
COMMUTERS. IN FACT ENROLLMENT
NUMBER SEVENTY DECLINE IN OUR
DISTRICT. ARE YEAR OVER YEAR
ENROLLMENT IS DOWN 9% AND HEAD
COUNT AND ALMOST 15% IN FULL
TIME STUDENT ENROLLMENT WHEN
COMPARING PAUL TWENTY NINETEEN
TO FALL TWENTY TWENTY. I MISS
THE BACKDROP OF PORT NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP. POLITICAL POSTURING
IN ONGOING RACIAL UNREST IN AND
DAY OUT OF THE IMPACT ARE
EXTREMELY DIVERSE STUDENTS AND
STAFF. AS WELL AS THE REALITY
THAT MANY STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAD LOST OR
WERE IN DANGER OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS. OUR DISTRICT LIKE MANY
OTHERS IN THE STATE NEEDED TO
BE COGNIZANT OF HOW THE DOWN
ECONOMY DISPROPORTIONATE.
INFECTION AND DEATH RATES HAVE
A CONTINUE TO IMPACT LOW
INCOME. LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES. WE WILL NEED TO BE
AT THE FOREFRONT FOR FRONT OF
ANY WELL INTENDED ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IF CALIFORNIA IS GOING
TO REGAIN ITS ECONOMIC FOOTING.
NATIONALLY WE COMPARED TO FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONTINUE TO SUFFER THE
MOST WITH THE DECREASE OF ABOUT
NINE POINT 5% ENROLLMENT. WHICH
IS ENROLLMENT DECLINED NEARLY
NINE TIMES THE PRE PANDEMIC LAW
FREE. HOWEVER I WANT TO POINT
OUT SOMETHING THAT'S PERHAPS
EVEN MORE CONCERNING. AND THAT
IS THE NUMBER OF FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS WHO ALSO DROP- MOST
DRASTICALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AT A RATE OF ABOUT TWENTY TWO
POINT 7% I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ENROLLMENT EXPERTS AND
ADVOCATES FROM THOSE
COMMUNITIES HAVE SHARED THAT
THESE STUDENTS TEND TO LIVE IN
MULTI GENERATIONAL HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT DON'T ALLOW FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THERE ARE CRITICAL
REALITIES TO BE MINDFUL OF IF
WE START TO THINK ABOUT
DESIGNING AND IMPLEMENTING A
STRONG AND EQUITABLE POST
PANDEMIC RECOVERY FOR THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT FINDING FROM OUR
DISTRICT'S LOCAL SURVEYS
HIGHLIGHTED THIS STUDENTS HAVE
HAD TO REDUCE THEIR COURSE LOW.
WITHDRAW COMPLETELY OR NOT
RETURN TO SCHOOL OR CLASSES DUE
TO THE IMPACT. OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES. SO CIVICALLY WE FOUND
THE STUDENTS WERE CHALLENGED
WITH A LACK OF ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET AND COMPUTER HARDWARE.
THE TECHNOLOGY NEEDS OF
STUDENTS. BECAME THE MOST
SALIENT WHEN WE MADE THE SWITCH
TO DISTANCE LEARNING. FOR
EXAMPLE WE PURCHASED AND
DISTRIBUTED ABOUT
1-200-200-0700 LAPTOPS THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY WIFI HOTSPOTS
THREE HUNDRED COMPUTER MONITORS
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED WEBCAMS.
OUR STUDENT SERVICES TEAMS OF
ALSO CONTINUE PROVIDING ACCESS
TO FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS FOR THE
MOST NEEDY STUDENTS AND THE
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE MADE THE
CONVERSION TO A VIRTUAL CAMPUS
PROVIDED DISTANCE EDUCATION
TRAINING ESTABLISH A CAMPUS
REOPENING PLAN. CONTINUE
STREAMLINING IMPLEMENTATION OF
GUIDED PATHWAYS AND GAVE THE
MEASURING CLASSROOM. ANTI
RACISM CURRICULUM STUDENTS ALSO
INDICATED THAT ACCESS TO THE
FOLLOWING SERVICES WERE
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING FROM A
REMOTE ENVIRONMENT ACADEMIC
COUNSELING LIBRARY SERVICES
FINANCIAL AID TUTORING WHICH WE
KNOW ARE ALL KEY COMPONENTS TO
STUDENT SUCCESS I ALSO WANT TO
HEAR THAT ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR
STUDENTS REPORTED THAT PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC THEY HAD NO
EXPERIENCE WITH TAKING ACADEMIC
CLASSES ONLINE. ARE CHLOE'S
ALSO WORK CHALLENGE IN THIS NEW
ENVIRONMENT WITH A LITTLE OVER
HALF OF OUR FACULTY STATING
THAT THEY HAD NO EXPERIENCE
TEACHING ONLINE PRIOR TO COPE.
FAR STAFF WE'VE BEEN SURE TO
PROVIDE REMOTE ACCESS FLEXIBLE
HOURS REQUIP COMMUNICATION
CLEAR SAFETY GUIDELINES. AN
ONLINE EMPLOYEE TO KIDS THE
COPA NINETY PANDEMIC OF RESULT
IN IT ON. DISRUPTION TO OUR
COLLEGE OPERATIONS AND THE
LIVES OF OUR STUDENTS. AS A
DISTRICT AS INDIVIDUAL COLLEGES
IN THE SYSTEM WE HAVE WORKED
HARD AND INVESTED THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY. FOOD AND
OTHER ASSISTANCE TO OUR
STUDENTS- WITH THE MOST NEED. I
TO WRAP UP BY. SOMETHING THAT
WE DIDN'T HAVE AN- BEFORE THE
TWELVE NINETY OUTBREAK WAS A
PAN PLAY AND I TO THANK I CHIEF
POLICE AND EFFORT AND ARE. FOR
MANAGING THE PROCESS AND IT WE
ALL DISCOVERED MANY OF COLLEGE
ALSO DID NOT SUCH A- AS WE ALL
WERE MORE FOR. ON A SHOOTER
EXERCISE OR WHAT TO DO IN CASE
OF AN EARTHQUAKE OR OTHER NAY
DISASTER AND NOT ANTICIPATING A
PANDEMIC. BUT THE SPECIFIC PLAN
OUTLINES A DURING A PANDEMIC
THE PRIMARY CHALLENGES FACING
THE DISTRICT WILL LIKELY BE
MAINTAINING STUDENTS PROGRESS
TO COMPLETE CLASS REQUIREMENTS
WHILE COMPLYING WITH ORDERS TO
CLOSE THE CAMPUS. MANAGING AND
LIMITING FACULTY STAFF AND
STUDENT EXPOSURE BOTH ON AND
OFF CAMPUS. COMPLYING WITH
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
MANDATES. LOSS OF REVENUE DUE
TO THE INABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
OFFER COURSES AND OR STUDENT
ILLNESS. THE PURPOSE OF THE
DISTRICT COURT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PLAN IS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE IN PREPARING FOR
IDENTIFYING AND RESPONDED TO
COVERT NINETEEN OUTBREAKS THAT
AFFECT THE SALE OF THE EVERY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. BY
LIMITING THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS AND MINIMIZING SOCIAL
DISRUPTION WITHIN A COMMUNITY
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT IS HIGHLY
COORDINATED. WITH LOCAL COUNTY
AGENCIES. THE CRITICAL FOR OF
EMPLOYMENT IS A OF STAFF AND TO
FULL STRUCK. OR SOME TYPE OF
HIGH BOB. THIS IS LEARNING
PROTOCOL MAKE. HOWEVER
PREPARATIONS MUST BE TAKEN TO
ASSUME THAT MOST FACILITIES
WILL RESUME TO BEING OCCUPIED.
HERE IS TO BE CONSIDERED ARE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN A
CLASS. BASED ON STUDENT
POPULATION AND INTERNAL
BUILDING SQUARE FOOTAGE.
ONGOING CONCERNS OF NOTE
INCLUDE OUR ABILITY TO HAVE A
ROBUST CONTACT TRACING PROGRAM
IN PLACE. AS WELL AS ACCESS TO
COPE WITH TESTING FOR STAFF AND
STUDENTS WHICH WE CURRENTLY DO
NOT HAVE- AND I'VE HEARD THE UC
AND C. ISSUE A SEGMENT TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THAT. I IN THEIR
PLANS AS WELL. AB ANY
PARTICULAR AS WE ARE
CONSIDERING RESUMING ATHLETIC
COMPETITION IN THE SPRING.
THESE THINGS OF COURSE AT
ADDITIONAL COST TO OUR BUDGETS.
OTHER AREAS THAT HAVE SEEN
DECLINES IN REVENUE. AS A
RESULT THE ONLY WARM REMOTE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT INCLUDE
OUR ENTERPRISE SERVICES SUCH AS
THE BOOKSTORE AND CAFETERIA.
AND OF COURSE OUR PARKING SPOT.
THE IMPACT OF OVER NINETY
OPPOSED. EDUCATION HAS BEEN
ACROSS GLOBE. AND CERTAINLY IN
THE FANTASQUE STATED. AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THE VIEWS OF MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE JOINT
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THESE
UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
BRIEFLY IMPACTED OUR STUDENTS
SUCCESS EFFORTS. AS WELL AS
THEIR ECONOMIC MOBILITY. AND
NOT TO MENTION THE OVERALL
HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE ARE COMMITTED TO SERVING. WE
ALMOST PRIORITIZE HIGHER
EDUCATION IS ONE OF THE BEST
PATHWAYS TO ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
AND IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO OUR NATION'S RECOVERY. WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BEING AT THE
CENTER OF THESE EFFORTS. GIVEN
THE OPEN ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY THAT WE PROVIDE
TO ALL COMMUNITIES. BEING ABLE
TO PUT ADDITIONAL RELIEF FUNDS
TO USE WILL HAVE A HUGE. IMPACT
ON OUR STUDENTS ABILITY TO. IT
THE PURSUIT OF THEIR-
CERTIFICATES ENTRANCE GOALS
DURING THE CHALLENGING TIMES.
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATE EVERY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN OUR BORDER.
I WANT THIS YEAR THANK ASSEMBLY
COME HIGHER. IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUT SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TIME AND
EFFORT TOWARDS IS ONGOING
CHALLENGES FOR ALL OF US. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHEN LANE AND WE
WILL NOW OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS. MR MCCARTY YES I
REALLY DON'T HAVE A QUESTION A
WE'RE WE'RE KIND OF RUNNING
SHORT ON TIME I JUST WANT TO
GIVE. A PROPS TO MY LOCAL CSU
PRESIDENT AT SAC STATE
PRESIDENT NELSON IS IN A
TREMENDOUS JOB. AS FAR AS
PUSHING THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE AND JUST THAT FIGURE
THAT HE TALKED ABOUT HOW MUCH
WE'RE SAVING FAMILIES. IN IN
MONEY AND STUDENT DEBT THAT
THEY DON'T TO. IS JUST A TOTAL
WIN WIN FOR CALIFORNIA AGAIN
FREES UP SPACE SO I KNOW-
RAINSTORM EARLIER WE'VE ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO DO IT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
BUT I NEED I THINK WE OF COURSE
HE DIDN'T LOOK AND SEE WE CAN
DO TO RELICATE THIS ALL ACROSS
THE TWENTY THREE. CAPAS SYSTEM
THANK YOU. SURE RUMBLING DR
ROOM ALL FOLLOW UP ON IF I CAN
I THOUGHT A NELSON GAVE SOME
SUGGEST THAT I INSTITUTION MAY
WANT TO LOOK AT AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO REPEAT THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT I GOT THEM RIGHT
PRESIDENT NELSON IT SEEMS THAT
YOU WERE FOCUSED ON STUDENT
FIRST DECISIONS AND FOR YOU TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT THE TWO TOP
THINGS YOU WORKED ON OR EMPATHY
FOR ONLINE STUDENTS. AS WELL AS
BRIDGING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
WANTED TO HEAR IF YOU THOUGHT
THOSE WERE TWO OF THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT YOU EMPLOYED AT
SACRAMENTO STATE OR IF THERE
WERE ANY OTHER OTHERS THAT YOU
THOUGHT SHOULD BE PRIORITISED
AHEAD OF THOSE. THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS A RE. IT IS A REAL
AND WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
WE THE PARKING GARAGE NUMBER
FIVE. WHICH IS ONE BAY HOT SPOT.
AND WE OUR STUDENTS ARE INTO.
AND WORKING IN THEIR- SO THEY
THEY CAN HAVE SPACE THERE.
OFTEN THERE THERE WITH THE RUDE
LITTLE KID IN LITTLE KIDS ARE
ON THEIR BIKES RIDING AROUND IN
THE PARKING GARAGE WHILE MOM IS
WORKING. SO YOU HAVE TO REACH
OUT AND GIVE THE STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY MOSTLY YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE IN THEM. WHEN WE MADE
THIS CHANGE IT WAS A HARD
CHANGE. BUT IF YOU BELIEVE IN
YOUR STUDENTS AND YOU BELIEVE
IN YOUR FACULTY AND YOU GIVE
THEM THE TOOLS THEY WILL
SUCCEED. THANK YOU. I HAVE A
QUESTION TO A CHANCER BREELAND.
WHAT OTHER SUPPORT- WOULD YOU
LOOK FOR OF THE LEGISLATURE
DURING THIS TIME TO HELP THE
NEEDS OF- OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. BUT THIS DID YEAH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER YEAH-
I THINK YOU HEAR ME NOW YES
SOUNDCHECK YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THE CALL AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
SUPPORT IN A NUMBER OF AREAS I
THINK OF MENTAL HEALTH WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED- MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING- WE'RE
CERTAINLY- UNDERFUNDED WHEN IT
COMES TO BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ON
OUR OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES- IT FOR
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THAT I
THINK IN THIS ENVIRONMENT TO BE
CREATED UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY-
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY A LACK OF STAFF
THERE- WE'RE ALSO CONTINUING TO
HAVE TO FIND- THE TRANSITION-
IN THIS NEW- ENVIRONMENT- I
THINK MOVING FORWARD WE ARE
GOING TO BE- I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE TRANSITION FROM 15%
ONLINE TO NINETY FIVE PERCENT.
ONLINE IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME SO WE'RE GONNA NEED
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL
TRAINING- FUNDING- AND THAT IS
OF OUR FACULTY AND OUR STAFF
WHO ARE NOW BEING ASKED TO A
FUNCTION AT A HIGH LEVEL IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT. AND OF COURSE
SUPPORT FOR OUR STUDENTS WE'VE
HEARD THE DIGITAL DIVIDE EVEN
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC BUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC IS
CERTAINLY POST PANDEMIC THAT
DIVIDE IS INCREASED- WE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO INTERNET. IN OUR OF
PARKING LOTS WITH STUDENTS WHO
ARE ABLE TO UTILIZE THAT BUT
WE'RE ALSO SEVERELY LACKING OR
SORELY LACKING ACCESS TO
INTERNET AS FAR AS A HT SPOT
OR EVEN LAPTOPS AND COMPUTERS
ALTOGETHER THESE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT EXPENSES- WHEN-
BACKDROP AGAINST OPERA NORMAL
OPERATIONAL- COST- WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO HAVE TO CONSIDER. YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS WILL LOOK LIKE
LONG TERM- IN MAKING CHANGES I
THINK A LOT OF A ONE TIME
DOLLARS A NEED- IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS ARE
TRAINING EFFORTS- AS WELL AS
THE ONGOING NEED FOR PP ANY-
AND ONE THING I'LL ADD- THAT WE
DO NEED. TO START IMPLEMENTING
IT START TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT CONTACT TRACING- AS
WELL AS TESTING- ON A REGULAR
BASIS- OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN
FUNDED FOR- AND IF SOMETHING IS
GONNA BE IMPORTANT MOVING.
FORWARD INTEL A VACCINE. I HAS
BEEN THE- INTO COURSE JUST TO
EVER. AND IN TERMS OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE WE-
THAT MAY TAKE UPWARDS OF TWO
YEARS. AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE NEEDS THAT WE DO HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DATA. THANK YOU
CHANCE. AND THEN TO PRESIDENT
NELSON. I'VE HEARD A LOT DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. THAT WE ARE
ASKING. EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO DO MORE WITH
LESS. SO TO PRESIDENT JOHNSON
WHERE. HOW CAN WE GET. TO THE
PLACE WHERE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
LESS IS LESS. AND THAT WE NEED
TO BEGIN TO PRIORITIZE- OUR
PRIORITIES. PRESIDENT NELSON. I
HAVE BEEN VERY STRONG ON OUR
CAMPUS THAT WE MUST DO LESS
WITH LESS. WE CANNOT ASK MORE
OF OUR FACULTY. THEY ARE
WORKING HARD RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
THEM AS THEY'RE APPROACHING THE
END OF THE SEMESTER ARE BURNING
OUT. WE NEED TO SUPPORT THEM AT
EVERY CABINET MEETING THAT I
HAVE WE BEGIN BY DISCUSSING
WHAT ARE WE NOT GOING TO DO.
NOW WE WILL ALSO ASK OURSELVES
WHAT ARE WE NOT GOING TO DO
THAT WILL NOT HAVE ANY HARM TO
OUR STUDENTS. SO WE LOOK AT
THINGS THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR SUCCESS. WE
SPENT FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ON EXTRA SECTIONS THIS
SEMESTER SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
OUR GRADUATION RATES MOVING
FORWARD. THAT IS ESSENTIAL WE
HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT IS A
CENTRAL. I'VE ASKED MY CABINET
AND OTHERS TO CUT THEIR LITTLE
DARLINGS LITTLE DARLINGS IS A
PHRASE FROM HEMMING WAY AND ONE
HEMINGWAY WITH A HE SAID IF IT.
WAS SOMETHING THAT HE LOVED IT
PROBABLY WASN'T SOMETHING THAT
HE REALLY NEEDED. AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE THINGS TO BE
ABLE TO. IN SHORT THERE
EVERYONE IS STILL MOVING
FORWARD BUT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THAT NORSTAR THAT RYAN STORM
TALKED ABOUT. OF HELP. AND THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE. RENDON
ANNOUNCED AND I APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO ASK ANY
OF THE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
WEATHERBY K. TWELVE OR HIGHER
ED TO DO MORE WITH LESS SO I
LIKE THAT YOUR CONCEPT OF DOING
LESS WITH LESS SO THANK YOU AND
I BEFORE I. I'D ASK THEM TO GO
ON TO OUR NEXT PANELIST I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
NO ONE. OUT THERE- ANY OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO ARE
WATCHING THE REMOTELY WHO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. SO NOT SEEN ANY
BY I THANK THE TWO PANELISTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND SHARING YOUR WISDOM
WITH THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT I WILL BRING UP
NOW- GINGER CLARK. PROFESSOR OF
CLINICAL EDUCATION THE ROGERS
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION ASSOCIATE
VICE PROVOST FOR ACADEMIC AND
FACULTY AFFAIRS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND SHE IS FROM THE
LOS ANGELES REMOTE ACCESS
STATION. A PROFESSOR CLARK
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH
US. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME I'M I'M
REPRESENTING U. S. C. AS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
UNIVERSITIES AND I WEAR A FEW
DIFFERENT HATS AT USC AS YOU'VE
MENTIONED I AM I AM FACULTY IN
THE ROSSIER SCHOOL I TEACH IN
THE MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY
PROGRAM THERE I'M AN ASSOCIATE
VICE PROVOST FOR ACADEMIC AND
FACULTY AFFAIRS WHERE I DEAL
WITH. ISSUES RELATED TO OUR
PART TIME AND FULL TIME
TEACHING TRACK RESEARCH TRACK
PRACTITIONER TRACK AND CLINICAL
TRACK FACULTY AND THESE ARE ALL
OF OUR FACULTY WHO ARE NOT ON
THE TENURE TRACK. I'VE ALSO
BEEN LEADING USC'S TEACHING
EXCELLENCE INITIATIVE AND
FINALLY I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR EXCELLENCE IN
TEACHING. SO TO GIVE YOU A
SNAPSHOT OF USC'S CONTEXT USC
HAS ABOUT FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
OF THOSE ARE UNDERGRADUATE AND
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND OF THOSE
ARE GRADUATE. ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND OF THOSE STUDENTS ARE
23% OUR INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF
THE VISA AND TIMES ON
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE BEEN
ENCOUNTERING IN TERMS OF THE
SHIFT TO ONLINE EDUCATION. SO
IN TRYING TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING DURING
THE COVERED AREA WE CREATED A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INCLUSIVE
PRACTICES TO ADDRESS OME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT STUDENTS
ARE FACING. THE FIRST WAS A
POLICY TO RECORD ALL CLASS
SESSIONS AND MAKE THOSE
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS IN
THE CLASS. AND THAT WAS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS TIMEZONE
ISSUES- ISSUES WITH CARE GIVING
OR HOME ENVIRONMENT LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. OR ILLNESS. WE
ALSO OFFERED ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
EXAMS PARTICULARLY FOR
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS SO THAT
STUDENTS COULD TAKE EXAMS OR
ASSESSMENTS BETWEEN THE HOURS
OF. SEVEN AM AND TEN PM AND
THEIR LOCAL TIME ZONES. WE
OFFERED LAPTOP LOANER PROGRAMS
HOT SPOT PROGRAMS MANY OF WHICH
HAVE ALREADY BEEN TALKED ABOUT
IN SOME OF OUR OUR- COLLEAGUES
ACROSS THE STATE. WE ALSO
OFFERED HOUSING FOR SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO ARE CHALLENGING
LIVING AND LEARNING CONDITIONS.
AND WE OFFERED CLASS
ACCOMMODATIONS AROUND THINGS
LIKE THE CAMERA ON POLICY WE
ASKED FACULTY THAT IF THEY WERE
GOING TO REQUIRE STUDENTS TO
HAVE THEIR CAMERAS ON THAT THEY
WOULD MAKE COMMENDATIONS FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAD ISSUES THAT
MADE THAT DIFFICULT OR
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM. WE ASKED
FACULTY AS AS OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED TO BE EMPATHETIC AND
TO BE FLEXIBLE WITH THEIR
STUDENTS PROVIDING ASSIGNMENT
EXTENSIONS IF NECESSARY DURING
THE CRISIS. THE UNIVERSITY ALSO
HELD MULTIPLE EVENTS TO ADDRESS
RACISM AS IT PLAYS OUT IN THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC PERIOD. AND R. USC
CENTER FOR RACE AND EQUITY HELD
TRAINING FOR FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS ON ANTI RACIST
PRACTICES. TO GIVE YOU A
PICTURE OF OUR FACULTY WE HAVE
SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED FULL AND
PART TIME FACULTY. ABOUT FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED OF THOSE
REGULARLY SPEND TIME IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THE RESTER
RESEARCHERS AND CLINICIANS. OF
OUR TEACHING FACULTY ABOUT A
THOUSAND ALREADY REGULARLY
TEACH IN OUR ONLINE PROGRAMS.
WHEREAS THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED OR
SO TEACH PRIMARILY ON GROUND.
USC HAS OVER A HUNDRED ONLINE
CERTIFICATES AND PROGRAMS
PRIMARILY IN OUR MASTERS IN
PROFESSIONAL DOCTORAL DEGREES
AND VITERBI SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING HAS THAT ONLINE
PROGRAM SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. SO ABOUT A QUARTER
OF OUR FACULTY WERE ALREADY
PREPARED TO TEACH ONLINE WHEN
COVERT HIT. BUT I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
OTHER SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. I'M
ACTUALLY PART OF THAT 75% I
TAUGHT A CLASS ONLINE FOR THE
FIRST TIME THIS SUMMER. AND I
CAN TELL YOU IT TOOK ME ABOUT
THREE TO FOUR TIMES AS LONG TO
PREPARE FOR THAT CLASS THEM FOR
MY ON GROUND CLASS. EVERYTHING
WHEN YOU TEACH ONLINE HAS TO BE
VERY ORGANIZED AND PREPARED AND
PRE PACKAGED. SYNCHRONIZER
LIFECLASS SESSIONS SHOULD BE
RESERVED FOR ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT
OF STUDENTS IN THE COURSE
MATERIAL THINGS LIKE. GUIDED
DISCUSSIONS WERE GROUP WORKER
CASE REVIEWS. AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS IT INCREASES
LEARNING AND KEEP STUDENTS
ENGAGED AND IT PREVENTS THE
ZOOM FIFTY. LECTURE SHOULD BE
RECORDED AND VIEWED BEFORE
CLASS IN SMALLER CHUNKS.
FOLLOWED BY AN ACTIVITY WHERE
STUDENTS ARE ACTIVELY APPLYING
WHAT THEY'VE JUST HEARD TO HELP
MAKE THE MATERIAL STICKIER AND
TO HELP THEM REALLY LEARN IT
WHICH MEANS YOU HAVE TO MAKE
MULTIPLE RECORDED MANY LECTURES
AND CREATE MULTIPLE SMALL
ASSIGNMENTS TO FOLLOW THOSE
LECTURES TO BE VIEWED
ASYNCHRONOUSLY OUTSIDE OF CLASS
TIME. ASSIGNMENT DESCRIPTIONS
GRADING CRITERIA ALL OF THAT
HAS TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR BECAUSE
STUDENTS DON'TGET THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET
CLARIFICATION FROM YOU AS A
FACULTY MEMBER AS THEY WOULD IN
AN ONLINE OR ON GROUND COURSE.
SO THIS REQUIRED A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK. AND IT USUALLY
TAKES MONTHS TO TRANSLATE AN ON
GROUND COURSE TO AN ONLINE
COURSE. AND FACULTY EVERYWHERE
HAD TO DO IT IMMEDIATELY. OUR
FACULTY STUDENTS AND STAFF
REALLY ROSE TO THE OCCASION AND
I KNOW THAT OUR STATE AND
INDEPENDENT COLLEGE COLLEAGUES
TO THE SAME. THEY DESERVE SO
MUCH CREDIT FOR THE AMOUNT OF
WORK AND EFFORT THEY'VE PUT IN
TO ENSURE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION DURING THIS CRISIS.
UNIVERSITIES HAVE HAD TO ACT
QUICKLY TO SUPPORT FACULTY IN
MAKING THIS CHANGE A U. S. C.
WE PROVIDED FACULTY AND STAFF
STIPENDS TO HELP OFFSET
INTERNET COSTS. WE CREATED A
WEBSITE WITH RESOURCES TO HELP
FACULTY. USER LMS WHICH WAS
BLACKBOARD FOR US. TO PUTS
THEIR COURSE MATERIALS IN THEIR
ASSIGNMENTS. TO TEACH THEM HOW
TO USE THEM FOR HOLDING LIVE
CLASS SESSIONS AND MEETINGS AND
TO UNDERSTAND EVIDENCE BASED
ONLINE TEACHING PRACTICES. WE
CREATED WORKSHOPS RANGING FROM
THE BASICS OF USING BLACKBOARD
AND ZOOM. TO USING MORE
ADVANCED SCHOOLS TO ALLOW FOR
MORE DYNAMIC AND FLEXIBLE
TEACHING. WE CREATED A SIX WEEK
TRAINING INTENSIVE TO PROVIDE
SOUP TO NUTS GUIDANCE ON
GETTING COURSES ONLINE AND
PROMOTING HIGH QUALITY ONLINE
INSTRUCTION. WE USED TO CALL
COURT MODEL IN THAT INTENSIVE
PROMOTING FACULTY COMMUNITIES
OF PRACTICE SO THAT FACULTY
COULD MENTOR AND LEARN FROM ONE
ANOTHER. AND TO HELP THEM
PREPARE FOR THEIR SUMMER AND
FALL CLASSES. AND WE CREATED A
SELF STUDY VERSION OF THAT
INTENSIVE. ODD TO HOPE TO ALLOW
FACULTY WHO COULDN'T MAKE IT TO
THE IN PERSON TRAINING TO DO
THE SELF STUDY ON THEIR OWN.
FACULTY WERE VERY RESPONSIVE TO
THE TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES. IN
A TYPICAL YEAR OUR CENTER FOR
EXCELLENCE IN TEACHING MIGHT
TRAIN A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FACULTY SINCE MARCH OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FACULTY
HAVE ATTENDED WORKSHOPS CLOSE
TO A THOUSAND PARTICIPATED IN
THAT SIX WEEK LONG INTENSIVE I
MENTIONED. AND OVER FIVE
HUNDRED VIEWS THE ASYNCHRONOUS
SELF STUDY VERSION OF THE
INTENSIVE MATERIALS. WE'VE BEEN
MONITORING OUR PROGRESS AS WELL
SERVING STUDENTS AND FACULTY
THREE TIMES SINCE MARCH. ASKING
WHAT SUPPORT SERVICES LEARNING
TOOLS ARE WORKING WELL AND WHAT
ARE THEIR EVOLVING NEEDS FOR
SUPPORT. THE CHALLENGES WE
FACED OBVIOUSLY WITH THE TIME
FRAME THAT WE HAD IN WHICH TO
MAKE THE CHANGE THAT WAS A BIG
CHALLENGE. THE DIFFERENTIAL AND
FAMILIARITY AND COMFORT LEVEL
OF BOTH FACULTY AND STAFF AND
STUDENTS IN ONLINE TEACHING AND
LEARNING. A SMALL NUMBER HAVE
NEVER HAD NEVER LOGGED INTO OUR
LMS AND SO WE HAD FOLKS WHO
WERE VERY COMFORTABLE WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND WE HAD FOLKS WHO
REALLY HAD TO PROVIDE MUCH MORE
INTENSIVE SUPPORT TO HELP THEM
GET COMFORTABLE WITH THAT. WITH
THOSE TOOLS. AND THEN THE THIRD
CHALLENGE WAS CREATING SUPPORT
RESOURCES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
FACULTY AND STUDENTS
IMMEDIATELY AS THOSE THOSE
NEEDS EMERGED. THE POSITIVES
THAT HAVE COME OUT OF THIS FOR
US HAS BEEN A RENEWED FOCUS ON
TEACHING. THERE'S BEEN AN
UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITY TO
REFLECT ON OUR COURSES AND TO
AND ARE TEACHING STRATEGIES.
WHEN WE LOOK AT TEACHING OUR
COURSES IN A DIFFERENT WAY IT
REALLY FORCES US TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND WHAT KINDS OF STRATEGIES
ARE USING. AND HAVE THOSE BEEN
EFFECTIVE AND WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT KINDS OF TOOLS ARE
AVAILABLE TO US ONLINE
SOMETIMES THERE'S A BETTER WAY
TO DO IT THAN THE WAY WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS. IT'S
ALSO GIVING FACULTY A CHANCE TO
REVIEW. BEST TEACHING
PRACTICES. AND TO GET MORE
EXPOSURE TO ONLINE LEARNING
TOOLS. A BIG TAKE AWAYS FROM
THIS AND I'M SURE THAT THESE
ARE HAPPENING- AT OUR STATE
AND- INDEPENDENT INSTITUTION
COLLEAGUES AS WELL. IS IT
FACULTY AND STUDENTS ARE VERY
ENGAGED STAFF FOR SUPPORTING
THE WORK THAT'S GOING ON AND
LEARNING ONLINE IS WORKING.
FACULTY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SUPPORT FOR THEIR TEACHING WHEN
IT HAS VALUE. WHEN IT MEETS
THEIR NEEDS AND WHEN IT'S
OFFERED THROUGH MULTIPLE MODES
IN ORDER TO FIT THEIR VARYING
SCHEDULES. AND FINALLY THE
FLEXIBILITY THE ONLINE TEACHING
TOOLS PROVIDE ALLOW FACULTY
MORE CHOICES TO HELP STUDENTS
LEARN SO THE MORE WE CAN
SUPPORT THOSE TOOLS THE BETTER.
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU DR CLARK.
QUESTIONS REGARDING. I DO HAVE
A QUESTION I WAS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER. WITH A DOG FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS I SPENT- IN THE
CLASSROOM TEACHING IN THE
CLASSROOM I'VE NEVER ONCE. HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY OR OR NEED TO DO
ONLINE TEACHING BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS ABOUT TEACHING IN THE
CLASSROOM IS THAT YOU SEE THE
STUDENTS IN FRONT OF YOU. AND
YOU CA WHEN THEY'RE GETTING
SOMETHING WHEN THEY'RE CATCHING
ON AND WHEN THEY'RE NOT. I
THINK STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM
ALSO. PROBABLY AS OPPOSED TO
ONLINE- FEEL FREER YOU KNOW THE
RAZOR AND- ASK A QUESTION A-
TEACHER THE PROFESSOR BALANCES
DISCUSSION. OF MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE MORE
HESITANT TO SPEAK UP. TO SPEAK
UP. I'VE I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THOSE THINGS YOU KNOW CAN'T OR
DON'T HAPPEN ONLINE ESPECIALLY
IF IT'S A- ONLINE DISCUSSION-
YOU KNOW TEACH A PROFESSOR AT
INTERACTING WITH STUDENTS WHAT
WHAT WHAT CAN PROFESSORS AND
TEACHERS DUE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STUDENTS WHO MAY HAVE A
QUESTION OR THE STUDENT WHO'S
HESITANT TO PARTICIPATE
ESPECIALLY ONLINE DOES AND I
WOULD THINK THAT YOU KNOW FIRST
GENERATION A LOWER INCOME A
STUDENTS MAY. MAY BE IN THAT
AREA MORE THAN THAN OTHER
STUDENTS. THAT QUESTION THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I COME
FROM A FAMILY OF TEACHERS MY
SISTER AND BROTHER IN LAW ARE
TEACHERS AND WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN. IN ONLINE
TEACHING AND THIS IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT OUR FACULTY HAVE
TALKED ABOUT AS WELL. IS HOW DO
I GET HOW DO I GET A GAUGE FOR
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MY
CLASSROOM AND IT. IT IS A BIT
LIKE LEARNING A NEW LANGUAGE
YOU DO HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO
LOOK FOR THINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU
WOULD IN PERSON. WHEN YOU'RE
WHEN YOU'RE INTERACTING WITH
STUDENTS ONLINE. AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT YOU CAN BE MORE
AND ARE ACTIVE WITH YOUR
STUDENTS YOU CAN YOU CAN.
ORGANIZER CLASS SO THAT THERE
ARE MORE CHECK INS WITH
STUDENTS- AND FRANKLY I'VE HAD
FACULTY TELL ME AND I'VE HAD
THIS EXPERIENCE AS WELL. USING
THINGS LIKE CHAT FEATURES. OR
BREAKOUT ROOMS CAN ACTUALLY
ALLOW STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE
LESS IN IN PERSON CLASSES. AS
IT ALLOWS THEM TO PARTICIPATE
IN A WAY THAT MAYBE THEY
HAVEN'T BEFORE BECAUSE IT FEELS
A LITTLE LESS INTIMIDATING TO
GET ON A CHAT AND RIGHT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING TO SAY IT- VERBALLY AND
SO. THAT'S SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR FACULTY IS TO FIND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO CONNECT WITH
THEIR STUDENTS. AND FIND WAYS
TO ALLOW THEIR STUDENTS TO
ENGAGE IN THE CLASS THAT MAYBE
IS DIFFERENT FROM TRADITIONAL
ONLINE INSTRUCTION. CHAU FROM
HOW YOUR DISK. IT THE TEACHING.
AT USC YOU YOU YOU IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU DON'T THINK ANY. ANY
ANYTHING HAS REALLY BEEN LOST-
IN SHIFTING TO. TO ONLINE
EDUCATION. AS FAR AS LEARNING.
WELL I THINK THE TRACK. I THINK
THE TRANSITION HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR EVERYONE- BUT WE
ARE HEARING FROM FACULTY THAT
THEY'VE- THEY'VE FOUND NEW
TOOLS OR NEW WAYS OF DOING
THINGS THAT. THEY HADN'T
THOUGHT OF BEFORE SO WHILE THE
TRANSITION WAS DIFFICULT FOR
EVERYONE I THINK AND YOU KNOW I
THINK FOR ALL OF US WE WERE IN
A BIT OF. DENIAL FOR AWHILE
HOPING THIS WOULD ALL JUST GO
QUICKLY AND THEN WE'D HAVE TO
DO IT FOR A FEW WEEKS. OVERTIME
IS THE REALITY SET IN WE SORT
OF DUGGAR HEELS IN AND TRIED TO
FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE
MAKE THIS WORK WELL AND I THINK
OUR FACULTY IN AND IT SOUNDS
pHAVE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE REACHING
THEIR STUDENTS AND THAT
EFFECTIVE WAY. AND MY LAST
QUESTION DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE WILL BE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED. DURING THIS PANDEMIC
USING DISTANCE LEARNING THAT
WILL- CONTINUED AFTER THE
PANDEMIC. IN THE WAY WE TEACH
THE WAY WE INTERACT WITH OUR
STUDENTS. ABSOLUTELY I'VE- I
THINK- YOU KNOW AS I SAID
BEFORE THE FACULTY HAVE BEEN
DISCOVERING WAYS TO CONNECT
WITH THEIR STUDENTS ONLINE
THAT. THEY DIDN'T HAVE ON
GROUND. BUT THERE'S NO REASON
THAT THEY COULDN'T CONTINUE TO
USE SOME OF THESE ONLINE TOOLS
EVEN WHEN THEY GO BACK TO FACE
TO FACE INSTRUCTION. SO FOR
INSTANCE YOU KNOW ALLOWING-
DOING POLLING DURING CLASS. CAN
SOMETIMES GET A GAUGE OF
WHETHER STUDENTS ARE ARE
ACCESSING MATERIAL ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE MATERIAL LIVE
SO THAT YOU CAN MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT IN YOUR INSTRUCTION
IN THAT MOMENT. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF FACULTY
HAVEN'T HAD ACCESS TO BUT AFTER
HAVING ACCESS TO IT THROUGH
THEM. THERE ARE OTHER TOOLS
THAT YOU CAN USE IN FACE TO
FACE INSTRUCTION AS WELL SO
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE CAN CAPITALIZE ON
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED NOW. BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOT SEEN ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I
THANK YOU DR CLARK FOR SHARING
WITH US- THIS AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
WITH THAT I WILL NOW GO TO THE
STUDENTS. OF THE FIRST STUDENT
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT
SENATE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STUFF AND
COULD DOOR AND HE WILL BE FOR A
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM ONE TWENTY
SIX. SECONDS STUDENT IS EIGHT
IN. PARIS AUSTIN HAVE PRESIDENT
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
AND HE IS IN WITNESS VIA IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN STEPHAN
IF YOU'RE READY PLEASE BEGIN.
YES ALL RIGHT- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEDINA SURE MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION- COMMITTEE ON THE
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO I JUST
WANT TO START BY SAYING THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY. AS AS WAS
SAID EARLIER MY NAME IS STEVEN
COULD LOWER I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OR THE SS ECO WHAT I'M
PROPERTIES GOVERNANCE AND
ADVOCACY GROUP RECOGNIZED IN
THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS THAT REPRESENTS THE
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. YES
YOUR BILL HAS BEEN FIRST RIGHT
AND NEED IN MY DIFFERENT WE
HAVE ADOPTED LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES YEAR IN AND YEAR
OUT. TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
OUR STUDENTS. WE HAVE FOUGHT
FOR STUDENT FRANCHISE MADE
GETTING THE STUDENTS VOTING
PRIVILEGES WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR
STUDENT NINE PLUS ONE RIGHT.
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
ON CAMPUSES- EVEN ADOPTED AN
ANTI RACISM STUDENT PLAN OF
ACTION THIS YEAR. AS YOU ALL
KNOW THE CODE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
HARD ON A LOT OF PEOPLE. BUT
ESPECIALLY OUR STUDENTS. WE'VE
BEEN REACHING OUT TO OUR
STUDENTS DO TOWN HALLS. REGION
MEETINGS- AND SURVEYS TO GAUGE
THEIR MOST CRITICAL NEEDS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. STUDENTS
HAVE SPOKEN OUT AND THEY'VE
SPOKEN UP ON ISSUES THAT ARE
MOST IMPORTANT TO THEM. THESE
ISSUES INCLUDE BASIC NEEDS
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
ACCESSIBLE STUDENT SERVICES AND
EVEN STUDENT WORKER
OPPORTUNITIES. THE THING IS A
LOT OF THESE ISSUES WERE
ACTUALLY PRESENT CREE COVE IT
AND THE PANDEMIC IS ONLY
EXACERBATED THE- ALTHOUGH IN
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSES TRIPLE
C. I'M ALSO A STUDENT READ THE
COLLEGE. IN THE HEART OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I AM S. M. S.
STUDENT THAT IS EXPERIENCING A
LOT OF THESE ISSUES SO THIS IS
PERSONAL FOR ME. AT THE ONSET
OF THE PANDEMIC I AM A- THE
OLDEST OF FIVE CHILDREN AND MY
YOUNGEST IS THAT IS MY LITTLE
SISTER. AND SHE MOVED IN WITH
ME. SHE RECENTLY DROPPED OUT OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM SO
SHE COULD WORK FULL TIME AS A
HEALTH CARE WORKER SHE'S A CNA.
AT A LOCAL CONVALESCENT
HOSPITAL THIS IS ACTUALLY PUT
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY IN
JEOPARDY I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
TESTED WEEKLY FOR KOBE. BECAUSE
MY SISTER BACK IN JUNE TESTED
POSITIVE. BECAUSE THERE IS AN
OUTBREAK AT HER ADDED
CONVALESCENT HOME. BECAUSE
SHE'S IN A VERY VULNERABLE
POSITION. I'M ALSO A FATHER
THAT'S GOING BACK TO SCHOOL. MY
FAMILY WENT FROM A DUAL INCOME
TO A SINGLE INCOME BECAUSE MOST
OF MY SIGNIFICANT OTHER HAD TO
ACTUALLY QUIT HER JOB IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR FIVE YEAR
OLD WAS ACTUALLY DOING IS ON MY
SCHOOL WORK AND MAKING SURE
THAT HE WAS. THERE ANY CITIZEN
CLASSES. I'M ALSO P. TEACHER
FOR A LOCAL K. THREE SIX. AND
I'VE HAD TO HAVE FLUCTUATING
WORK HOURS THAT IS CONFLICTED
WITH MY SCHOOL SCHEDULE. AND IF
YOU THINK THAT- COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN AND PUBLIC COMMENTS
CAN GET OUT OF HAND. I WANT YOU
TO TRY TEACHING SIXTY
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS ON ZOOM.
YOU KNOW WHILE THEY'RE SHOWING
YOU EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE
IN THEIR HOUSE. MOREOVER JUST
FOR EXAMPLE- TECHNOLOGY IN
BROADBAND ISSUES. ARE ARE
EXISTING IN IN OUR SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW. THEY ARE REQUIREMENT FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS IN ORDER
CAN TO CONTINUE THEIR STUDIES.
BUT THIS RESOURCES IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS.
SPECIFICALLY AT MY COLLEGE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE FALL%
SEMESTER SEMESTER THERE WAS A
TWO WEEK WAITING PERIOD FOR ANY
STUDENT THAT WANTED TO GET A
COMPUTER WHY FIVE BECAUSE THOSE
RESOURCES WERE NOT AVAILABLE AT
THAT TIME. SO FOR THE FIRST TWO
WEEKS OF SCHOOL WE HAD STUDENTS
THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO CHECK
THEIR CANDIDATES. GOING TO
THERE'S CLASSES OR UTILIZE ANY
OF THOSE RESOURCES BECAUSE THE
RESOURCES WERE NOT THERE. I
ALSO LIVE IN A RURAL PART OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. OR
BROADBAND INTERNET. IS NOT
REALLY READILY AVAILABLE THERE
IS NO XFINITY. SATELLITE
INTERNET IS NOT FAST ENOUGH FOR
ME TO BE ABLE TO GET ON TO DO.
SO I HAD TO ACT ACTUALLY
PURCHASE A SECOND CELL PHONE TO
BE ABLE TO UTILIZE A HOT SPOT.
YOU MAY NEED- TO MY- PHONE
CARRIER JUST TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE MY STUDIES. OTHER
STUDENTS. THEY HAVE THAT. WITH
THE RESOURCE LIKE I DO AT THE
END THEY'RE IN THE SAME SHE
USES I AM. ANOTHER ISSUE IS
BASED NEEDS. WE HAVE STUDENTS
EXPERT PRUDENCE. HOUSE AND SIX.
AND THE RESOURCES EXIST FOR
THEM TO UTILIZE. BUT THEIR
RESOURCES ARE NOT AS READILY
AVAILABLE AS THEY WERE WHEN
THEY WERE IN PERSON. MY SCHOOL
IS DOING TWO DAYS A WEEK FOOD
PANTRY. BUT WE KNOW THAT
STUDENTS DON'T JUST EXPERIENCE
FOOD INSECURITY IS TWO DAYS A
WEEK. I'M FORTUNATE BECAUSE I
DO HAVE A JOB THAT NOT ALL
STUDENTS ARE AS LUCKY AS ME.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO- YOU KNOW.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THE
TWENTY DOLLARS THAT IT TOOK FOR
ME TO PURCHASE THIS JACKET JUST
TO BE HERE BECAUSE MY NORMALS
IN THE- WASN'T APPROPRIATE FOR
THIS MEETING. I ACTUALLY IF I
ALREADY EXPERIENCED THIS- IS
THIS PANDEMIC FOUR YEARS AGO
WHEN I FIRST CAME INTO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. I WAS ACTUALLY
COUCHSURFING FOR THREE
SEMESTERS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT I GOT MY STUDIES DONE. AND
I LOOK TO THOSE STUDENTS THAT
ARE IN THAT SITUATION NOW. AND
HOW ARE THEY BEING ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC. YOU KNOW
THE FOOD PANTRY I FREQUENTED
DAILY. I HAD TO GET YOU KNOW MY
CUP OF NOODLES MY MAC AND SHE'S
JUST TO BE ABLE TO FEED MYSELF
EVERY DAY. AND THEY'RE STILL
STUDENTS OUT THERE THAT NEED
THAT RESOURCES DAILY AND IF
THOSE RESOURCES ARE JUST NOT
THERE AS WE- EARLIER THERE ARE
STUDENTS THAT ARE BREAKING
LEASES SO I THINK YOU. SO MUCH
CHAIRMAN ENOUGH FOR BRINGING
THAT UP BECAUSE IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THERE ARE STUDENTS THAT
ARE DOING THAT ALSO. AND THAT
THAT HOUSING IN SECURITIES AND
THE- THE UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE FAT IS
PUTTING IT THAT MAN IS
INSURMOUNTABLE. I ALSO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE STUDENT SERVICES
WE HAVE ADMISSIONS COUNSELING
FINANCIAL AID EUROPEAN SDS ****
ALL THE STUDENT SERVICES. AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC
I THOUGHT THAT THEY WOULD
BECOME MORE READILY AVAILABLE.
AND OVER TIME THEY HAVE BEEN.
BUT NOW THAT THERE ARE STUDENTS
THAT STILL DO NOT HAVE
TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THOSE RESOURCES. TO BE ABLE TO
STAY. IN THE KNOW WITH ALL OF
THE SERVICES. STATE OR WHAT THE
SERVICES ARE NOW DOING IS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SERVING JUST
THOSE THAT HAVE RELIABLE
INTERNET. THE TIME TO TAKE OUT
OF THEIR DAY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. AND THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
TAKES TWO TO. BE A PART OF
THOSE. BE A PART OF THOSE
STUDENTS SERVICE MEANING. ARE
SO WORKERS. AS YOU KNOW AND
CUTTING DOWN ON ON JOB. AND DO
THINGS LIKE OUR STUDENTS
WORKERS WERE OF THE FIRST TO GO
AND I NEED. DOESN'T WORK FOR US
TO MORE. WHEN THERE'S LESS OFF.
NOW IN ONLINE AND BY. FOR IF
STUDENTS TO. BE WITH THEIR CAMP.
ANOTHER AND ANOTHER ISSUE IS
THAT ARE MEANT HEALTH IT. HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW REACHING AND
SAYING MENTAL IS THAT UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. AND IT ACTUALLY ONE
OF THE THING THAT THERE'S FROM
THE MOST IS THE LACK RESOURCES
FOR MEANT HEALTH. YES IF YOU'RE
BUSY CONDUCT A SURVEY THAT HIGH.
THE ON IS. AND OVER 65% OF THE
RESPONSES SAID THE STUDENTS
WERE- WE'RE SUFFERING FROM SOME
SORT OF MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES
BY THE TRANSITION TO ONLINE
LEARNING. THEY IT'S EXPECTING
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH. THEIR THAT
THEY'RE NOW IN ARE NOT SAFE
THEY MIGHT BE TO BUSY AND NOW
CLASSES IN SOME IN SOME INTO
CLASS ARE ACTUALLY GETTING
HARDER. TO GET THREE
COMMUNICATION CLASS WHERE YOU
KNOW IN IN WHEN I WAS TAKING A
IN PERSON I WOULD GO TO CLASS
YOU KNOW PARTICIPATE IN MY
LECTURE GO HOME AND PREPARE FOR
THE TIME THAT I NEED TO SPEAK.
OR WHEN THAT CLASS TRANSITION
TO ONLINE LEARNING I ACTUALLY
HAD A DISCUSSION BOARD POST
THAT WAS DUE EVERY WEEK AN
ARTICLE THAT I HAD TO READ AND
WRITE ON. AND THEN ALSO ON TOP
OF THAT SPEAKING- AND MAKING MY
SPEECH AND ACTUALLY HAVING TO
DO IT IN FRONT OF SOMEBODY ELSE.
THERE WAS. I CAN'T USE SOME
TEACHERS ARE ACTUALLY REQUIRING
THAT CAMERAS ARE TO BE ON. FOR
ME I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW MY
SCHEDULE DOESN'T REALLY ALLOW
FOR ME TO ALWAYS HAVE MY
CAMARON DURING OUR MY MEETINGS.
HI I'M A MULTI TASKER I CAN
ALSO DO MY SCHOOL WORK WHILE
BRUSHING MY TEETH AND YOU KNOW
COOKING FOR MY SON WHILE HE'S
ACTUALLY ON HIS- ON HIS CLASS
FOR HIS KINDERGARTEN CLASS SO-
YOU KNOW THE RESTRICTIONS FOR
CAMERA USE IT. IS SOMETHING
THAT'S THERE TO- FIND FINANCIAL
AID IS OF ONE OF THE LAST
THINGS I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT SET UP TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE TRUE COST OF
COLLEGE. WHY IS IT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THEM IS THE- CHEAPEST TUITION
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY THE MOST
EXPENSIVE OPTION BECAUSE WE'RE-
AS WAS STATED BYPASS BY CHANCE
OR NEVER AT EARLIER. NO LESS
THAN 7% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING CAL GRANT.
SAYS A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
NOT ACTUALLY BEING EQUIPPED
WITH THE RESOURCES TO GET
THROUGH THEIR- SCHOOL AND
GETTING THE FUNDING THAT THEY
NEED TO ACTUALLY GO THROUGH. I
RECEIVED- I DO NOT RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID AT ALL TO BE A
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM I
SUPPORT MYSELF THROUGH MY JOB.
AND I RECEIVED A ONE TIME DAY
CARES FOR GRANT FUNDING. AND AS
A CHAIR MEDINA SAID YOU KNOW
THIS IS BEEN A NINE MONTH-
PANDEMIC AND I RECEIVED ONE
CHECK FOR THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS- AND- AND THAT HAS HAD
THE LAST. FOR NINE MONTHS ON
TOP OF ONE ON TOP OF MY WORK SO
YOU KNOW OTHER STUDENTS ARE ARE
GO. THROUGH THIS WHOLE THIS
WHOLE THING ALSO SO. I JUST
WANT TO SAY CLOSE. I JUST ONE
TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR.
THIS HEARING AND AN AND
LISTENING TO US- AND EVERYONE
ELSE WHO CAME BEFORE ME I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE REMEDIES THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS- AND THAT
THEY WILL PROVIDE TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS SO THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR THAT PERSPECTIVE FOR OUR
TWO MILLION PLUS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS- LASTLY WERE
HAVING A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SATIATE. STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION. EIGHT IN THE
AVAILABLE. YES I AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA JR
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
A NURSE TOSSING HIM I'M A
RISING SENIOR MAJORING IN
GLOBAL STUDIES AT UCLA AND I'M
PROUD TO SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
THE OFFICIAL VOICE OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THIS LEGISLATURE
FOR ITS LEADERSHIP IN
PROTECTING STUDENTS FROM THE
MOST SEVERE IMPACTS OF THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES DURING THE
ONSET OF THIS PANDEMIC THIS
LEGISLATURE PROTECTED BASIC
NEEDS FUNDING STATE CAL GRANT
AID AND SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND THE
STATE BUDGET. AND AS WE
CONFRONT YET ANOTHER YEAR OF
PANDEMIC AHEAD OF US THESE
CONTINUE PROTECTIONS ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS EXCEPT
THERE'S ONE THING THAT STUDENTS
HAVE LEARNED OVER THE PAST SIX
MONTHS IT'S BEEN PASSED THE
CRISES WE FACE BEFORE HAVE ONLY
BEEN DEEP IN BY THIS PANDEMIC
AND IN ANY APPLICABLE COVERT
NINETEEN RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
WE ONLY BOLD SOLUTIONS TO THE
ACCESS. BASIC NEEDS BROADBAND
AND MENTAL HEALTH CRISES.
IMPACTING STUDENTS RIGHT NOW.
NOW I WANT TO SET US THE
CURRENT BECAUSE WE'RE MEETING
AT A CRUISE INFLECTION POINT IN
THE FUTURE OF ACCESS. FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. JUST A WEEK
AGO THE USE OF AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD. FOR THE ADMISSION OF
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS T
UC WAS VOTED DOWN BY THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTORATE. AND
INTEREST TWO WEEKS ANXIOUS
FUTURE UC STUDENTS WILLSUBMIT
THEIR APPLICATIONS AND
ADMISSIONS CYCLE TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN BY CALL BUT- WE ARE
ALREADY SEEING HOW THIS
PANDEMIC HAS PUSHED VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. OUT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO LOSE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
UC STUDENTS. BY NOT INVESTING
IN UC STUDENT ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AND EDUCATION
PARTNERSHIPS OR STATE PROGRAMS.
SET UP A NATIONAL LIKE YOU SEE
SCOUT VITAL IN PER. TENS OF
HIGH SCHOOLS WITH ACCESS TO THE
COURSE THEY NEED. TO SATISFY A
THREE G. OR- SEVERAL. STUDENT
INITIATED SAY POP. WHICH ARE
PROVEN TO BE OF THEM SUCCESS
WAYS. TO AND- UNDER A TO. IN
THE ABSENCE OF ACTION OUR NEED
FURTHER. TO BUILD STUFF SYSTEM
FOR ON REPRESENT STUDENTS. BUT
I YOUR COMMITTEES NOW EVEN MARK
YOU GET OUT TO USE. VERY FIRST
BASIC NEEDS ACCESS HIGH AND
THESE BASIC NEEDS. HAVE ONLY IN.
DURING THE DOWN. NEARLY ONE IN
THREE COLORS RED L. TO AND ONE
IN FOR NINE HOLE GRANT OF WHICH
ELIGIBLE. WERE BEING VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR ABILITY
TO MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. AND
THESE BASIC NEEDS CHALLENGES
ARE HEIGHTENED FOR DOCUMENT
STUDENTS OR INELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL FORMS OF SUPPORT. NO
GRATEFUL FOR THE ONE TIME FUNDS
IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET THAT WAS
APPROVED. TO PROVIDE AID TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ACROSS
THREE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. BUT THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC OF THIS PANDEMIC WILL
LAST BEYOND THIS BUDGET CYCLE
AND ADDITIONAL ONE TIME DOLLARS
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AID
ARE NECESSARY IN THE YEAR AHEAD.
ON THE GROUND. NEEDS PERSON
HAVE TAKE THE ROLE OF PANDEMIC
FIRST FIRST. MARSHALLING
SCARCER. TO UC'S MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. BUT THEY'RE
CRUCIAL WORK IS CONSTRAINED IN
ADDRESSING NEW AND EMERGING
BASIC NEEDS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THIS PANDEMIC.
BURKE STUDENT TRANSIT ACCESS IS
A BASIC NEED. FOR STUDENT
LEARNING ONLINE INTERNET ACCESS
IS A BASIC NEED. AND FOR A
PARENTING STUDENT CHILD CARE IS
A BASIC NEED. BUT UNDER CURRENT
STATE STATUTE STATE BASIC NEEDS
DOLLARS CAN ONLY NARROWLY BE
USED FOR ADDRESSING FOOD AND
HOUSING INSECURITY. EXPANDING
THE SCOPE OF WHAT STATE BASIC
NEEDS FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR AND
DO A LOT OF GOOD IN MEETING THE
NEEDS OF UC'S MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS DURING THIS MOMENT.
AND FAR BEYOND. AND ONE OF
THESE EMERGING BASIC NEEDS
WHICH STUDENTS ARE SPECIALLY
STRUGGLING WITH. OVER A YEAR OF
ONLINE LEARNING IS ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE BROADBAND
INTERNET. WELL PUBLIC EDUCATE
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN PROVIDING
STUDENTS. ACCESS TO NECESSARY
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE TO PURSUE
ONLINE. FOR MOST OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. THE STATE OF ALL LOW
COST BROADBAND INTERNET ACCESS
REMAINS ELUSIVE. HAVE YOU SEE
72% OF FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND 60% OF NON FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING ACCESS
TO RELIABLE INTERNET FOR THEIR
STUDIES I THINK THEY'RE DOWN
OVER A YEAR PERHAPS OF
CONTINUED ONLINE LEARNING.
ADDING TO THE EDUCATION TRUST
LAST OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND UC
STUDENTS AND OVER ONE HUNDRED
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- ACROSS
SEGMENTS HAVE NO INTERNET
ACCESS. AND WITHIN THE DIGITAL
CLASSROOM OVER ONE IN THREE
STUDENTS DON'T EVEN FEEL
CONFIDENT AND USE THESE TOOLS
FOR REMOTE LEARNING. A
STATISTIC THAT IT'S EVEN WORSE
AMONG LACK NEXT BLACK AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS. THEY CAN
STEP INTO A THE OF BY TWO THREE
THINGS FIRST BY WORKING WITH
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE REDUCED PRICE
CONNECTIVITY. FOR LOW INCOME
POST SECONDARY STUDENTS WITHOUT
A CAP ON SPEED. SECOND BY
INVESTING IN NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH AS PORTABLE CELLS ON
WHEELS TO CLOSE COVERAGE GAPS
FOR STUDENTS AND RURAL AND
UNDER SERVED REGIONS. AND THIRD
OF CONTINUING TO EMPOWER
INSTITUTIONS TO DISTRIBUTE
PORTABLE HOTSPOTS AND DEVELOP
LOCALIZED BROADBAND PROGRAMS
FOR THEIR STUDENTS SUCH AS THE
PROGRAM'S DISC DESCRIBED TODAY.
BUT BEYOND THE VISIBLE DIGITAL
DIVIDES THERE EXISTS A GROWING
INVISIBLE CRISIS AFFLICTING YOU
SEE STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. THE
GROWING NATIONAL STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. AT THE END OF
THE JUNE ACADEMIC YEAR JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL REPORTED THAT
ONE INFOUR PEOPLE AGED
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR.
SERIOUSLY CONTEMPLATED SUICIDE.
IN ADDITION 92% OF YOU SEE
STUDENTS REPORT BEING WORRIED
ABOUT THE EFFECT OF BEING
ISOLATED FROM THEIR FRIENDS
DURING COVERT NINETEEN. WELL
NEARLY 60% OF STUDENTS
NATIONALLY REPORT BEING WORRIED
ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF THIS
PANDEMIC ON THEIR MENTAL HEALTH.
ADDRESSING THIS CONCERNING
TREND REQUIRES US TO INVEST IN
PREVENTION AFTER. NOW MORE EVER
AND THAT'S WHY WE AS UC'S ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF UC
HEALTH'S PROPOSED STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH BUDGET REQUEST TO
THE STATE. THAT IS BEING
PRESENTED AT THE UC REGENTS
MEETING NEXT WEEK. AS YOU CAN
SEE THE SIX MONTHS HAVE NOT
BEEN EASY FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS
AND WE HAVE A LONG HARD ROAD I
HAD. TO RESPOND AND RECOVER TO
COVERT NINETEEN IN A WAY THAT
BEST SUPPORT STUDENTS. EVEN
WITH SOME OF THE BEST EFFORTS
MADE BY OUR INSTITUTIONS WE
NEED THE CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
THE STATE IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE DEEP BARRIERS. AND ACCESS
GAPS AMONG OUR STUDENTS. AND IN
THE COMING MONTHS UC STUDENTS
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR TO
BEST SUPPORT THE OVER ONE
QUARTER MILLION STUDENTS. IF
NOT IN PERSON OVER THE NEXT
YEAR BUT IN THEIR HEARTS CALLED
YOU SEE HOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE- UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PLUS STUDENTS. AND IN
APPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK AS
WELL. THAT CONCLUDES I DO NOT
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR EITHER
YOU NOR STEVEN BUT THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING AN INSIGHT ON
WHAT THE REALITY IS FOR SOME OF
OUR STUDENTS TODAY AND- WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
THE LAST. COUPLE YEARS ANYWAY
ABOUT THE NEEDS ESPECIALLY THE
COMMUNICATORS I WANNA SAY TELL
THAT TO STEVEN. AND SO WILL
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW COULD TAKE
THESE ISSUES INTO CONSIDERATION
WE- LOOK AT CRAFTING NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET AND IN LOOKING AT
HAD PUBLIC POLICY RELATED TO
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
OUR STUDENTS- WITH THAT WE NOW
HAVE- PUBLIC COMMENTS. WITHOUT
ANY OTHER MEMBERS HERE ASKING
QUESTIONS AS WELL WITHOUT
PUBLIC COMMENT IF WE HAVE
ANYBODY- ON THE LINE WE CAN WE
CAN KICK YOU OUT. IF NOT JUST A
REMINDER THE PUBLIC COMMENT
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE FORTY
TWO A TWO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN.
AGAIN THE NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS FORTY TWO OH TWO.
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN. DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
HAVE A GENTLEMAN ONCE AGAIN AS
A REMINDER IF YOU ARE. YOU ON
THE PHONE LINE TO WHICH TO MAKE
YOUR VOICE HEARD YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR THAT DO WE
HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT FROM
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM. HI MY NAME
IS KATHERINE MCBRIDE. I'M A
GRADUATE OF SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY. I'VE SPENT THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS IN CLASSROOMS AS A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER. FIRST I
WANT TO MENTION THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM THERE IS NO PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY IT'S AN OUTBREAK THE
VIRUS HAS A GREATER THAN 99%
RECOVERY RATE AND IS NO WORSE
THAN THE FLU. I AGREE WITH
GALLAGHER ON THE- IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING BACK TO IN PERSON IN
PERSON LEARNING THE CAMARADERIE
IN SCHOOL LIFE IS A HUGE PART
OF LEARNING PROCESS. THERE'S
GREAT JOY. IN THE IN PERSON
LEARNING I CANNOT IMAGINE BEING
A STUDENT IN THIS DYSTOPIAN NEW
NORMAL ENVIRONMENT. THERE'S
NOTHING NORMAL ABOUT DISTANCE
LEARNING OR EVEN MASKS AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING. THIS IS ALL
UNNECESSARY COLLEGES
TRADITIONALLY OFFERED ONLINE
CLASES THIS IS GREAT FOR SOME
STUDENTS EVERYONE HAS DIFFERENT
LEARNING STYLES. HOWEVER THIS
IS LEARNING IS NOT FOR EVERYONE.
FURTHERMORE THE USES AT A GREAT
A VERY LOW RISK OF COVER DEATH
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO LIVE IN
CONSTANT FEAR THIS MINDSET IS
FAR MORE UNHEALTHY THAN THE
RISK OF KOBE DEATH SUICIDE
RATES AVE SKYROCKETED IN THE
USE. TOO MUCH TIME AND MONEY IS
BEING SPENT ON COBIT PLEASE
STOP WASTING OUR TAX DOLLARS ON
THE PLAN THE PLAN DOWN MAKE AND
DON'T BE SURPRISED IF THE
MOMENT CONTINUES TO DROP. AT
THE RATE THIS IS GOING. THE
BECAUSE THE TESTING IS USELESS
AN INACCURATE. THE PROPOSAL
CONTACT TRACING OF VACCINES IS
SOMETHING YOU SHOULD NEVER
INCLUDING YOUR BUDGET. THANK
YOU MAY HAVE TO ASK YOU TO WRAP
UP THANK YOU. I USUALLY HAVE A
MINUTE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT NOT A
LOT OF ANY HERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE SO. IF YOU KEEP IT
INTERESTING I'LL BE SOMEWHAT
FLEXIBLE. SO TODAY WE TALKED
ABOUT BUDGETING FOR HER
EDUCATION RIGHT HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE MORE OF OUR MONEY.
THROUGH YOUR SUGGESTIONS
CORRECT HOW OFTEN DO ANY OF YOU
TAKE A STRANGER'S ADVICE ON HOW
AND WHERE TO SPEND YOUR MONEY.
SO HOW DOES THAT IN MENTIONING
HOW WE NEED TO DEVISE WAYS TO
MITIGATE JOB CUT OFF. FROM AN
ORCHESTRATED ECONOMIC CRASH
MAYBE WE COULD ACTUALLY EDUCATE
OUR STUDENTS. FUNDED TEACHING
KIDS HOW THE SECOND AMENDMENT
PROTECTS THEM FAR MORE THAN ANY
HOMEMADE FABRIC MASK EVER COULD
FROM ALLY. FIND TEACHING THEM
HOW TO GO AFTER IN FOR THE-
FIND THEM HOW TO READ THEM BACK
INSERTS. FIND EXPOSING HOW
INDOCTRINATED THEIR EDUCATION
REALLY IS. FINE TEACHING
STUDENTS THAT THEY DON'T NEED
TO SUFFER IN SCHOOL FOR YEARS
THEN IN THEIR FUTURE JOB TO
HAVE A PIECE OF PAPER THAT'S
JUST AS WORTHLESS AS THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION IS TO ALL OF YOU.
AND MAYBE FOR EXTRA CREDIT
LET'S BUDGET SOME MONEY FOR
TEACHING THEM ABOUT THE HISTORY
OF THE FEDERAL RESERVE THE
ROCKEFELLER FOUNDATION AND THE
ROTHSCHILD FAMILY. THANK YOU.
BUT. KEVIN MCCARTY YEP I
CONTACT. I WENT TO SAN JUAN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS YOU TOLD WHERE
TO GO. YOU'VE BEEN ON THAT
SCREEN THE WHOLE TIME. YOU
WEREN'T IN MY HUSBAND'S
KINDERGARTEN CLASS. I SAW YOU
TWO WEEKS AGO AND A HEARING AND
LORRAINE WAS HERE AND DONALD
WAS HERE BUT LOOK LOOK WHO'S
LEFT THING IS GONE LEVINE IS
GONE JOSE MEDINA IS GONE THERE
IT IS YOU WANT TO TAKE A SELFIE
OF ME. SINCE TWENTY ONE SHE
JUST SPOKE. THE CONSTITUTION
YOU WIPE YOUR **** WITH IT. YOU
LEGISLATORS ARE A JOKE. AND
WE'RE ON TO YOUR GAME. THE
FARMER TECHNOCRACY WE DON'T
CONSENT WE DON'T AGREE. THERE'S
YOUR EYES AGAIN. YOU ALL NEED
TO GO BACK TO MY HUSBAND'S
KINDERGARTEN CLASS BECAUSE YOU
LEGISLATORS HAVE LOST YOUR WAY.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE YOU CAN STILL
USE A PENCIL. SO MAYBE THERE'S
HOPE FOR THIS. THIS GOVERNING
BODY. IS IT ENTERTAINING ENOUGH
KEVIN MCCARTY BECAUSE THE ONLY
THING MISSING IS JUGGLING BEARS
ON ROLLER SKATES. AND THEN
SHARED SOME WE KNOW WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT. PARENTS WILL NOT
SUBMIT TO THIS. YOU WORK FOR US
THIS IS OUR HOUSE WE PAY YOUR
SALARIES. YOU HAVE TO WRAP IT
UP WE DO WHAT YEP. YEAH ABOUT
TEN MORE SECONDS- I HAVE MORE
THAN THAT KEVIN MCCARTY YOU DO
BUT NOT TODAY THIS IS MY HOUSE
AND YOU WORK FOR ME THANK YOU.
ARE YOU MY CONSTITUENTS THANK
GOD NO BUT COOLEY IS ALMOST AS
BAD AS YOU KNOW HOW IT WORKS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NEXT BAKER. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO ONE
ELSE ONE MORE. YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK. OKAY I WANTED TO TALK.
HE IS HE DOING WHAT YOU'RE NOT
OKAY YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE TIME
IS DONE YEAH I BECAUSE WE'RE
POLITE WE YOUR- RANGE. OKAY
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER PLAY.
THANK. TELL THEM WHAT. TO HI
PLEASE KEEP YOUR TO ESTIMATES
ABOUT NINETY SECONDS NEW GUYS
ALL HEAR ME YEP OKAY SO I'M
TALKING TO ALL OF YOU. INTO
ARAMBULA I'M TALKING INTO MARC
LEVINE. I'M TALKING TO JIM
PATTERSON I'M TALKING TO YOU.
KEVIN MCCARTY IF YOU WOULD LOOK
AT ME AT LEAST. I GUESS NOT
TODAY. ANYWAY I'M ALSO TALKING
TO PHILLIP THING PATRICK
O'DONNELL AND WHOEVER IS NOT
HERE IN PERSON. ACTING ON OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES. I
OUR. WITH OTHER SWISS ARE STILL
HERE IN THIS ROOM INFORMING YOU.
THROUGH THIS LETTER OF NOTICE
THAT WE INTEND TO HOLD YOU
PERSONALLY. AND COLLECTIVELY
RESPONSIBLE AND LIABLE FOR THE
ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS SICKNESS
AND ALL OTHER DAMAGES SUFFERED
BY OUR CHILDREN ELDERLY AND US.
AS A RESULT OF YOUR ROLE IN
FACILITATING OUR INOCULATION
DURING THE COLD AT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THIS LETTER OF NOTICE
WILL ALSO SERVE TO NOTIFY YOU.
THAT BECAUSE OF YOUR LIABILITY
IN THIS MATTER WE INTEND TO
TAKE FULL LEGAL ACTION AGAINST
YOU IN THE EVENT THAT OUR
CHILDREN SUFFER FURTHER DAMAGE
TO THEIR HEALTH. BECAUSE OF THE
ONGOING MEASURES ENACTED DURING
THE CALL THAT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. LIKE THE MASK
MANDATES LOCKDOWNS AND
INFRINGEMENT ON PERSONAL
FREEDOMS. YOU'RE TAKING THIS
COURSE OF ACTION BECAUSE OF THE
MISHANDLING OF HEALTH SINCE
MARCH OF THIS YEAR. THE CDC HAS
EXPRESSED THAT THE RECOVERY
RATE AFTER GETTING INFECTED
pVERY HOT IN THE NINETY NINE.
FOR NINETY NINE PERCENTILE FOR
YOUNGER AGE GROUPS AND THE
NINETY FOURTH FOR OLDER. OSHA
HAS VOICE HOW MEDICAL MASK EVEN
THE AND NINETY FIVE OR NOT
SUFFICIENT IN PROTECTING
AGAINST INFECTIOUS DISEASES THE
BLUE MASK THAT ARE OFFERED IN
STORES YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT I
AM- ON EVERY BOX THAT READS
THIS PRODUCT IS AN EARLOBE MASK
THIS PRODUCT IS NOT A
RESPIRATOR AND WILL NOT PROVIDE
ANY PUT PROTECTION. AGAINST
GOBERT NINETEEN CORONA VIRUS OR
OTHER VIRUSES OR CONTAMINANTS
THANK YOU GIVE ME ONE SECOND
HERE I'M RIGHT THERE WHICH YOU.
YOU HAVE TO WRAP IT UP OKAY TEN
SECONDS OKAY. THE GOAL OF THIS
LETTER IS TO NOTIFY YOU OF THE
LIABILITIES YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERLOOKING IN THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS WILL LIVE A
DIFFERENT REALITY OF COOL BUT
NINETEEN THEN OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS DO. YOU MCCARTY. AND
IT'S TIME TO LOOK AT ALL THE
NUMBERS AND THAT INCLUDES ONE
AND A HALF MILLION SACRAMENTO
COUNTY RESIDENTS WHO ARE ALL
AFFECTED. AT AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS NOW I HAVE MY LETTER SO
PLEASE TELL ME WHO TO GIVE IT
TO YOU CAN GIVE IT TO THE-
GENTLEMAN RIGHT HERE FUNNY
THANK OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY FOR EACH OF YOU
PERSONALLY PERFECT AND YOU YOU
DO MAN AND ANSWER THAT IN
FOURTEEN DAYS. IN THE WRITING
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REQUEST. THANK YOU SIGNALED
MORE TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S HEARING
THANK YOU.